KCell und Musicsoft freundlich präsent Windsongs 95, Musik zu kompüren. Windsongs 95 macht Musik einfacher und mehr fach.
Die Klamotten erlauben alle neuen Stereo-Komponenten und die aktuellsten Bios.
It's slow, and that's no lie.
So, nachdem ihr jetzt gehört habt, was ihr alles haben wollt, würd ich sagen, wollen wir gleich die Telefonnummern durchgeben, dass ihr Leute auch bestellen könnt. Ja, Scheiße, wo ist denn jetzt die Nummer? Opportunity-Mist, müssen wir uns doch wieder über langweilige Macintosh-Themen unterhalten.
Haben wir denn überhaupt was? Ich hör mich nicht.
Nee.
Hör ich mich?
Du hörst dich nicht?
Ja, solange ihr noch tun, kann ich ja noch die Lebkarte machen.
Also ich hör dich, Dennis. Hörst du dich nicht?
Also ein bisschen wenig.
Na, red vielleicht mal ins... Dein Mikrofon zeigt auch hier noch an deine Mitesser. Du musst das sozusagen.
Ich hab keine Mitesser.
Jaja, du bist ein Mitesser. Ihr wird nämlich gefressen, wie nix. Denn es hat sich wieder umgesprochen, dass Weihnachten ist. Bei den Hörern von Movamex, wir sind überschüttet worden geradezu, mit einer Flut von Lebkuchen, kann man eigentlich festhalten, oder? Also Keksen, Lebkuchen, also hier sind allein...
Und Liebesbriefen.
Und Liebesbriefen, genau. Hingebungsvollen, Devoten, warmherzigen Briefen. Ja, aber alles Jungs.
Die Briefe?
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, die Briefe sind alle von Jungs.
Passt nicht an unser Beuteschema.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schade eigentlich. Davon trotten wir ja eigentlich so als Tech-Podcaster.
Von Jungs?
Nee, das ist so, dass man einfach von Frauen was kriegt. Guck mal, DJs und so.
Ich glaube bei DJs ist das auch so, dass da im Wesentlichen irgendwelche... Hey, was nimmst du da für ein 38er, 45er...
Quatsch, die haben die Frauen. Ich sass ja.
Ach, glaub ich nicht.
Das redest du nur noch ein. Damit du bei deinem Computer-Hobby bleiben kannst. Aber wenn du mal geschnuppert hättest an der DJ-Welt, dann wärst du schon längst raus.
Da fällt doch nicht das Maul ein.
Ja, kannst du mir mal meinen Rechner reparieren?
Nee, es gibt auch tatsächlich Nerd-Gruppis, ne? Nee, gibt's schon immer.
Bei Hoge gibt's das schon immer, bei mir gibt's das mittlerweile.
Ja, das bin gesehen, aber ich hab bisher noch keine Lebkuchen bekommen.
Doch, wir haben da Lebkuchen.
Ja, aber jetzt drehen wir uns im Kreis.
Willst du jetzt Frauen-Gruppis damit, dass du Lebkuchen verlegst?
Aber wir haben immer noch nicht die viereinhalb Kilo Toblerone bekommen.
Oh, Toblerone haben wir noch im Kühlschrank. Warte mal kurz, hol dich mal kurz.
Die Sendung ist um eine Viertelstunde verschoben. Tim muss erst mal bis nach Hause radeln.
Also wer die Hoffnung gehabt hat, dass das eine schmatzfreie Sendung und kaufreie Sendung ist, der hat sich getäuscht. Hat sich getäuscht und schon sind die höher. Ich muss jetzt allerdings sagen, das habe ich mir hier nicht notiert, von wem die Toblerone ist.
Das ist ja fast viereinhalb Kilo.
Steht nicht auf diesem Zettel drauf. Was, was?
Das ist ja schon ganz schön fett, ne?
Wie was ist fett?
Kilomäßig.
Kilokalorien mäßig, meinst du? 124 Kilokalorien.
Wie viel Gramm sind das denn, auf 25 Gramm? Also einmal schief angucken, 124 Kalorien.
Das ist interessant, sie geben die Kilokalorien für 25 Gramm an, aber es sind 100 Gramm drin.
Das machen sie immer so, weil die es in Einheiten angeben müssen. Irgendwie so.
Immer noch müssen oder dürfen viel mehr.
Also nach drei so einen Lebkuchen bin ich jetzt aber auch echt satt.
Du hattest ja auch 40 Kilo Sushi vor, ja?
Das ist eine einzige Füllerei hier. Die Sendung läuft, ja, ja, ja. Es wird jetzt aber auch schon klar und bewusst, dass wir eigentlich keine Themen haben.
Haben wir Glühwein?
Also Themen sind auch für Schissner.
Ich dachte, wir machen jetzt hier so eine schöne Gadget-Empfehlungs-Sendung, damit die Leute nochmal so ihre letzten Macintosh-Päckchen für den Weihnachtsbaum schnüren können.
Wir können ja gleich mal ins Thema einsteigen. Ich leg einfach mal los.
Gleich ins Thema einsteigen?
Ja, wir haben, ich hab grad die Kommentare gelesen. Wir lesen ja jeden Tag regelmäßig im Stundenrhythmus. Unsere Kommentare, ist ja klar. Und da steht was, dass irgendwie Tethering mit iOS 4.2.1 nicht gehen würde. Ich steig jetzt gleich volle Bulle ein. Max hat schon nachgefragt.
Ich wollte noch vorlesen, wer hier was geschickt hat.
Jetzt muss ich auch schnell zu Ende machen.
Man muss sich auch bedanken irgendwie. Also wir haben ja, Thomas hat Dings geschickt, dann das andere ist namenlos und das andere...
Du müsstest jetzt eigentlich so wie der Muppet-Show sagen, Applaus, Applaus, Applaus.
Und ihr seid da die beiden oben jetzt auf dem Balkon. Steilorf und Waldorf.
Mirko hat von Bodensee die Leckerli aus Basel geschickt.
Aus Basel, da sind doch aber die Tobleronen, die dicken.
Ja, das kam auf. Das weiß ich jetzt, habe ich mir leider jetzt nicht gemerkt hier. Das tut mir leid, aber...
Aber er schickt das erst mal davon, ne?
Aber wir sind nette Spezialitäten und du willst ja unbedingt nur Toblerone, dieses Massenprodukt.
Genau.
Das andere sind auch Massenprodukte.
Vorher hatten wir Sushi, die wir irgendwie toll bestellt haben, mit diesem neuen Clicky-Service, das hatten wir auch mal erwähnt.
Aber dass du hier eine Woche für uns aufhebst, das Sushi ist echt nett von dir. Wer hat das geschickt?
Ach, das ist noch vom letzten Weihnachten. Aber kalt war es, oder? Aber hat geklappt mit diesem Kollektiv-Click. Fand ich immer ganz gut. Ja, wir haben jetzt Wochen und Monate lang haben wir versucht, hier irgendwie gemeinsam mal zu koordinieren, wie man den jetzt online bestellt. Und das ist ein totales Grauen mit diesen ganzen Online-Bestelldiensten. Keiner kommt mal auf die Idee, dass die Leute, die bestellen, vielleicht nicht am selben Ort sind in dem Moment, wo sie bestellen.
Ja, und selbst wenn, also wir wollen ja nicht 20 Mann vor einem Display hängen.
Genau. Und der eine hat dann sogar nicht funktioniert. Das war der von dem Laden selber. Da konnte man irgendwie nicht drauf klicken. Das ist echt unglaublich. Aber jetzt haben wir irgendwie den Lieferheld entdeckt. Und Lieferheld kann im Netz verteilt bestellen oder so. Wie soll man das nennen?
Ja.
Sharing. Order-Sharing.
Bestellliste.
Wir haben ein Bestelllisten-Feature.
Bestelllisten-Feature, würdest du sagen?
Bestelllisten-Feature.
Bestelllisten-Feature?
Bestellen.
Liste. Ja.
Soweit es sich schon folgt. Aber da ist ja der Multi-User-Aspekt so nicht drin.
Sammelbestellungs-Feature.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir langsam dahinten. Genau, so ein Sammelbestellungs-Feature.
Online-Sammelbestellungs-Feature. Ich denk mir weiter etwas aus.
Hamburg in Berlin wohnt, weil dann nur da läuft das, kann dann auch mal Meta-Held, Meta-Held, das wollte ich gerade sagen, Liefer-Held-Klicken. Da geht das. So, das hätten wir.
So, jetzt denn es. Darf ich? Halt!
Shit. Stopp!
Noch ein interner Kram. Wir haben... Also, aus Gründen, die ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann, gab es verschiedene Podcast-Feeds für Mobamex. Mindestens drei.
Podcast-Feeds sogar? Also, einmal natürlich den richtigen Podcast-Feed.
Ja, so alles, was bei Feedburner war. Es gab drei verschiedene Feedburner-Feeds. Und wenn ihr das hört, checkt noch mal, was ihr so abonniert habt. Beziehungsweise, da müsste jetzt eigentlich schon nichts mehr kommen. Eine Weile wurden die weitergeleitet, jetzt sind die irgendwie tot. Jetzt müsste eigentlich nur noch drinstehen, dass es der falsche ist. Also, wundert euch nicht, wenn das irgendwie leer ist. Einfach mal neu abonnieren im Zweifelsfall. Es hätte eigentlich alles automatisch umgestellt werden müssen. Ich bin mir bloß nicht so sicher, wie gut das geklappt hat. Aber wir haben jetzt alles auf einen Feed runtergebrannt.
Wenn ihr das jetzt hier nicht hören könnt, dann läuft doch was falsch.
Könnt ihr uns hören? Oje, ich glaube, es ist schiefgegangen. Ich höre nichts.
Jungs und Mädels. Dann darfst du aber nicht bei der Sprache auslassen. Du musst sagen Jungs und Mädels.
Was hab ich gesagt?
Jungs.
Ach, deswegen haben wir keine weibliche Sprache.
Ja, siehst du, die denken immer, du hast mir gar nicht zugehört.
Ja, das stimmt.
Weißt du, manchmal sind doch da Frauen ein bisschen ein.
Dann kann Dennis jetzt auch gleich wieder über Nerdkram reden.
Kann ich jetzt loslegen? Im Chat labern sie auch schon darüber. Da gibt es irgendwie Leute, die sagen, dass Tethering auf dem 3G nicht geht. Das kann ich jetzt erstmal nicht nachvollziehen, aber ich kann nur sagen, dass ich...
Auf dem iPhone 3G.
Ja, wo sonst?
Ich dachte mal, auf dem 3G-Netz.
Achso, ne, ne, ne, Entschuldigung. iPhone 3G. Aber ich hab einen Bekannten, der hatte auch...
Generell nicht, oder seit Neuesten nicht, oder mit dem OS-Update nicht, oder was?
Ist unklar.
Dass es überhaupt irgendwann mal bei irgendjemand nicht geht. Mit egal welchem Netz. Also redest du jetzt von einem bestimmten Fall bei einem bestimmten Netz?
Hier ist im Chat einer, der meint, dass auf seinem iPhone 3G das nicht mehr funktioniert seit 4.2.1.
Ah, seit dem OS-Update.
Können wir jetzt erstmal durchlabern und dann können wir nochmal gucken. Und zwar hab ich einen Bekannten, der hatte O2, so wie ich, hatte da auch irgendeinen Standard-Datentarif, mit dem Tesserang gehen sollte und bei dem ging's einfach nicht. Ich ihm gesagt, bei mir geht's. Er gesagt, bei ihm geht's aber nicht. Ich gesagt, alles klar, mach mal Folgendes, Folgendes und Folgendes. Er hat gesagt, hab ich alle probiert, geht alles nicht. Okay, dann hab ich gesagt, er soll mal komplette Backup, also er soll komplett löschen, neu aufspielen und sein altes Backup nicht einspielen. Dann ging's wohl erstmal irgendwie. Aber er hatte auch mit der O2-Hotline irgendwie da geredet und die meinten dann auch irgendwann, da würde es wohl mehrere Leute geben, bei denen es nicht funktioniert.
Bezieht sich jetzt alles auf O2?
Bezieht sich alles auf O2 und auf Tethering mit irgendwie iPhone. Und dann kam mir vor ein paar Tagen ein neues Carrier-Profile von O2 und dann war der Bug wohl weg.
Angeblich soll jetzt auch Visual-Voice-Mail damit gehen bei O2. Hat das schon einer ausprobiert?
Ich hab bisher, ich weiß nicht, wie ich meinen Anrufbeantworter einschalte. Also wenn ich jetzt den Button drücke, den Voice-Mail-Button im iPhone, im Telefon, dann komm ich auf dieses Visual-Voice-Mail-Interface. Das sieht jetzt so aus, aber das ist halt eine Schrinne.
Oh, stimmt. To retrieve voice mail, first set the password in greeting.
Wie, das kam bei mir nicht.
Wie, das geht jetzt?
Nee, das kam bei mir gar nicht.
Ich hab jetzt das erste Mal da drauf geklickt. Normalerweise rief er ja dann immer, wenn man da drauf rief, dann rief er ja sofort bei der Mailbox an. Ich mein, ich hab Mailbox vor Jahren ausgestellt.
So sieht's aus, die ane vernünftigen Leute. Ja stimmt, das ist bei mir jetzt auch da.
Also bei mir kommt das hier.
Das heißt, sie haben es mir jetzt wieder eingeschaltet?
Das heißt, greeting, speaker.
Sie haben es wieder eingeschaltet.
Und was heißt denn Password?
Und wie kann ich es denn setzen hier?
Jetzt muss ich mir eine PIN setzen.
Wie kann ich denn überhaupt hier und so weiter? Ich will auch.
Ich setz mir eine PIN.
Hören Sie weiterhin bei Mobile Max, wie die Moderatorin ihren Anrufbeantworter einricht. Erleben Sie das nächste Mal so spannende Themen wie Kühlschrank reinigen.
Voice-Mail-Award, try again later.
Genauso sieht es bei mir auch aus.
Aber hast du eine Mailbox?
Ja klar.
Also hast du nicht ausgeschaltet deinen Anrufbeantworter?
Doch, aber es gibt noch einen Fall, wenn mein Telefon aus ist, dann kommen sie doch drauf.
Okay, also du hast das noch. Ich hab sie komplett ausgeschaltet.
Dafür musstest du aber anrufen, richtig?
Ja, ich hab denen das gesagt, ich will...
Keine Mailbox.
Nothing, ich will nichts von euch hören.
Also ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich jetzt mal einen Anruf vortrage.
Der Grund ist schlicht und ergreifend, weil ich dieses User-Interface über DTMF erniedrigend fand. It's horrible, yeah. I wanna destroy, I wanna kill it. Und da hab ich's gekillt. Aber jetzt ist vielleicht was anderes. Ich tendiere dazu, testweise...
Das ist der alte Schalt für Voicemail.
Ja, damit ich jetzt auch mal ein bisschen für Future haben kann. Das gibt's ja schon seit drei Jahren. Ich hab noch nie damit gespielt.
Ich hab das ja schon als Telekom-Apfer.
Und wie ist es so?
Ich hatte vorher auch die Voicemail. Ich war ja früher bei O2. Da hatte ich die Mailbox auch ausgeschaltet. Und bei der Telekom hatte ich's einfach mal direkt angelassen, weil ich mir dachte, okay, Visual Voicemail, jetzt gucken wir mal. Und ja, benutzt sich cool. Die Leute reden mir auf die Voicemail. Ich sehe, wer drauf labert. Ich kann mir überlegen, trotzdem nicht abzuhören und sie direkt zu löschen oder zu irgendeinem späteren Zeitpunkt, weil mir langweilig ist, die anzuhören, und kann mir die dann selektiv auswählen und so.
Aber die verdienen auch so ein bisschen Geld, wenn man so eine Mailbox anruft. So ist es ja, oder? Der Call kostet ja auch Geld. Und es ist ja jetzt dann for free, wenn ihr diese Daten abholt. Ich hab gehört, dass Visual Voicemail über ein IMAP-Server funktioniert. Das sind eigentlich Mails, die da geholt werden mit Attachments.
Hast du das von jemandem anders gehört als von mir? Also ich habe das bisher immer nur vermutet, aber ich habe noch nie eine Bestätigung dafür gefunden.
Weiß ich nicht.
Noch schlimmer, ich habe noch nicht mal Leute gefunden im Netz, die sich fragen, wie es funktioniert.
Da muss ich doch irgendjemand finden hier.
Das ist diese Apple-Szene, weißt du, die hinterfragen das alles nicht.
Das ist bestimmt nur so ein App Store-Verfahren, dann sind Steve davon.
Und dann wird man gestieft.
Und hört die alle ab und dann ist alles...
Hört man gestieft.
Nö, es hat so ein bisschen, hat es ja schon so diesen Feel von so einem Imap-Folder.
Ja, ich meine, das ist naheliegend, oder? Ich meine, was soll man sonst dafür nehmen?
Aber vor allen Dingen geht ja die Voicemail nicht...
Also ich meine, hier fallen jetzt viele Dinge an, die man da auch nehmen könnte.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall ist es natürlich datenbasiert. Also wenn du im Ausland bist oder sonst wo, geht halt Visual, Voicemail nicht. Ja, geht nur in Deutschland bei mir.
Also, weil es über Internet geht.
Weil es wahrscheinlich über Internet geht und ich im Ausland immer Internet nicht an hab.
Also ich werde vorne mal ausmachen und du berufst meine Box an?
Aber das heißt ja auch, dass dann das Audio auch über Daten geht und das wiederum bedeutet, dass dann das Abhören deiner Voicemail-Box von deinem Datentarif abgeht. Und das könnte man dadurch überprüfen, dass wenn man jetzt sozusagen 10 Nachrichten hat und man spielt die sich jetzt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde lang mal vor und dann guckt man, wie viel Daten das Telefon vertragen hat.
So eine halbe Stunde, die werden doch hier raufkopiert und dann spielst du sie von hier immer. Ja, du kannst das nicht.
Dann musst du dich halt permanent anrufen, neue Nachrichten erzeugen, nichts anderes als Visual-Voicemail machen und dann gucken, ob dein Datenkontingent, dein Verbrauch hochgegangen ist.
Ja, das können unsere Hörer gerne mal machen. Wir erwarten das Ergebnis im späten Februar.
Das müsste dann auch über WLAN gehen. Klar. Klar oder geht?
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht. Ich könnte jetzt mal ja...
Und dann kann man es auch mitschnüffen.
Na, ich hab jetzt Airplane-Mode an und ich hab WLAN an.
Das gibt es jeder Beschwerden, dass wir schlecht vorbereitet sind.
Und dann gebe ich jetzt mal deine Nummer in den Chat und dann sprechen dir die Leute was drauf. Das ist ein Deal.
So, ne, hier sagt er, aber Visual... Also mit GSM aus sagt er, Voicemail ist currently unavailable. Also es muss schon Netz da sein dafür. Also GSM.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt auch deine schon übertragenen Nachrichten gar nicht abhören oder du hast jetzt keine mehr?
Er sagt jetzt, Visual Voicemail ist currently unavailable.
Stimmt, das hab ich ja auch, das hätte man total einfach machen können.
Und das, obwohl du schon welche noch hattest, die du noch nicht gelöscht hast.
Also ich komm gar nicht an das Interface ran. Das würde ja dann...
Ich bin gerade dagegen sprechen, ne?
Ich bin gerade im Flugmodus und hab aber WLAN an und kann trotzdem keine Nachrichten abrufen.
Ich auch gerade.
Hier ist ein Typ, Juli2007, der meint, Visual Voicemail ist really audio IMAP.
Ja, das war ja auch meine Vermutung.
Aber dann nur über GSM?
Ja, aber ist das in einem technischen Sinne?
Vielleicht, weil sie die Notifications über das GSM-Netzwerk voraussetzen.
Oder das mit der Nummer authentifizieren, keine Ahnung.
Das ist wirklich unklar. Wer mit sicher ist, könnte es eigentlich auch verschlüsseln. Black funktioniert ja auch per MMS, guck mal. Dann wäre es auch alles total logisch, warum es auch nicht geht.
Ich meine, so Voice. Müssen wir jetzt mal so ein komplexes Musikstück von Bach auf die Voice-Mail tun?
Ich glaube, da bleibt eh nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Also so ein bisschen rechtsscheinig gehabt zu haben, aber so richtig hundertprozentig wissen tun wir es noch nicht.
Es gibt doch hier so Mitarbeiter bei so Unternehmen, die uns auch hören und die das vielleicht genau wissen.
Die das mal für uns recherchieren können, nicht dabei so zu Weihnachten.
Ja, wie wärs denn damit?
Zur Nutze sogar Vodafone-Mitarbeiter.
Und warum macht Auto noch keine Werbung, dass das irgendwie mit Visual-Voice-Mail funktioniert?
Weil Visual-Voice-Mail als der langweiligsten Feature überhaupt ist.
Das sind sie nicht überhaupt nicht. Aber ich finde damit Voice-Mail, also Mailbox, tatsächlich überhaupt erstmal benutzbar. Haben das überhaupt irgendwelche anderen Leute? Oder gibt es das nur auf Apple?
Ich glaube, das gibt es nur bei Apple.
Das gibt es nur beim iPhone. Bei Android gibt es das nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, nein.
Müssen die immer noch anrufen, die Voice-Mailbox?
Bei Google, bei Google, Google Voice geht es. Was heißt das, dass es da geht, bei Google Voice, also dass es dann über Voip oder was?
Nee, Google Voice ist ja kein Voip, sondern es ist ja einfach nur so ein Telefonnummernverteildienst.
Max, du musst die Schmatz-Taste drücken.
Ah, die Schmatz-Taste.
Stimmt. Gib mir lieber so ein Lebkuchen und hör auf zu essen, während du redest.
Hat man doch schon mal letztes Mal erzählt, dass du kriegst eine Telefonnummer, dann stinkt normal und die ruten es dann auf deine andere Telefonnummer.
Ja gut, aber sie nehmen auch für dich Voice-Mail an. Genau, du hast da auch einen Anruf-Beantworter, und dann musst du die ja auch irgendwie abhören.
Über ein Web-Interface.
Also du stellst wohl alle langsam um und bis zum 17. soll fertig umgestellt sein.
Ja, okay, das Datum hab ich auch gehört.
Bis zum 17.
Ich hab am 18.
Kurz vor Weihnachten. Kurz bevor, am 18. sind wahrscheinlich alle im Urlaub. Deswegen muss es bis zum 17. fertig sein, ob es dann auch wirklich überall funktioniert ist, wenn wir dann sehen. Okay, scheint aber so zu sein. Ja, war's das?
Schon hier steht 8.
Haben wir noch ein Thema?
Noch 2.
Es ist nichts passiert, oder? Ist irgendwas, nennst du, dass es passiert ist?
So eine Google-App wurde im iPhone zugelassen.
Und irgendeine App wurde im Mac-Store nicht zugelassen.
Ja, das stimmt, dieser Google-Latitude ist ja gerade freigeschaltet worden. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab das mit Freude benutzt jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen. Wieder ein cooles Familien-Feature.
Ich hab ja noch keine...
Ich hab da vorher mal Latitude genommen, oder wie das heißt. Aber Latitude ist echt besser, das Offizielle. Ja, davon riech ich doch. Es gab vorher schon... Man konnte ja vorher das Web-Interface nutzen. Das war ja ganz okay.
Ja, aber das ist ja sinnlos, weil du hast keine App, die im Hintergrund deine Positionen akzeptiert.
Und da hab ich Latitude genommen. Und Latitude gibt's da auch noch. Latitude, genau, wie der Dude. I'm the Latitude.
Es gibt ja auch Google Goggles und Goggles, ne? Und Goggles ist ein anderes Interface für Goggles. Aber eigentlich sogar schlechter. Aber ich könnte ja auch mal über ein tolles Tool berichten, was ich gefunden hab.
Tak, ich mein gerade im Chat, dass ich schon vor 80 Monaten von Latitude geschwärmt hätte. Wahrscheinlich als irgendwie bei...
Als der offizielle Google Fanboy?
Stimmt, ich bin nicht der offizielle Google Fanboy. Ich nutze ja jetzt auch noch Valve. Nein, mach ich nicht.
Wobei mich Latitude total fertig gemacht hat. Ich hab dann von verschiedenen Leuten... Also ich hab ja bei so Geodiensten und so bei bidirektionalen Social Networks hab ich ja so eine totale, mega harte Friendship Policy. Also so Leute, die ich nicht kenne, die kommen dann sozusagen auch nie rein und so. Also ist halt was so, damit für mich der Dienst irgendwie noch benutzbar... Ja, was soll ich mit so einer 5000, bei Game Center ist das ja noch irgendwie lustig, aber bei einem Dienst, der einem potenziell ja vielleicht auch noch mal irgendwas nutzen kann, ist es für mich ein bisschen sinnlos, mit Leuten zu kommunizieren. Und bei Geo bin ich da halt nochmal besonders sensitiv, deswegen suche ich mir das sozusagen aus, also eine sehr kleine Testgruppe, die daran teilnimmt. Aber es ist halt super für den Familienbedarf, das ist wirklich cool.
Aber was macht man denn damit genau? Sagt man damit nicht, ich bin gerade da?
Man macht es automatisch.
Na wer ist zum Beispiel näher dran, am Kindergarten Kitzaps holen?
So wie beim Skat oder wie, wo man den anderen so überbieten kann. Oder Unterbieten.
Du sitzt ja schon in der S-Bahn. Dann kann ich den Job ja mal übertragen. Dafür ist es cool. Und jetzt war ich halt auch unterwegs. Also ich bin, was weiß ich hier, wieder da im Start. München, tralala, im Zug und so. Und das aktuelle sitze ich halt irgendwie halbwegs. Also nicht, dass das jetzt früher schon immer gefehlt hat, aber so ist es.
Kann man machen.
Kann man machen und kann Spaß haben damit. Und irgendwann kommt man dann eben auf so Ideen, was man daraus mal machen könnte. Also ich finde jetzt Latitude eigentlich ganz okay.
Man muss das jetzt nicht benutzen oder so, aber ich als der offizielle Google-Fanboy kann jetzt auch was hinweisen, was gerade eben gestartet ist vor wenigen Minuten.
Oh, Late Break, haben wir dazu überhaupt einen passenden Jingle?
Nicht wieder der.
Der passt grad nicht. Ach, da fällt mir noch mal was zu dem Thema. Und zwar ist das so eine Erweiterung für Chrome. Also sie machen das jetzt auch wegen Weihnachten und so. Das heißt Chrome for a Cause. Und das ist für jedes Mal, wenn man einen Tab aufmacht, dann spendet Google was dafür. Zehnmal Tab aufmachen, was war's? Dann pflanzen sie irgendwo einen Baum.
Hast du schon wieder gescriptet?
Wir sind alle so gut. Einmal im Jahr sind wir alle gut.
Jaja, und ab 250 offenen Tabs kriegt irgendwo jemand ein jahrelang trockenes, sauberes Trinkwasser.
Echt? Aber ab 1000 Tabs, offenen Tabs, stirbt ein Kätzchen im Internet.
Und bei...
Ulloe-Kätzchen.
Das wird erdrängt.
Oder wird in so eine Flasche gesteckt. Das passiert ja immer im Netz, das wissen wir ja.
Ja, komm, kann man schon mal machen.
Wie heißt denn jetzt dieses tolle Spenden?
Chrome for a Cause. Das sieht ganz lustig aus.
Ach komm, kann man schon mal machen.
Wenn man Chrome benutzen würde, kann ich mal schauen.
Wo wir schon bei Google sind, da hab ich ja auch noch was hier. Google Earth, ne?
Ich hab schon 10 Tabs hier.
Google Earth hat Bäumchen jetzt.
Siehst du, die kannst du einmal pflanzen.
Ja, das Interessante ist, sie haben ausgerechnet mit New York angefangen und mit Berlin. Noch so ein paar Orte, aber ganz wenig.
Wie in Berlin steht schon, in San Francisco?
Ich bin heute schon den ganzen Tag in die Stadt gegangen. Überall Bäume.
Mit Schnee drauf, ne?
Die werden jetzt demnächst alle weggekattelt, weil die stören die Optik von Street View.
Welche Optik? Die verschleierten.
Man kann die Pixel gar nicht mehr sehen.
Ich finde das ganz gut, wenn sie die Bäume jetzt hier in unserer Straße rendern, dann hält der das den Vorteil, dass man die ganzen verpixelten Häuser nicht mehr sieht.
Die sind nicht verpixelnt, die Häuser.
In dieser Straße, da ist fast...
Soll ich dir das erzählen?
Weichgezeichnet. Ich poste jetzt das passende Bild noch mal in den Chat. Moment.
Pixel-Nerds hier von wegen.
Ja, das ist blö. Ich hab's ja auch erst gesagt, aber als ich da drauf gestoßen wurde, dachte ich mir, Gott, wie peinlich.
Was ist wie peinlich?
Naja, dass man dazu verpixelt, obwohl es offensichtlich nicht verpixelt ist.
Ich find den Begriff...
Ich find den Begriff völlig...
Weichgezeichnete Pixel sind auch Pixel.
Nein, ich find den Begriff verpixelt völlig in Ordnung.
Sagst du etwa auch schon der Block?
Es ist nicht gepixelt.
Es ist bei dir schon so weit gekommen.
Ich werd dir gleich die iPhone an den Kopf. Aber in unserer Straße sind die Bäume komischerweise nicht enabled. Es ist ganz merkwürdig. Die haben das nur auf bestimmte Bereiche.
Das geht ja ab. Alex, das sieht ja krass aus. Dieses 3D.
Das gibt's doch schon seit Jahren. Berlin ist seit einiger Zeit 3D.
Aber die Bäume sehen ganz cool aus.
Man muss jetzt mal hier ein bisschen mehr in die City reinfliegen. Da hast du dann so richtig Bäume.
Flieg mal kurz in die City rüber. Am Alex auf dem Platz, hinter dem Fernsehturm unter dem Platz. Genau.
Da müssen wir mal ein bisschen warten. Die Bäume brauchen komischerweise mal... Ah ja, da kommen jetzt die Bäume. Das heißt, die haben von oben so ein Pattern-Matching gemacht. Und sie unterscheiden auch zwischen großen und kleinen Bäumen. Zum Beispiel jetzt hier bei der... Guck mal hier, da gibt es kleine Bäumchen. Büschen.
Ist das cool?
Also es sind wirklich kleine Bäume, die immer noch so einen total dicken Baumstamm haben.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen albern.
Das sieht schon ein bisschen albern aus, wenn man ganz nah ran fliegt. Und sie wechseln das auch so randommäßig ab. Und ich hab auch so den Eindruck, sie haben irgendeine Detection, ob das jetzt ein dunkler oder ein heller Baum ist. Keine Ahnung, aber sie machen da einfach so ein random Filling.
Meinst du nicht, dass sie das mit Street View gleich mitgemacht haben?
Unsere Hörermann, du sollst irgendwie das eine Bild nochmal zeigen.
Welches eine Bild nochmal zeigen?
Ist egal, die können das alle gerade nicht sehen.
Ich versuche das mit meiner blumigen 3D-Sprache.
Mit der blumigen 3D-Sprache.
Ich pastee mal was zum Angucken im Chat in der Zwischenzeit.
Ja, fliegt einfach zum Alex mit Google Earth 6 und dann seht ihr doch diese Scheißbäume.
Berlin Alexanderplatz, gibt's auch ein Buch zu.
Und ein Film.
Das Buch zum Platz.
Das Buch zum Platz und zum Film.
Auf jeden Fall ist das alles hochgradig nützlich geworden, weil ich finde, durch diese Baum-Geschichte kriegt man einfach das erste Mal so richtig das Gefühl, was für ein Gefühl kriegt man denn da? Na ja, man kriegt so ein Gefühl von der tatsächlichen Begebenheit und vor allem Sichtbarkeit von Dingen. Die Bäume machen ja schon eine Menge aus, meistens.
Na ja.
Ja, schon schick auf jeden Fall.
Aber sie müssen da wirklich jeden einzelnen fucking Baum entdecken.
Aber die sind auch gut platziert, das ist echt gut.
Ja, ich tue mir leid, die Festplatte, die muss leider in Betrieb sein, weil ich da gerade einen Backup zurück spiele.
Ach, die ist so laut, verstehe.
Das kann sein, dass die nicht so laut ist, ja. Aber von der wird gelesen und hinter dir wird geschrieben. Du bist sozusagen eingeengt. Aber ich könnte da nochmal diesen komischen Ding von Beiz umzingelt machen.
Jetzt habt ihr gerade wieder hier so eine Themenpause, ne? Kann ich mich wieder reindrängeln?
Wir sind bei Google, ne? Also das ist jetzt sozusagen unser Fokus gerade.
Aber ich benutze ja kein Google.
Du benutzt kein Google, benutzt gar kein Google? Doch. Ein bisschen Google benutzen wir alle.
Wird wir nicht alle ein bisschen Google?
Ja, ein bisschen Google sind wir schon.
Aber ich halte es auf ein Minimum.
Wir sind für Google. Außer suchen nix?
Oh, ich benutze viel Google, um ehrlich zu sein.
Maps noch manchmal, ja.
Ich benutze Maps.
Was gibt es denn alles?
Na, hier fängt ja schon mal an mit diesen komischen, wo du das auf deine Domain registrieren kannst. Dann hast du dann Mail und Kalender und...
Genau, Google, das nutze ich.
Google Apps, das benutze ich. Kalender benutze ich. Benutze ich auch für Mobile Maps. Es gibt ja einen Kalender, wo immer unsere Sendungen drin sind. Wo ist denn das hier? Advanced, Bla, wie ist denn das hier mit More? Wo ist denn hier dieser...
iTunes Update.
Wie?
Großartig.
In diesem Moment oder was?
Das kann ich nicht mehr aufzählen. Also ich nutze nur noch Google Mail, Google Kalender, Reader natürlich.
Reader benutze ich sozusagen nur als Backend.
Ja, ich im Wesentlichen auch, aber eben so, um diese ganzen Features zu synchronisieren, ist das super. Was muss ich hier in den Chat?
Google Talk?
Google Goggles gehen ehendlich mal, aber total selten. Du hast doch hier erzählt, ganz stolz von Spracherkennung bei Google und so.
Ja, das benutze ich aber nur zu Showzwecken. Also das benutze ich nicht.
Also zu sagen, weiß Google jetzt, wenn sie diesen Podcast anhören, dass du das immer nur machst, wenn du gerade angeben willst. Genau das für die Werbung.
Wenn du bei Google Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2 eingibst, kommt Huckels Homepage raus.
Ach, YouTube benutze ich natürlich auch. Sowohl passiv als auch aktiv, das stimmt.
Ich habe jetzt einen Vimeo-Account, einen bezahlten.
Bezahlten?
Ich wollte meinen Blog-Besuchern endlich mal auch hier Flash-Free-Video und auch auf dem iPhone und so.
Ja, ich überlege auch, aber was kostet das?
60 Dollar pro Jahr.
Also 5 Dollar pro Monat.
Das ist schon Geld, aber ich dachte mir, die sind mir einfach irgendwie sympathisch als diese ganze, also das YouTube, also diese ganzen Google-Interfaces, die gehen mir total auf die Mütze. Und irgendwie bei Vimeo ist alles so schön und so.
Das stimmt. Aber warum die iPhone nicht einfach für alles?
Das verstehe ich nicht. Die haben halt nicht so viel Power wie Google mit ihren unendlichen Data-Centern und CPU-Zyklen und hast du nicht gesehen.
Na sie hat zwischendurch schon mal freigeschaltet. Das war der Moment, wo ich alles umgebaut habe auf HTML5 und so.
Na ich hab's jetzt bezahlt. Ich dachte mir, okay, ich supporte die Jungs mal. Ich finde das gut, was die eigentlich so machen.
Ja, finde ich auch. Aber ich hab da irgendwie fünf Videos oben.
Na ich hab ja vor, jetzt ein paar mehr rauszuschieben. Von daher.
Fünf Videos, das wäre irgendwie so ein Dollar pro Video pro Monat.
Na irgendwie ein bisschen zu viel.
Der Flashbacker funktioniert bei mir nie. Das ist, und zwar, ich muss immer auf die Seite zu dem entsprechenden Vimeo-Video gehen.
Den effect hab ich auch seit einiger Zeit. Das kann aber auch mit irgendwelchen blöden Unblockern oder so.
Das war zwischendurch, na das tritt in jedem Browser auf.
Bei mir.
Und das war zwischendurch mal weg und ist jetzt wieder da.
Na siehst du, jetzt kannst du meine Videos auch ohne Flash gucken.
So, mal gucken.
Was putze ich noch? Google Mail benutze ich. Aber auch eher so als Backend. Hab ich ja letztmal schon drüber geklagt. Docs benutze ich. Häufig. Also sowohl Spreadsheets als auch... Cooles Feature bei den Google Spreadsheets ist ja, dass du damit auch so Web-Formulare machen kannst. Und wenn du mal eben eine Umfrage starten möchtest, dann baust du dir quasi ein Formular in Google Spreadsheets und sagst hier, sammel mal. Und jeder, der das Formular ausfüllt, füllt quasi eine Zeile in Google Spreadsheets aus. Gibt schon eine Weile, ist jetzt wirklich nichts Neues, aber trotzdem mal wert, noch mal explizit erwähnt zu werden. Also wenn du jetzt so, keine Ahnung, 100 Leute, dieses und jenes, ich hab ja neulich mal hier so den User-Zuwachs bei Flatter und so, da hab ich das auch mal benutzt, wo die Leute halt eintragen konnten, ich habe einen Count bei Flatter-Seit. So, dann kommt das alles rein, dann hast du es halt gleich in so einer Tabellenkalkulation und kannst das dann halt auch gleich cool weiterverwenden. Das ist echt eine praktische Sache. Das ist ein echt schönes Feature. Da kenn ich nix, was dir ähnlich schnell sowas erlaubt und wo du das dann auch so gut weiter verwenden kannst.
Warum gibt es eigentlich noch keine Datenbank im Sinne von Google Docs oder so was?
Tja, sowas wie FileMaker, ne?
Eher sowas wie HyperCard. FileMaker mochte ich ja nie so richtig.
Der Unterschied ist ja nicht so groß zwischen HyperCard und FileMaker.
Das eine war eines der coolsten Produkte aller Zeiten. FileMaker auch. Und FileMaker ist eine schlechte Datenbank.
Da will ich aber echt wieder sprechen.
Ja, ich auch. Also es gibt Leute, die hassen auf jeden Fall auch FileMaker, aber es gibt auch Leute, die seit 10 oder 15 oder seit 20 Jahren super happy damit sind und alles tun können.
Also es gibt einiges zu hassen an FileMaker, aber es gibt auch nichts, was so ist wie FileMaker.
Nichts.
Das stimmt. Aber wenn die Daten einmal in FileMaker drin sind, dann kriegst du auch nie wieder raus.
Doch, die haben halt so ODBC und diesen ganzen Schwachsinn.
Das gilt aber für jede Datenbank. Du kannst Bilder per Copy und Paste reinpasten und hast eigentlich keine reale Chance, die jemals wieder rauszukriegen. Jedenfalls war das, als ich das letzte Mal so benutzt habe.
Wann war das?
Ich stelle mir eine ganze Weile her.
In den letzten zwei Versionen hat sich da auch ganz schön was getan.
Können die mittlerweile halbwegs so was exporten? Ich musste mal eine Zeit lang eine Feimeca-Datenbank für mehrere Leute. Ich habe im Endeffekt auf MySQL-Basis und PHP rasch dafür was geschrieben, was bis heute im Einsatz ist und so halbwegs funktioniert, weil Feimeca es überhaupt nicht gebracht hat. Es gibt nach wie vor keine vernünftige Multi-User-Variante, also dass man irgendwie über ein Web-Backend oder sowas, dass mehrere gleichzeitig das nutzen können.
Da gibt es doch jetzt dieses...
Feimeca-Server gibt es doch.
Ben, wie heißt es?
Auch Bento. Bento ist im Prinzip so ein Rewrite von Feimeca. Da haben sie es nochmal ganz anders aufgesetzt. Das ist so Mac OS 10 only. Das nutzt halt auch so die Mac OS 10-Datenbanken. Habe ich glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, aber kann ich ja auch gleich nochmal was dazu sagen. Aber zu Feimeca muss man einfach erstmal festhalten, Feimeca ist eine Desktop-Database. Und man kann sie von daher erstmal mit anderen Datenbanken so nicht in einen Topf schmeißen. Das ist kein, das kann man nicht vergleichen mit einem Post.
Mir ist klar, dass das kein SQL-Server ist, aber...
Ja, aber der große Vorteil von Feimeca ist einfach der, wenn du mal eben schnell eine Datenbank, die halbwegs komplex ist, auch so mit Tabellen und Relationen aufsetzen willst, da hat eigentlich der Normalsterbliche mit allem keine Chance, mit Feimeca ist das ein Klacks. Da sagst du irgendwie, wir haben ein neuer Rekord, irgendwie Layout-Modus, hier ein neues Feld da hinlegen, du hast sofort deine Eingabemaske, kannst du das customisieren, kannst du das irgendwie da in der Optik gießen, kannst du das rasend schnell durchsuchen, durchblättern, kannst du dir mal eben mit ein bisschen Maus hin und her schieben, kannst du dir deine eigenen Reports machen, das druckt ordentlich und auch sehr komplex. Ich habe den ganzen Kongress-Fahrplan, die ganze Kongress-Organisation, habe ich jahrelang mit Feimeca gemacht und es war einfach allem überlegen, einfach weil der Time-to-Market sozusagen so niedrig ist.
Also man kann sich schnell mal was zusammenklickern, da stimme ich dir absolut recht, das ist ein großartiges Feature und schade, dass es da, also sowas in der Richtung bräuchte man mehr, aber darüber hinaus, sie haben irgendwie, das war so die ursprüngliche Idee von Feimeca, das haben sie irgendwie mit Feimeca 1.0 gemacht und seitdem ist da eigentlich nicht so wirklich, also da ist was passiert, sie haben Relationen eingebaut.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber du hast nicht so, also Hypercard fand ich immer cool, weil Hypercard war für mich genau dieses gleiche Tool, das ist auch so diese Datenbank, Features im Untergrund. Und dann hast du da oben eine Scriptsprache drauf und kannst, also ich hab darüber Programmieren gelernt über Hypercard. Und bei Feimeca hast du, ich glaube nach wie vor, diese per Drag-and-Drop-Zusammenschieb, wir haben hier acht Befehle für dich und wissen nicht mal, was eine Viable ist. Das ist für viele Leute genau das, das mag für viele Leute genau das Richtige sein. Aber selbst Action-Skripte ist mittlerweile weiter, dass man da auch selber Skripte schreiben kann.
Klar, der Schwerpunkt liegt da nicht auf dem Programmieren. Von daher ist Hypercard und Feimeca schon noch was anderes. Sie sind bloß in ihrem Appeal ähnlich, als dass sie sich sozusagen wie Files, also wie Karten präsentieren. Und dass du da so durchblättern kannst. Das ist halt eine Ähnlichkeit. Es sind andere Sachen, das mit dem Server. Ja, es gibt Feimeca Server, ich hab versucht damit zu arbeiten. Das ist ein Schmerz. Weil es ist so übers Netz, na ja, es geht auch irgendwie übers Internet. Aber es ist nicht so die so...
Eigentlich, na ich glaube, es ist...
Wenn die Verbindung immer schnell ist und immer steht, dann ist es gut. Und wenn irgendwie was komisch ist, dann ist gleich irgendwas komisch. Und es kann halt nur online arbeiten, verstehst du? Also du hast keinerlei Replikation. Zumindest war das noch vor ein paar Jahren so, als ich mit Feimeca Server gearbeitet habe. Ich glaube, da hat sich nicht so viel dran geändert. Und das ist halt die große Schwäche von Feimeca. Das ist bei Bento meines Wissens jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anders. Und ich denke, an der Stelle lauert eigentlich auch eine riesen Opportunität. Und ich frage mich eigentlich, warum das noch keiner hinbekommen hat. Also so eine Desktop-Database, die so ähnlich wie Git einfach in der Lage ist, eben auch zu replizieren und dezentral zu sein. Weil das ist ja immer genau dieses Problem. Du willst deine Datenbank mit auf Reisen nehmen. Da willst du dann ein paar Sachen interfacen. Und dann connectest du dich halt wieder mit der Zentrale. Und dann möchtest du, dass das eben schnell da hinein repliziert. Aber eben hier nicht so wie mit Evernote, wo du dann gleich wieder so eine komplette Kopie so, oh, ein Byte von deinen 80 Megabyte war anders. Hier habe ich dir mal das eine hinten an das andere dran appendet. Und jetzt viel Spaß, die nächsten 20 Stunden überhaupt mal rauszufinden, was der Unterschied ist. Sowas geht natürlich nicht. Und Salmeca hat das einfach verhindert, dadurch, dass es einfach nur online ist, aber eben überhaupt keinerlei Replikation.
Lotus Notes, ist das nicht exakt das?
Lotus Notes hat Replikation.
Die haben jetzt hier diese ziemlich gute Replikation, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das ist so deren Kernfeature, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja.
So, der Typ, der die Lotus Notes Datenbank entwickelt hat, hat ja dann CouchDB entwickelt.
Genau.
Und Replikation war ja bei dem einen wie bei dem anderen ein Thema. Quasi nicht nur ein Thema, sondern eines der Kernthemen.
Das stimmt. Aber was da dann wiederum bei so was wie CouchDB fehlt, ist halt einfach der Desktop Appeal. Also, dass es wirklich auch so designt ist, dass mal irgendein normaler Mensch sagen kann, ich will jetzt hier eine Adressliste machen und jetzt will ich hier eine Liste von Personen haben. Und jetzt will ich sagen, jede Person kann irgendwie N-Adressen haben und dass es mit der Zuordnung hingeht und dass es dafür auch ein nachvollziehbares Drag-and-Drop-User-Interface gibt, etc., pp. Dass du aber trotzdem da noch mit einem Skript irgendwie rangehen kannst und das Ganze automatisieren kannst und dann Intelligenz schaffen kannst. Also, es ist schwierig. Es ist auch sehr schwierig da einen Fokus zu finden, wo man sich da quasi positioniert bei all diesen ganzen Features, aber es wäre halt mal nötig.
Also, ich hab mal vor ein paar Jahren angefangen, da wollte ich sowas wie HyperCard fürs 21. Jahrhundert machen. Das sollte dann CyberCard heißen, weil ich den Namen so schön dämlich abwegig finde. Und das wollte ich komplett. Das leider hat dann natürlich eingeschlafen.
HyperCard für das 21. Jahrhundert.
Genau. So kriegst du endlich gleich... Ach komm, HyperCard. Habt ihr jemals was in HyperCard gemacht?
Wenig.
Lange her.
Ja, genau.
Wenig lange her.
Das ist toll. Ich hab sogar X-Command und X-Functions dafür entwickelt. Weil HyperCard, die Fähigkeiten waren ja sehr begrenzt. Und dann konnte man...
Put the item into the bucket.
Put the item into the bucket?
Diese ganzen Apple-Sprachen waren alle so verbos.
Stimmt.
Bei Applescript hast du auch das Gefühl...
Cell-Application-iTunes-2-Set-Volume.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt Applescript. Das ist jetzt Applescript. Bei HyperCard war das auch im Wesentlichen so. Das stimmt schon, HyperTalk hieß das ja. Aber da konnten sie noch nicht so viel. Darum war das ein bisschen simpler und ein bisschen einfacher. Ein bisschen näher an der heutigen Programmiersprache dran. Weil HyperCard irgendwann immer an seine Grenzen geraten ist, habe ich dann irgendwann mal gelernt, wie man da für Plugins schreibt. In Pascal habe ich dann Plugins für HyperCard entwickelt. Die musste man dann kompilieren. Und dann musste man mit ResEdit, hat das dann so eine XFCN oder eine XCMD Ressource daraus gemacht. Und die konnte man dann in HyperCard schmeißen. Ich hab gerade einen Rätselmoment. Und dann, je nachdem, wie man die Ressource benannt hatte, konnte man unter dem Befehl, konnte man dann in HyperCard die entsprechende Funktionalität erzielen.
Da hätte er schon wieder einen 80er nehmen können.
Das war so Mitte der 90er.
Du bist jetzt auch langsam schon so alt. Mit Mitte der 90er kannst du jetzt hier über die Jungforschung reden bekommen. So einer aus den 90ern.
Aber krass, kaum sagte RessEdit, kriege ich gleich feuchte Augen. Damit hab ich mir meine Spiele damals irgendwie gecheatet und gekrägt, hätte ich mal gesagt.
RessEdit war super.
Aber RessEdit war, das war so ein Tool von einem anderen Stern auch irgendwie, ne? Und das kam einfach mit dazu, also das war ja ein offizielles Tool.
Ja, das war vor allem auch schon...
Dabei war es nicht, man musste sich irgendwo runterladen oder kaufen.
Na, das gab es von Apple, also es war ein Apple-Tool.
Ja, ja, das gab es von Apple. Na, es war ja dringend notwendig, ein Programm zu entwickeln. Hatte es ja sonst keine Chance.
Ja, es war auch alles, alles war irgendwie metadata galore. Also irgendwie alles war strukturiert und so und wo ja sozusagen die McIntosh-System-Ferne-Meute immer so kotzt, so mit irgendwie ja, ResourceForks und so, wozu braucht man denn das eigentlich? Das hat ja auch alles seinen Sinn und seine Vorteile gehabt.
Das war großartig, man konnte in die Programme reingucken und man konnte gucken, was da drin ist.
Das ist schon alles eine coole Sache, aber es ist mittlerweile echt Ballast, weil es hat sich irgendwie nicht so richtig durchgesetzt.
Sie haben es jetzt verbessert mit Mac OS X, mit diesen Packages.
Bundles.
Bundles, Bundles, genau, mit diesen Bundles ist ja eigentlich das wesentlich überlegene Prinzip.
Na nur, dass die Daten da halt nicht in demselben Maße strukturiert sind, dass du da jetzt mit so einem ResEdit ran gehst und dann siehst du alles, was da drin ist. Das ist halt die Aufgabe des Programms, das strukturieren. Na gut, da gibt es so ein bisschen...
Wieso, da hast du ein Dateisystem unten drunter.
Ja gut, aber es ist nicht ganz klar definiert, was es ist. Bei ResEdit hast du ja Code-Resources, wo dann...
Manchmal ist es ja auch gut, wenn was nicht so ganz klar definiert ist. Da kann man einfach lauter Zeug reinschmeißen.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Das war auch zu reglementiert. Und das hat sich ja im Prinzip eben auch nicht... Das hat er eben auch nicht überlebt.
Aber es war schön.
Die Chancen waren super.
Da konnte man immer die Bilder von Programmen auswechseln.
Also mein erster Computer war ja ein Mac. Hat man ja schon ein paar Mal.
Was ist denn für einer?
Na, ein Performer 6300.
Oh, ist ein Spätes.
Mit sowas einzusteigen und den Macintosh noch gut zu finden, das ist natürlich auch ein Wunder.
Ey, das war immer noch besser als Windows 3.11, C64 und Atari, fand ich. Da konnte man ja richtig... Was machen noch?
6300?
Musste zwar alle 10 Minuten Rebooten wegen irgendwie, wissen schon, Fehler minus eins oder so, aber...
6300, das klingt ja schon nach PowerPC.
Ja, war der erste PowerPC-Performer.
Power-Huckel.
Ey, 24 MB RAM, Alter, ja?
Das kriegt man ja nie voll.
Sowas konnten wir uns nie leisten.
75 MHz.
Hammer.
War ja noch vor meinem. Und die 24 MB hat sie auch nicht beim Kauf, sondern erst am Ende.
Ja, hat 8000 Mark gekostet, die Kiste. Ja, war richtig viel.
Power Mac?
Ja, das war mit Monitor und RAM.
Ach so, komplettes System dann?
Komplettes System. Ach, mit RAM?
No shit Festplatte und Alm.
Ja, das war halt so nach der Wende.
Und die Dastatur?
Das war aber schon lange nach der Wende.
Ja, klar, das war 95 oder so. Da haben halt irgendwie meine Eltern so gemeint, der will sie nicht einen Computer haben. Ich meinte, die sind alle doof.
Hattet ihr dann schon Strom im Osten zu der Zeit?
Dann hat ein Kumpel von mir halt den ersten Power-PC bekommen, den 601, hier den 6100 da.
Den hatte ich auch mal.
Genau, diese Pizzaschachtel. Und dann hatte ich mir, ich will auch so einen Mac. Und dann habe ich gesagt, doch, hier, Mami, Pappi, ich will doch einen.
Performa 475 dieses Gehäuse, ja?
Nee, quatsch, Performa 475, das war ja das LC-Gehäuse. Nee, nee, es gab noch ein anderes Pizza-Gehäuse.
Performa 475, das war das ganz flache Ding, was vorne so ein bisschen höher war.
Genau, und es gab den 6100er, das war ein größeres Gehäuse.
Performa 6300, oder war es sogar ein 200er?
6300, weil der erste, genau der.
Ja, das ist doch nicht die Pizza-Box.
6300 CD.
Aber ich sage ja, mein Kumpel hat den 6300er gehabt.
Ja, so sieht mein Power Mac 7500 aus, den habe ich immer noch zu Hause rumstehen.
Also 6300 CD gab es gar nicht in Europa.
6300 in Sold, dann habe ich einen 200.
Also das hier ist die, es gibt die größere Pizza-Box und die kleinere Pizza-Box. Den hier hatte ich, den 6100er.
Genau, und den hatte mein Kumpel, den 6100er. Und da dachte ich mir, okay, das ist ein Computer, will ich auch haben, bin ich zu Mami und Papi gegangen und habe gesagt, ich will jetzt doch einen Computer. Und dann haben die gefragt, wie viel kostet der? Und dann meinte ich, ja 8000 Mark. Dann sind sie aus dem Latschen gekippt, aber haben wir den trotzdem gekauft.
Und das hier ist die Original-Pizza-Box. Das ist der LC und das war dann die, das hier ist die 6100er-Pizza-Box.
Das ist ein deutlich größeres Gerät. Ich meine das andere, das flachere Vorbild, das kenne ich als Performa 475.
Es gab es, der hieß LC, dann gab es den LC2, dann gab es den LC3, dann gab es den Performa 450 und dann den Performa 475.
Der 475 ist dicker als der LC.
Aber mein Lieblingsmännchen ist immer der Quadra 700.
Der war ein MCI-Gehäuse. So hat sich der 475 angehört beim Starten. Und so der Todes-Chime.
Oh ja, da wusste man, das ist alles vorbei.
This is the end.
Dann kam der Sad-Mac auf dem Bildschirm. Die Leute kennen heutzutage nur den Happy-Mac, aber es gab auch einen Sad-Mac.
Den kannst du mir mal schicken.
Den Happy-Mac kennt auch keiner mehr.
Das ist ein schöner Intro-Jingle.
Fokus wieder. Eine tolle Applikation, die ich auf jeden Fall allen wärmstens empfehlen wollte. Mac-Tracker. Heute ist wieder ein Kollege damit überrascht, dass es dieses Programm gibt. Das gibt es schon seit 2001 und das ist extrem cool, weil das ist die komplette Datenbank von allen Geräten und Programmen, die Apple jemals gemacht hat.
Auf dem iPhone oder auf dem Mac?
Sowohl als auch. Es gibt Mac-Tracker auf Phone und Mac. Da gibt es eben das coole Feature, nicht nur, dass man alle Daten über seine Lieblingsalten Geräte sieht und welcher RAM da rein muss und was für eine Festplatte maximal reinpasst, sondern man hat eben auch den Start-up-Chime und den Chime, das sprich man so aus, und den Death-Chime von den alten Geräten. Das ist halt irgendwie ein total cooles Tool. Also für alle, die sich auch mal einen alten Mac auf Ebay schießen und so, kann man da prima vorher mal nachgucken, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht und ob man dafür überhaupt noch RAM oder eine Festplatte kriegt und so.
So, jetzt für die Weihnachtszeit kann ich ja mal empfehlen Welcome to McIntosh. Das ist so eine schöne Dokumentation über diese Zeit, mit Andy Herzfeld und so, über diese alten McIntosh-Zeiten. Und da ist ein Interview, ich hab leider den Namen vergessen, mit dem Typen, das hab ich ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, der diesen Start-up-Scheim, naja, machst du ja auch schon nicht, der diesen Start-up-Scheim erfunden hat. Und der hat wohl irgendwann, der hat den irgendwann mal erfunden für den Quadra 700, glaube ich. Und das war so, das müsste ja der gleiche, und dann hat es sich irgendwie so eingeschlichen, dass jeder Mac so einen neuen Start-up-Sound kriegt und der wurde dann immer dünner.
Also die haben schon bei Mac Plus angefangen und da klang das aber allerdings noch so hier.
Ich glaube die Zweier haben da noch etwas an. Nein, Macintosh 2.
Der Classic, auch so. Macintosh 2.
Der hatte nämlich ein 6820er Prozessor, nicht so ein lahm 68000er.
Ansonsten gibt es noch hier voll klore.org, da sind auch lauter Geschichten von dem Herzfeld und von Steve und all den Leuten.
Über Steve dann eher.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er auch einen Artikel gemacht hat, aber da können lauter Leute so wikimäßig Artikel aus ihrer Apple-Zeit einstellen. Gibt es auch als gebundenes Buch, glaube ich.
Das gibt es sogar, den habe ich auch schon mal erwähnt, vor Ewigkeiten, den Vollklore-Podcast dazu, wo die Geschichten vorgelesen werden.
Vorgelesen. Auch nicht von Steve.
Auch nicht von Steve, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, aber sehr gut vorgelesen.
Stimmt, das ist eigentlich ein guter Klingel-SMS-Ton.
Stimmt, man kann jetzt eigene SMS-Tons machen.
Kann man nicht.
Kann man nicht?
Eigentlich nicht, aber neue gibt es jetzt.
Ach, ich dachte, dass sie...
Aber du kannst jetzt pro User, also pro Adressbucheintrag einen SMS-Ton festlegen. Das ging ja vorhin nicht, da kam immer einer für alle.
Wir überschlagen uns gerade mit Themen.
Na, ist schon geil.
Na, geil ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das Wort, was mir als allererstes eingefallen wäre.
Das sagt man so, wenn man noch jünger ist.
Jetzt haben wir die Retroschiene aber auf jeden Fall ganz gut bedient, oder? Total.
Ich bin überrascht.
Aber was ich ja eigentlich, wie wir eigentlich drauf kommen, ich wollte nämlich mal so was wie Hypercard für heute. Weil es ist so eine Idee, also irgendwie, man hat natürlich, man hat irgendwo einen Server stehen, da läuft ein, meinetwegen CouchDB drauf, meinetwegen auch ein SQL-Server. Dann kann man so mit einem Cursor, indem man auf eine Seite drauf surft und ein paar Felder aufzieht, kann man irgendwelche Buttons basteln und irgendwelche Textfelder und dann kann man das Ganze programmieren mit JavaScript. Hätte ich total Bock drauf. Sollen wir jemanden machen? Macht das mal. Chet, mach mal dat.
Aber so ein Interface für so eine Mongo oder CouchDB zu hacken, kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Ja eben, aber wie gesagt, über JavaScript erweitern wir und im besten Fall dann auch irgendwie, dass man so gleich so eine Abstraktionsschicht schafft, dass man wirklich eine gute API hat, kann alles nicht so in Hölle sein. Ich glaube, es ist noch ein Markt, der wo noch echt Potential drin ist.
Okay, wollen wir jetzt mal wieder irgendwie in die Gegenwart hüpfen?
Das war die Gegenwart.
Ja, Tim ist ja hier noch in seinem Mischpult versorgt.
Ja dann erzähl doch mal.
Ja, ich wollte euch jetzt hier nicht über eurem Veteranengespräch unterbrechen und dachte, ich nutze das mal hier für so ein bisschen, um mir mal deine Analog-Hardware anzubucken.
Aber ihr seid schon fertig gerade, oder?
Erzähl, was hast du denn?
Ich wollte nur hier das nächste Thema aufbrechen.
Und zwar völlig jetzt einen Break. Es gibt so gerade News, dass irgendwie, hast du ja auch schon gelesen, die Open-BSD-Geschichte.
Ach, die nochmal.
Und zwar hat ein Typ, der, wenn ich was falsch habe korrigiert, nämlich, ne, weil ich erzähl mal aus dem Stegreifen, ist ja alles live hier, ne, ich hab hier nichts vorgeleitet. Hat ein Typ, der vor 10 Jahren mal bei Open-BSD mitentwickelt hat, dem Haupt...
Oh Dennis, ich hab dir den letzten Blattentwurf gegeben. Warte mal, ich geh dir den aktuellen Ausdruck zum Ableben.
Den Hauptmacher hier bei Open-BSD, diesen Theo der Rath, der auch sehr, wie sagt man, umstritten ist, oder naja...
Ist halt auch so ein typischer......ein anstrengender Nerd.
Ja, da sind manche mit dem nicht so ganz happy, aber er führt da seine Diktatur und hält dieses Open-BSD im Leben, was ja nun auch noch kleiner ist als FreeBSD und so. Also es ist ja echt eine kleine Gemeinschaft. Egal, jedenfalls der ehemalige Open-BSD, ja Mitarbeiter nicht, aber Programmierer hat jetzt nach 10 Jahren im Theodorat geschrieben, dass er damals beim FBI gearbeitet hätte oder für die. Und dass jetzt sein NDA abgelaufen ist. Also es muss ja dann so eine Art 10-Jahres-NDA gewesen sein.
Von 10 Jahren war die Rede, genau.
Genau, und deswegen meint er auch zwischen 2000 und 2001, das passt ja genau, dass sie für das FBI eine Bektor in den IP-Stack von Open-BSD eingebaut haben. Und dass sie doch jetzt bitte mal gucken sollen, jetzt fragen sich unsere Hörer natürlich, what the fuck hat Open-BSD irgendwie mit Mobile-Max zu tun? Ganz einfach, weil, weil was?
Airport, Time Capsule.
Erstens das und zweitens, weil diese ganzen...
Ah nee, das ist nette BSD.
Die ganzen, ist egal, diese ganzen BSD, die machen ja schon ziemlich viel Codesharing untereinander.
Das ist ja sehr destack-eitig, ne?
Genau, die komplizierten Sachen machen die oft nicht doppelt, wie so wie sich das gehört, und der Unix, was ich durchsetze und was gut ist, wird einfach kopiert, so gehört sich das. Und das kann also sein, dass dieser IP-Stack von OpenBSD auch in NetBSD drin ist und auch in FreeBSD drin ist und dadurch dann auch automatisch in Mac OS X mit drin ist. Das heißt, es könnte sein, mit einer geringen Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese Backdoor von dem FBI von vor 10 Jahren auch in Mac OS X drin ist.
Wenn es die überhaupt gibt.
Wenn es die überhaupt gibt und wenn die nicht schon längst auch wieder durch Reparaturen, Patches, Umstellungen irgendwie wieder wegprogrammiert wurde. Kann ja sein, dass irgendwann einer gemerkt hat, hier wird ja so ein bisschen über den Speicherrand geschrieben, weil irgendwie müssten sie sich aus einfallen, dass das nicht so auffällt beim FBI. Hat das irgendwie korrigiert und dann war es wieder weg irgendwie. Kann ja schon ein Jahr später passiert sein, kann letzte Woche passiert sein, weiß man halt nicht. Aber da werden die jetzt irgendwie forschen müssen und dann haben die ein bisschen Spaß. Aber könnt ihr mal sehen, auch Open Source Software, wo irgendwie alle reingucken können, da kommt einfach mal das FBI her, lässt irgendwie da Programmierer bezahlt oder bezahlt hat Leute dafür, die dann Open Source mäßig ein bisschen mitmachen, um da irgendwie Backdoors einzubauen. Also niemand ist sicher.
Fidel hatte ja irgendwie einen coolen Tweet. Conclusion, the mail to Theodor Rath came from Microsoft Marketing Strategy. Let's remember people, what Open really means.
Ja, bisschen spät, aber...
Wenn ich auch ein schönes bin, ja. Also, komische Geschichte auf jeden Fall. Bin ich sehr gespannt, ob die dann mal tatsächlich jetzt was finden, dann auch.
Naja, spätestens in irgendwelchen alten Versionen müssen ja noch irgendwelche Hinweise zu finden sein.
Ja, also ich mein, das wird garantiert jetzt nicht so super offensichtlich sein, weil die gucken ja schon alle auf die Comvits da irgendwie.
Naja, aber dieses ganze Kryptozeugs ist ja schon ganz schön komplex. Und da kannst du schon ordentlich was verstecken.
Ich meine, damals dieser Debian-Fehler, dass die nicht vernünftig initialisiert haben. Wie lange ist das jetzt her? Wie lange war das unerkannt drin?
Ja, es könnte auch so ein Job gewesen sein, weiß man ja auch nicht.
Theoretisch schon, aber das ist ja auch ewig lange niemand aufgefallen.
Naja, sag ich ja. Das hat ja einen Grund, warum die Leute alle lieber hier OpenVPN und was weiß ich nicht, alles mit für einen kleinen Krypto-Lösung kommen. Weil dieses IPSEC ist einfach mal scheiße komplex und deswegen. Genau, was in der Mail noch drin stand, ist, dass der Typ, also der, der für das FBI da oder für die gearbeitet hat, dass er auch meint, dass das DARPA, das ist hier, was heißt DARPA genau? Defense, keine Ahnung. Was war DARPA?
Advanced Research Program.
Und das D davor?
Und das A hinten? Jedenfalls die haben...
Defense Advanced Research Projects Agency.
Die sponsoren halt auch irgendwie Sachen. Es ist irgendwie so Military-based. Die wollen natürlich auch kryptosichere Verbindungen. Und die haben damals wohl auch bei OpenBSD irgendwie Sachen gesponsert. Und die haben dann ihr Sponsorship eingestellt oder ihre Förderung. Und der meint auch in seiner Mail, dass die wahrscheinlich von diesem FBI-Deal, weil die arbeiten ja mit denen zusammen, dass die von diesem FBI-Deal da Wind bekommen haben. Und deswegen erst mal ausgestiegen sind, weil das OpenBSD dadurch halt nicht mehr sicher war. Also haben sozusagen zwei Agenturen da bei den Amis ein bisschen gegeneinander gearbeitet und die DARPA hat sich dann zurückgezogen. Sag da, ob das jetzt alles stimmt, weiß man nicht. Aber wär es nicht so gewesen, hätte vielleicht OpenBSD mehr Sponsoren gekriegt. Und vielleicht würden wir heute alle OpenBSD benutzen. Ja, unwahrscheinlich.
Also es gibt ja jetzt sehr viel Hypothese.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber ist auf jeden Fall mal eine interessante Geschichte.
Hast du gesagt, was wir der DARPA zu verdanken haben?
Na alles. Google zum Beispiel.
Internet?
Weil das haben die nämlich vorher auch gesponsert und gefördert und gemacht und getan.
Danke, liebes amerikanisches Verteidigungsministerium. Was habt ihr euch da eingeborgt?
Kannst du eigentlich meinen Kopfhörer so ein bisschen leiser machen?
Ja, kann ich machen.
Dann müh.
Müh?
Wie macht die türkische Kuh?
Ähm, warte mal, eins, zwei, wo bist du heute? Du bist hier zwei. Jetzt ist es leiser.
Nee, irgendwie kommst du mir immer noch laut vor.
Das liegt daran, dass ich jetzt immer lauter rede.
Ach so.
Und ich das Gefühl habe, dass du mich nicht verstehst.
Nee, alles klar.
Ja, ich versuche hier die ganze Zeit, diesen Macintosh-Trecker da mit seinen Sounds irgendwie...
Einzuholen, spielen.
Hier direkt ins Programm einzuspielen. Versage. Aber gerade... Weil ich irgendwie... Ja, ich versage gerade.
Du bist immer noch nicht Herr deiner Technik.
Doch, eigentlich schon. Die Technik steht bloß gegen mich auf. Sklavenaufstand in der Metaebene. Sie begehrt auf.
Wir sind...
Jetzt hab ich wieder dieses Syncing-Problem hier mit Evernote, weil ich hier irgendwie auf zwei Computern rumschreibe.
Der Tim ist heute nicht so richtig konzentriert bei der Sache.
Nein, der ist nicht bei der Sache. Der ist schon in Feiertagen.
Hast du denn den nächsten Punkt für uns?
Ich bin ein bisschen krank und ich hab einen echt langen Tag schon hinter mir. Also... Na ja, mein Tag fängt auch um 0 Uhr an. Ihr wart ja so zuversichtlich, dass ihr das irgendwie alles schon irgendwie hier telmäßig bestückt bekommt. Aber ich hab noch einen Nachtrag zu Google Earth. Und wo Huckel gerade meinte, das sieht ja so cool aus. Das sah ja vor allem deshalb eben so cool aus, weil ich hier meinen coolen... Nein, weil ich meinen diesen geilen Space Navigator irgendwie da dran habe. Weil das ist ja irgendwie... Ich meine, wer schon immer mal mit Google Earth rumgespielt hat und das Gefühl hatte, dass das ja überhaupt gar keinen Spaß macht, da rumzufliegen, weil das irgendwie so schwierig zu navigieren ist, der sollte sich mal den... Wie heißt das Ding nochmal offiziell? 3D Connection Space Navigator zulegen, den es irgendwie absurderweise in einer Business und in einer Personal Edition gibt, wobei es sich dabei um die identische Hardware handelt. Nur um eine andere Lizenz, die du kaufst sozusagen. Das ist vollkommen absurd.
So läuft es heute beim Geschäftemachen.
Ich kenne kein anderes Hardware-Produkt, wo wirklich dasselbe Produkt mit zwei verschiedenen Preisen verkauft wird.
Grafikkarten. Wie Grafikkarten?
Na die gibt es einmal als normal, und dann gibt es die als...
Es gibt auch so...
Ja, aber handelt es sich dabei um die identische Bestückung?
Die gleiche Hardware, nur du kriegst halt dann einen anderen Treiber, also für diese Cut-Typen und so, und die kriegen dann Treiber, die halt genau rechnen und nicht so abstrahieren, damit es für Games schnell ist.
Und es gibt ein Oszilloskop, was ich ja einen aus dem Club letztens gekauft habe, das gibt es in 50 MHz oder 100 MHz, aber es ist die gleiche Hardware und das schaltet sich nur durch ein Setting oder... Also man muss nicht mal die Firmware austauschen.
Aber immerhin tut sie dann in dem Modus was anderes.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Das ist meines Wissens bei dem Teil nicht der Fall. Also es ist wirklich einfach nur so ein ich bin privat, deswegen zahle ich weniger.
Der Intel hat doch eine Zeit lang, haben die doch jetzt angefangen, dass man sich 3rd Level Cash nachkaufen konnte per Rubbelkarte. Also hast du dir einen Prozessor gekauft und der war dann relativ günstig und hatte irgendwie nur 1 MB 3rd Level Cash, dann konntest du dir... Dann konntest du dir ein Kärtchen kaufen und da war dann so ein Code drin und den musstest du dann irgendwie im Bios eingeben und dann hat er, ich glaube, auf 3 erweitert oder irgendwie sowas. Also, dass du wirklich, per Software, konntest du Hardware-Features nachrüsten.
Krass.
Da sind dann auch alle zu...
Aber so ein Chip direkt mit so Rubbel los oben drauf wär auch gut, ne? Rubbel den Chip.
Rubbel den Chip.
Das schafft dann auch mehr persönlichen Bezug.
Mit so einer Kinnik wär doch eigentlich Google Earth noch geiler, oder? So, stell dir vor, du könntest dann so...
Das ist gehampelt. Ich meine, Spracherkennung und Hampelsteuerung, da bin ich wirklich echt nicht von überzeugt.
Also Hampelsteuerung stelle ich mir ganz gut vor. Spracherkennung auch nicht. Das mag ich auch nicht, aber so.
Würdest du vor deinem Computer die ganze Zeit rumhampeln um irgendwelche Dinge dann?
Shut application.
Jaja, Spracherkennung ist scheiße. Wobei, beim iPhone nutze ich ja schon ganz gerne die Spracherkennung. Die Spracherkennung beim iPhone nutze ich schon regelmäßig mal. Und zwar, wenn ich irgendwie gerade keinen Bock habe, das Telefon aus der Tasche zu nehmen. Ähm, ernsthaft? Zum Beispiel, wenn ich auf dem Rad setze. Dann drücke ich kurz die Taste an. Also wenn man die mittlere Taste ein bisschen gedrückt hält, dann macht er ja Spracherkennung. Und um eine Telefonnummer anzurufen, reicht es im Allgemeinen.
Und was machst du dann da?
Dann sag ich einfach den Namen an und dann musst du sagen...
Aber musst du da nicht Mark Schwinde sagen?
Nein, nein, der sagt das...
Nur wenn er sich selber anruft.
Ich hab das schon 5 Mal ausprobiert.
Ich hab das schon 5 Mal ausprobiert. Ich hab noch nie irgendeine Erfolgserlebnisse gehabt. In irgendeiner Form.
Doch, doch, das funktioniert relativ gut.
Was muss ich hier drücken auf meinem iPhone?
Die Home-Taste.
Die Home-Taste, oder?
Einfach festhalten eine Weile.
Max Winde.
Anrufen. Sprachwahl ist im Flugmodus nicht möglich.
Boah, Recht hat er recht, genau. Zeig mal Flugmodus, Ben.
Was muss ich dann sagen? Gesichtszeit mit Max Winde, oder was? Max Winde anrufen. Das ruft er denn jetzt für eine scheiße Nummer an. Jetzt ruft er nämlich irgendeine scheiße Nummer an. 16222.
Ich sag einfach nur die Namen. Ich würde jetzt bei dir Tim Friedloff sagen.
Er hat irgendeine scheiße Nummer angerufen, die nicht Max Winde ist. Max Winde. Ich komm mir jetzt schon wieder so blöd vor.
Was?
Und dann läuft ja auch die ganze Zeit so ein Text vorbei, was ich alles erzählen kann. Wie heißt das gute Stück? Stand da gerade. Wanni, wie heißt das Stück?
Wie heißt das gute Stück? Also wenn das iPhone das beantworten kann, dann hat man es zuliebt.
Mehrere Treffer hat er jetzt gesagt. Nein.
Du musst das aber auch richtig ans Ohr halten.
Wieso ans Ohr?
Also ich mach das halt.
Das ist Spracherkennung, das ist Ohrerkennung.
Damit du reinsprichst in das... Ich weiß, ich mach das halt immer nur mit dem Kopfhörer. Und das funktioniert auch.
Max Winde.
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht so ergiebig.
Spielband. Jetzt ruft der irgendwelche Leute an. Das ist doch scheißdreck, das funktioniert nicht.
Im Chat sagt jemand Ruf vorsagen, das mach ich aber nie.
Ruf!
Das war ein Ruf vorsage.
Ja, haben sie nach Ruf übersetzt.
Ruf Max Winde?
Du hast jetzt gesagt, Max Winde anrufen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich sag einfach mal Max Winde.
Ich hab halt noch eine leise Behandlung.
Diana Mobil, wenn ich meine Freundin anrufen will.
Ich will jetzt...
Abzarschanfuck, du machst...
Ja, ich muss das... Ruf Max Winde. Jetzt ruft er irgendeinen Kinderladen an.
Vielleicht hast du auch zu viele Nummern einfach. Ja, nimm doch mal ein paar Nummern.
Dann gerade, wenn man viele hat, will man ja da Abkürzungen haben. Also das ist Dreck. Ich komm mir jetzt schon wieder so bekloppt vor. Ich sitz jetzt irgendwie so im Park.
Was?
Ruf Tim Pritlav.
What? Ja, ist auf Englisch.
Ich muss schon Call sagen.
Call Tim Pritlav.
Ich bin da auch noch nicht überzeugt.
Nichts vorher sagen und den Namen so sprechen, wie im Telefonpostell. Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, jetzt kriegst du solche Tipps mit. Du machst es falsch. Das heißt, ich muss mich an diese Scheißmaschine anpassen. Anstatt dass diese Scheißmaschine...
Du rick dich nicht auf!
Mach mal mein Kopfhörer noch ein bisschen leiser.
Das ist die Unterwerfung. Unter die Maschine ist das.
Das ist die Unterwerfung. Jetzt hast du mein Kopfhörer leiser gedreht.
Tatsache. Ich schalte das jetzt wieder aus. Das will keiner. Und dieses Rumhampeln will auch keiner.
Mach aus!
Die Spracherkennung nutze ich gerne mal.
Ich glaube, mein Telefon ist gehalten.
Er ratete über die Spracherkennung. Und Max letztes Kommentar. Also ja, die Spracherkennung nutze ich sehr oft.
Ich nutze sie ganz gerne.
Das ist meine Badewanne.
Das wird echt keine Weihnachtssendung hier. Schau mal vor, da spielt jetzt jemand unter dem Baum.
Ich würde dir nochmal ein Programm vorstellen.
Das ist gut, das ist was Pragmatisches.
Und zwar, ich blogge ja nach wie vor. Und ich bin jetzt von Tumblr auch weggezogen. Ich bin jetzt wieder auf Self-hosted-Wordpress erstmal. So als temporärer Übergang. Nicht so oft, aber jetzt mal die letzten zwei. Und auf jeden Fall dachte ich mir, dann wär's ja total ein cooles Feature, weil oft wollen so Leute zugucken, wie man so Seiten designt. Also ich weiß oft für euch jetzt wahrscheinlich noch nie die Anfrage kommen, aber ich dachte mir halt, wär total cool, du machst ein Iframe, wo die Webseite total ungestylt ist, also das Blog. Ich kode dann sozusagen live an dem CSS-Stylesheet auf dem Server und in dem Iframe wird das halt automatisch refreshed und die Leute sehen dann halt, wie die Elemente so in Place rücken und sich das Blog so innerhalb von zwei Stunden so richtig formiert. Ja genau, jetzt kam der nächste Gedanke natürlich. Eigentlich wärs ja cool, wenn die Leute dann auch noch meinen Editor sehen würden und sehen würden, was ich dann halt auch so genau da rein tippe. Und dann dachte ich mir, ok, Audio-Stream, das haben wir jetzt ja so langsam im Griff, und wie siehts denn eigentlich mit Video aus? Und kann ich einen Screencast direkt wegstreamen? So und jetzt dachte ich mir, ok, da hab ich ja auch getwittert, was gibt es denn überhaupt für Tools, um einen Screencast zu streamen? Genau. Und da gibt es nämlich nicht viel. Also es gibt halt viele coole Screencast-Tools auf dem Mac, ja, Screen, Flow und wie sie alle heißen. Aber keiner streamt. Und da hab ich ein Tool gefunden, das muss von einem Typen sein, der so VJ-Software vor allen Dingen macht. Und dieses Tool heißt Raster Grabber oder Window Grabber. Und die Seite ist halt auch sehr minimalistisch, und alle Tools, die er da so hat, die sehen auch sehr nach VJ-Zeug aus. Aber das Coole, was Raster Grabber macht, ist, du kannst einen Rechteck über deinen Schreibtisch ziehen. Und er exportiert dir ein virtuelles Kameradevice, was du in Quartz Composer, in QuickTime Broadcaster und überall nutzen kannst, als wäre es eine echte Kamera.
Kann das sein, dass das Grubber Raster heißt?
Oder Grubber, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht auch Grubber Graster Graster Grubber.
Grubber Raster.
Kann das so? Nee, Moment, ist das so? Nee, Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp. Ja, jetzt müssen wir auch nochmal gucken, warte mal. Anni hier, dieses doch von BlackOp, Grubber Raster, doch ja. Genau, diese Seite, wunderbar. Kannst ja dann in die Notes posten. Und da gibt es halt auch Window Grubber. Und der macht das halt für Fenster. Dann kannst du halt genau sagen, dieses Fenster soll jetzt ein Kameradevice sein oder der ganze Desktop. Und damit kann man dann natürlich auch eben das in den QuickTime Broadcast als Kameraquelle nehmen und dann wegstreamen. Leider ist es dann daran gescheitert, dass ich keinen Video-Streaming-Server so auf die Schnelle aufgesetzt oder gefunden hab.
Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt hier mein Chat-Fenster von, wie heißt das Scheiß-App hier?
Genau.
Also jedes Fenster, das ich hab, kann ich als Stream benutzen.
Genau, und du kannst halt dieses Device, was der dann emuliert, sozusagen, eben auch einen Quartz-Composer benutzen. Und das ist halt für die VJs natürlich cool, die Quartz-Composer sozusagen benutzen. Dann kannst du halt irgendwie irgendwelches Zeug, was auf deinem Desktop abläuft, als Videoquelle sozusagen benutzen. Fand ich schon ganz pfiffig so.
Ja, sowas wie Skype zum Beispiel, Skype-Video. Kannst du dir sozusagen über das Netz auch irgendwas reinholen oder einen anderen Stream holen oder so. Das ist nicht blöd.
Ja, und der hat hier nur noch so ein paar andere Tools.
Aber dein Window-Raster sehe ich jetzt hier nicht.
Das ist da drunter, das da, genau.
Grabber Window.
Und da kannst du dann entweder sagen, den ganzen Desktop oder einzelne Fenster halt noch.
Okay, Fake Webcam. Ist aber jetzt eigentlich genau das Gleiche, nur dass es ein Fenster ist und nicht irgendein Aussteller. Aber dafür macht er noch mal ein eigenes Programm.
Ja, was weiß ich.
Ja, dann hat er noch einen Webcam-Video-Mixer am Start.
Und dann hat er auch noch irgendwie so einen von Bluescreen oder Greenscreen-Dingsbumstool. Also die sind jetzt, glaube ich, schon alles relativ einfach gestrickt, die Tools, aber zum Beispiel bei Boing's TV, was ja so eine relativ professionell anmutende Software ist, um jetzt so Web-Video-Content zu produzieren und so newsmäßig aussehen zu lassen. Da gibt's halt in der FAQ auch so die Frage, wie stream ich denn jetzt einen Screencast da rein oder wie kann ich denn das machen? Und die verweisen dann auch eben auf genau Raster-Grubber, um da so ein Device zu machen und das in Boing's TV rein zu more stellen. Und es hat auch funktioniert, ich hab dann zwar Boing's TV doch gar nicht mehr benutzt, aber ich hab halt mir erstmal alle Tools runtergeladen, die irgendwas mit Screencast und Mac OS X zu tun hatten.
Das ist ja ein interessanter Punkt, weil genau um dieses Problem hier beim Podcast, zeig ich nochmal das Bild und so weiter, ich würde ja gerne hier auch mal Screencast-Streaming machen. Damit würde das ja sogar gehen, dass man sozusagen so einen Mac hat, den man hier mit dem Beamer und so weiter, wie ich das schon lange plane, dass man dann dessen Inhalt auch immer streamt, sodass Leute quasi uns auch noch beim Surfen zu gucken können, ohne dass wir jetzt hier so Videokameras haben. Das sehe ich den Mehrwert irgendwie nicht so richtig. Aber das wäre schon ganz cool. Das muss man dann aber auch nicht sehen, um so einen Audio-Podcast jetzt genießen zu können. Wäre aber noch mal so ein Extra Value. Nur dachte ich mir so, jetzt da mit RTSP, in diesem ganzen Klimpim, und dann wieder skalieren, in Streaming-Servern zu arbeiten, ist irgendwie alles Quatsch. Eigentlich will man dieses iPhone-HTTP-Streaming machen. Weil, das wäre dann eigentlich relativ einfach. Dann bin ich auch tatsächlich neulich, als ich bei dem Bits und so Ding war, bin ich über so einen kleinen Programmierer getrampelt, wollte ich gerade sagen. Nein, auf ihn gestoßen, mit ihm ins Gespräch gekommen, der tatsächlich so ein ähnliches Tool zwar erstmal nur für Audio gemacht hat, was eigentlich nichts anderes tut, als einen Audio-Stream zu nehmen und den im entsprechenden HTTP-Streaming-Format auf Platte zu schreiben. Das heißt, dieses Chunking, also das Ganze in so einen MPEG-Transport-Stream zu bringen, also in Codesys, in AAC, in Audio, packst es in einen MPEG-Transport-Stream, also nicht in einen MP4, sondern in einen Transport-Stream. Das ist ja so, wie das HTTP-Streaming auf dem iPhone funktioniert. Ist ein bisschen schwierig zu finden. Ich kann das nochmal verlinken. Ich sag aber gleich dazu, das Tool ist extrem mega-Beta-Konzept-Lalala. Funktioniert ja auch nur auf der lokalen Platte, weil was ich nämlich eigentlich machen wollte ist, ich muss das ja irgendwie auf den Web-Server kriegen. Und wenn das dann sozusagen so auf dem Web-Server ist und der dieses Playlist-Fall immer entsprechend aktualisiert, dann würde das ja ausreichen. Und mein Plan war, Trans mitzunehmen, diese FTP, SFTP-Software. Damit kann ich über SFTP ein Verzeichnis von meinem Server mounten. Und dann nehme ich sozusagen das Tool und schreibe einfach lokal in dieses gemountete Filesystem mehr oder weniger direkt auf den Fileserver drauf.
Das ist einfach per Dropbox.
Ja, mit Dropbox habe ich aber nicht so ein definiertes Verhalten. Also bei so einem Mount weiß ich genau, wenn das Ding geschrieben ist, ist es auf dem Server. Also weil er es direkt dahinschreibt. Er macht nicht eine lokale Kopie auf der Festplatte, sondern er schreibt direkt mal das Internet dahin und dann ist das da auch da.
Machen die das auch mit MacFuse oder wie machen die das?
Ich kann nicht ausschließen, dass das auch mit Dropbox funktionieren würde, bloß dann muss ich das ja von Dropbox auch erstmal wieder auf meinen Web-Server kriegen und das ist irgendwie alles Gurke. Also das ist jetzt nicht so das, was ich will. Nur jetzt von der Vision her, vielleicht gibt es dieses Tool ja auch, deswegen erzähle ich das jetzt gerade mal, weil es würde einfach das ganze Streaming total einfach machen. Derzeit benutzen wir diese Xenium-Infrastruktur, die ist super, weil die ja auch schön skaliert, etc. Aber man kann ja auch über normal HTTP und eben diesen ganzen Caching-Vorteil, den man dabei hat, auch ganz gut skalieren. Proxys davor schalten, etc.
Aber für Livestream würde das ja dann trotzdem nichts bringen.
Na, wenn du Proxys vorschaltest, könntest du da schon deine Last runternehmen. Aber du kannst das halt alles mit normaler Web-Server und Proxy-Technologie machen. Du brauchst jetzt dafür keine spezielle Streaming-Infrastruktur.
Gibt es eigentlich Dienstleister für?
Und asekrone Streaming könnte man machen.
Für Web-Proxys?
Für HTTP-Streaming, Video-Streaming. Ich will mit meinem QuickTime-Broadcaster irgendwo hinzeigen und dann sollen die sich darum kümmern, dass das...
Eigentlich alle, Akamai, S3 und so.
Du encodes das gleich in den File-Chunks, wie es ist, und dann musst du es nur noch auf den Webserver kriegen. Und dann kannst du das ja bei irgendeinem Webserver, Dienstleister, du kannst das ja auch bei Amazon S3 draufgießen. Du kannst auch dein S3-Mounten uns da drauf packen, wenn du es bezahlen kannst. Aber das skaliert. Ja, also das skaliert amtlich, aber du kannst das alles in so ein Bucket reingießen. Und wenn der entstandene Treffik... Ja, also wenn du es sozusagen jetzt finanziell hinkriegst, dann brauchst du keinerlei eigene Infrastruktur. Nur jetzt über diesen SFTP-Umweg könnte ich es halt secure und easy auch so machen, mit einem Tool, was einfach nur Files schreibt, was gar nicht jetzt irgendwelchen Upload-Schmu noch machen muss. Sonst schreibt halt einfach und was auch immer ich remote haben will, mount ich mir eben remote ins Fallsystem rein und dann ist es da. Das Problem mit diesem kleinen Streamer-Tool ist, dass da ein Bug drin ist und wenn ich auf was Gemountes draufschreibe, dann bricht er ab mit Error 0.
Ich würde es mir einfach mit einem Ersing-Script laufen lassen, das die ganze Zeit rumläuft und gucke, was neu ist.
Ersing hat auch wieder absurde Delays. Klar, kann man irgendwie alles machen. Na, das Ersing muss ja dann auch immer erst mal gestartet werden und...
Wieso, du musst das einfach durchlaufen.
Nur mal eine kurze Frage, bevor ihr euch gleich überkommt.
Ersing muss dann immer wieder die andere Seite lesen. Was ist denn da? Was habe ich denn hier? Irgendwelche Hashes vergleichen. Vollkommen überflüssig.
Um dieses... Also, muss ich denn irgendwas Spezielles tun, damit QuickTime jetzt mein Video auch versteht als HTTPS-Training? Oder schiebe ich einfach nur MPEG 4 dahin?
Du musst Snow Leopard haben.
Okay, und ich schiebe dann einfach nur MPEG 4, H264 irgendwo auf den Server. Und die Adresse kann der dann auch... Also einfach nur ein Videofile abholen und was noch?
Die Frage ist, wie funktioniert HTTPS-Training auf dem iPhone?
Ja, oder auch so...
Okay, also es funktioniert im Prinzip so. Und zwar für Audio und Video ist es das gleiche. Du hast deine Audio- oder Video- oder Beidesquelle und du encodes das in MPEG 4 Codex. Also Audio in AAC, Video in H264 mit Bitrate deiner Wahl. Und du kannst aber auch mehrere Bitraten deiner Wahl machen und machst separate Streams.
Mit welchem Tool macht man das zum Beispiel? Diese Tools gibt es halt nicht.
Darüber rede ich jetzt gerade. Das ist sozusagen genau das Problem. Es gibt natürlich irgendwelche Lösungen im Internet und jede Hosting-Bude bastelt gerade an ihren eigenen Kram. Aber so out of the box kenne ich halt auch nichts.
Verstehe.
Es gibt aber so allerlei Script-Utilities, die halt das schon irgendwie machen und du kannst dir da auch deine Command-Line-Chain mit FFmpeg und so weiter bauen. Also mit FFmpeg kannst du alles machen, Audio-Enkoden, Chunks machen und das in einen Transportstream-Block reinmachen und du machst dann halt bestimmte Zeit irgendeine Blockgröße, die ist üblicherweise so bei 10 Sekunden, kann weniger sein, kann mehr sein. Das hängt halt immer davon ab, was sozusagen die Ladeeinheit ist. Wenn man davon ausgeht, du machst es, wenn du es zu groß machst, dann muss halt zu viel geladen werden, bevor er was abspielen kann. Wenn du es zu klein machst, muss er halt zu häufig neue Zugriffe machen. Und 10 Sekunden, da hat er irgendwie genug zu spielen, aber das sind immer noch überschaubare Dateigrößen. Das ist eigentlich so die Ratio, die dahinter steht. Um dann aber auch zu wissen, auf welches Pfeil folgt, und du jetzt nicht irgendwie über Dateinamen oder so ein Scheiß gehst, erzeugst du so eine Playlist. Und es handelt sich dabei im Wesentlichen um eine Erweiterung dieser ganz normalen HTTP-Audio-Streaming-Playlist, diesen M3U-Kram. Sie haben so ein M3U-UTF-8-Version gebaut, zwei, drei weitere Keywords noch mit reingebaut, wo du dann eben unterschiedliche Bitraten unterscheiden kannst. Also du kannst in dieser Playlist sagen, hier haben wir eine niedrige Bitrate, eine hohe Bitrate und noch eine höhere Bitrate. Und du kannst dir selber aussuchen, was du abspielst. Und wenn du Probleme hast, einen Chunk schnell genug laden, dann gehst du halt automatisch in der Bitrate runter. Du kannst da im Prinzip auch noch Schlüssel mit reinpacken, wenn es dir beliebt. Und du kannst dann sagen, ok, hier ist jetzt der Live-Kram, wenn du das jetzt live spielen willst, dann musst du diesen Chunk und als nächstes den Chunk und so weiter. Das heißt im Prinzip stehen da nur ORLs drin. Der Client liest die Playlist und lädt einfach die Chunks in der Reihenfolge, wie sie da drin stehen, einfach nach. Kann dann entsprechend, wenn er casht, auch vor- und zurückspringen. Das ist dieses, geh mal 30 Sekunden zurück Feature, das wird damit ja auch unterstützt. Aber alles, was du als Infrastruktur brauchst, um einen Stream zu liefern, ist ein ganz normaler Web-Server, der nichts Spezielles können muss. Du brauchst keinerlei Streaming-Server-Infrastruktur. Du kannst einen ganz popligen Strato-Web-Server nehmen, völlig egal.
Und warum kann der QuickTime-Broadcaster das nicht?
Der QuickTime-Broadcaster kommt aus einer anderen Zeit und das ist ein RTSP-Tool. Und ich frage mich auch, warum dieses OS das nicht kann. Also wieso kann der QuickTime-Player das nicht? Ich kann ja mit dem QuickTime-Player auch Audio und Video aufnehmen. Warum kann ich nicht gleich in diese Chunks und erzeugen mir noch eine Playlist aufnehmen, schreib's auf die Platte und fertig ist die Laube. Und vielleicht noch in mehreren Bitraten. Ich wäre mit einer erstmal glücklich. Ist total einfach. Ist echt nicht das große Problem. Ist bloß nicht drin. Andererseits ist es jetzt auch nicht das große Problem für jemanden, der halbwegs begabt ist, auf Mac so ein Tool zu schreiben. Ich bräuchte nur so ein kleines Programm, das nichts anderes macht, als ich gebe ihm den Audio-Kanal, sage ihm eine oder mehrere Bitraten, irgendein Naming-Schema und einen Ort auf meiner Platte, wo er es hinschreibt. Und das darf dann auch ein Mountpoint sein. Und dann sage ich, jetzt geht es los. Ich sage noch die Metadaten, die da noch mit drin schreiben sollen, dann schreibt er das dahin. Und schon habe ich eine Streaming-Infrastruktur. Und wenn ich die skalieren lassen möchte, Proxies. Und wenn ich es mega skalieren will und Geld ist egal, Amazon. Und wenn ich es mega skalieren lassen will und Geld ist nicht egal, muss ich mir was einfallen lassen.
QuickTime-Tool ist nicht?
QuickTime-Tool?
Kann der nicht aufnehmen oder wo hinschreiben?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Tatsächlich. Also, du kannst aufnehmen oder nachfüllen.
Zeig mir ein neues Feature auf meinem Computer. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Du hast ja gerade gesagt, du willst ein Tool, womit man...
Ja, halt live, ne? Also nicht irgendwie aufnehmen, dann Stopp drücken und dann speichern, sondern irgendwie...
Nee, aber der muss doch die ganze Zeit wegschreiben, während du schon...
Er schreibt einfach fünf Sekunden oder zehn Sekunden.
Ja, aber der gibt ja halt nicht diese Playlist-Files und...
Ach so.
Er muss dieses Playlist-File generieren, klar. Also er muss hochzählen, irgendwie jeder Block kriegt so eine laufende Nummer. Ja, wieder zehn Sekunden, zack, einen hochgezählt, schreibt das einfach gnadenlos in so einen File, in so ein Directory rein. Oder meinetwegen auch in so ein... Nimmst die erste Nummer und dann... .sagt Directories, Voodoo und so weiter, dass das nicht so voll ist, wie auch immer, hast du einfach deinen Ort und danach hältst du auch ein wunderbares Archiv von deinem Stream automatisch auch gleich. Du musst nicht deinen Stream mitschneiden, weil dein Stream ist schon mitgeschnitten, bevor du ihn überhaupt gestreamt hast, weil Sim-Files, das ist super. Und tja, dann kannst du eben später auch so Replay-Sachen machen. Du kannst dann halt die Playlist anders anordnen und sagen, hier sind alle Chunks. Und dann kannst du eben per Streaming an beliebige Stellen hingehen, sodass du eben auch über das Web auf, was weiß ich hier, drei Stunden Mobile Max und dann kannst du mehr oder weniger direkt linken auf, spule mal vor, auf die Stelle, 2 Stunden nach vorne. Kannst dann aber auf deinem iPhone hin und her scrabben und auch noch zurückspringen und vorspringen. Geht alles. Und musst nicht das ganze Fall runterladen, sondern du gehst einfach direkt auf den Chunk, der eben für diesen Zeitraum zuständig ist. Und das ist alles.
Wer kann das denn außer QuickTime, dieses HTTP-Streaming?
Also meines Wissens ist mir nicht bewusst, dass Apple schon irgendjemanden dazu gebracht hätte, das auch zu implementieren.
Weil ich hab mir heute vorhin, um ganz genau zu sein, Audio.js angeguckt.
Das ist ein Audio-JavaScript-Player.
Der macht einen ganz guten Eindruck. Und eigentlich müsste man, wenn man's macht, dann müsste man's ja gleich so machen, dass der das auch kann. Das würde ich total durfte finden. Ich hab den vorhin mal ausprobiert. Der funktioniert mittlerweile sogar auf dem iPhone.
Das ist nicht so sehr ein Feature des Displayers in deinem Browser, sondern das ist eher ein Feature deines Browsers, was dieses Audio-Element im Browser kann.
Eben. Obwohl, vielleicht könnte man's ja sogar so hinkriegen. Also, könnte man nicht sogar ein HTTP...
Also in einem Safari müsste das gehen.
Aber wenn das nur eine Datei ist und das ist ein HTTP-Streaming, dann müsste man doch auch eigentlich per HTTP-Streaming diese PLS-Datei abfragen können, gucken, welches MP3 brauche ich gerade, und wenn dann...
MP3 wirst du da nicht drin finden.
Kann man ein HTTP-Streaming nicht auch mit MP3 einfach machen?
Nein, das ist alles...
Alles M4A.
Ja!
Ihr könnt eigentlich auch MP3s nehmen.
Warum?
Warum nicht? Damit es kompatibler ist.
Kompatibel zu was?
Zum Rest der Welt.
Wer weiß schon diese Leute da draußen.
So die Firefox-Nutzer zum Beispiel.
Du, in dem Moment, wo die das implementieren müssen, müssen wir die Diskussion nochmal führen? MPEG-4 ist da.
Das ist da.
Sag mir ein Gerät, was das nicht kann. Sag mir ein Gerät, was nicht in der Lage ist, MPEG-4 abzuspielen, außer jetzt so billigen USB-Plastescheiß, den es bei Aldi vor drei Jahren gab.
Firefox.
Firefox kann natürlich auch MPEG-4 abspielen.
Also wie war das von den Formaten? Chrome kann alle, kann OK, MP3, M4A. Also, Chrome kann das. Die drei Formate. Firefox kann nach meinem Wissensstand OK und MP3. Safari kann M4A und MPEG-3. Mit anderen Worten, MPEG-3 ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, der auf allen modernen Browsern funktioniert.
Firefox ist doch kein moderner Browser, wenn die nicht MP3 haben.
Ach komm!
Das ist doch Quatsch. Das ist doch kein moderner Browser.
Natürlich, das ist ein moderner Browser.
Das ist kein moderner Browser, wenn er nicht MPEG-4 ist, der Standard. Da können die sich drehen und wenden, wie sie wollen. Das einzige, was Firefox wirklich pusht, ist Flash. Naja, das einzige, was Firefox pusht, ist Flash, weil damit du dir den ganzen MPEG-4-Contact im Internet anschauen kannst, müssen sie das Flash-Plugin laden, und das Flash-Plugin spielt dann MPEG-4 ab. Das ist doch das einzige, das ist doch dieser Irrsinn, dieser Firefox-Irrsinn. Das macht doch alles hinten und vorne keinen Sinn.
Wir reden jetzt von Audio.
Okay, reden wir von Audio. Ich will auch bei Audio MPEG-4 haben. Übrigens sind die Lizenzbedingungen von MPEG-4-Audio besser als von MP3 auf dem Papier. Interessiert natürlich eh keinen, aber ist so. Und MPEG-3 klingt einfach schlechter. Man hat weniger Features. Ist vorbei. Ich will das eigentlich gar nicht mehr haben. Aber diese Denke, die steckt überall drin. Ich hab hier neulich dieses WordPress-Plugin, was wir verwenden. Blueberry PowerPress. Das ist das am wenigsten Schlechte von diesem ganzen Teil.
Ja, kann man so grob sagen.
Bei Podpress hat sich in letzter Zeit einiges getan. Vielleicht tue ich diesen Plugin unrecht. Ich weiß, dass da eine ganze Menge Leute, auch irgendein Deutscher, der uns schon mal eine Mail geschrieben hat, da dran mithackt. Und das müssen wir uns irgendwie auch nochmal anschauen. Aber ich hab's neulich mir nochmal angeguckt. Dieses PowerPress hat nettere Features. Und dann hab ich irgendwie da mal im Forum rumgestochert, weil die nämlich auch dieses Problem haben, wenn du da M4A... Wenn du das halt da irgendwie abspitzst, dann machen sie halt gleich so ein Videofenster auf. In ihrem Player.
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, ist ja MPEG 4, da muss es ja auch ein Video sein. Ah ja, okay, alles klar. Und dann war da auch so ein total beratungsresistenter Typ, der irgendwie im Forum geantwortet hat und dann so, es gibt doch OK.
Hallo, ich hab nie gesagt, nehmt OK. Ich hab nur gesagt, MPEG 3, man könnte das gleiche Streaming auch mit MPEG 3 machen, es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, man hätte die Variante, die auf allen Systemen funktioniert, fertig aus.
Okay, pass auf, ich will hier modern kommunizieren. Ich möchte hier gerne einen Live-Podcast machen, ich möchte gerne streamen und ich möchte skalierbare Infrastruktur benutzen, die einfach aufzusetzen ist. Und wir haben hier dieses Privileg, dass wir durch die Unterstützung von dem Xenim-Projekt, die sich da wirklich schwer Mühe geben und kostenlose Dienstleistungen bereitstellen, haben wir das Glück, dass wir das hier gewuppt bekommen, dass irgendwie 400, 500 Leute zu hören. 499 natürlich haben wir nur, weil sonst wären wir ja Rundfunk.
Achso!
Das sind wir ja nicht, wir sind ja ein Podcast. Also haben wir so 499.
Maximal.
Maximal. Gleichzeitig.
Wie war die Seite? Na, streamsxenium.de. Da steht alles drauf. Und was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Ich wollte sagen, es ist sozusagen opportun, dass man, wir sind wirklich bei 499, dass man das eben auch mit seinem normalen Web-Server tun kann. Und diese Methode, die ich da jetzt gerade beschrieben habe, also dieses iPhone hat DTPs und das macht einfach total Sinn. Apple hat das erfunden hin und her, ist mir echt egal. Das macht einfach Sinn. Spezifiziert, benutzt offene Standards. Offene Standards. Nicht freie Standards, sondern offene Standards. Aber es sind Standards. Immerhin.
Aber nur leider nur von Apple unterstützt werden.
Opera kann zum Beispiel kein MP3.
MP4 machen alle.
Ja, aber guck mal, wenn es MP3 wäre.
Außer Firefox.
Wenn es MP3 wäre, würde ich mich jetzt hinwitzen, würde sagen, ich probiere mal einen HTML5-Player zu schreiben.
Ja, dann müsstest du dein MP3, dein MP1, Audio-Layer 3, um genau zu sein, in einen MP3-Transportstream reinbauen. Du müsstest da sowieso anfangen zu hacken.
Hier steht übrigens, dass der Firefox auch nicht mal MP3 kann.
Die fünf Minuten für das Thema sind abgelaufen.
Das sind einfach Penner. Das geht einfach gar nicht. Dieses Firefox bremst einfach die Entwicklung des Internets aus.
Aber ich weiß, warum Firefox sich durchgesetzt hat.
Das hat sich gar nicht durchgesetzt.
Doch, lass mich ausreden. Firefox hat sich deswegen durchgesetzt, weil der Internet Explorer noch viel schlechter ist.
Wahr.
Ja, da will ich jetzt gar nicht...
Weil das erste, was man macht, wenn man so Windows installiert, ist Firefox erst mal drüber.
Deswegen nehmen sie jetzt alle Chrome.
Und sowas von Safari nutzen.
Weil Chrome halt noch besser ist als...
Ja, und weil alle halt immer noch den neuesten Scheiß haben wollen. Weil Firefox nutzen ist ja heutzutage nicht mehr cool. Hat ja jetzt jeder Idiot und sein Bruder. Deswegen wechselt man jetzt zu Chrome. Das heißt, wenn einer sagt, ganz stolz, ich hab jetzt auch Firefox, dann sagt er, ich hab jetzt schon Chrome.
Aber Firefox ist halt auch lahm. Also der hat weniger Features, die sind lahmer beim Hinterherimplementieren von HTML5 und CSS3. Irgendwie haben wir halt auch hier Extension hell. Obwohl, das kriegen wir jetzt auch, aber egal. Und performen halt nicht so fett wie Chrome und WebKit. Also die sind schon jetzt auch hinten dran einfach.
Was ich auch bei dieser ganzen Mediendiskussion bei Firefox nicht verstehe ist, okay, meinetwegen, dann haben sie das nicht eingebaut. Aber mein Betriebssystem kann das. Ja, da müssen sie überhaupt gar keine Lizenz irgendwo klicken. Die benutzen einfach die Infrastruktur des Betriebssystems. Sie müssen nur Mediendateien annehmen und spielen sie mit dem, was man Mac OS X schon voll fertig lizenziert, jedem Programm bereitstellt, spielen sie es ab. Und dieses Betriebssystem kann MP3 und das kann den ganzen MP4.
Also wenn es nach mir geht.
Es ist nicht so, dass es nicht ginge. Es ist nur so, dass sie es nicht wollen. Sie wollen einfach nicht.
Und dabei haben die so viel Geld, die könnten sich die Lizenzgewöhn sogar, wenn es welche gäbe, leisten.
Ja, sie müssen da gar keine Lizenzen für kriegen. Zumindest wären wir das jetzt neu, dass man dafür, dass man jetzt ein MP4-Video von dem Betriebssystem abspielen lässt, Geld zahlen muss. Dann müsste ja jedes Programm auf dem Mac, was ein Video anzeigt, Lizenzen zahlen. Das ist ja Quatsch. Das ist ja genau dadurch, dass es ein Betriebssystem eingebaut ist, ist das ja abgedeckt. Und bei Windows ist es halt genauso. Das Einzige, was los unter den Tisch fallen würde, ist halt Linux, weil das eben nicht mit MPEG-4 kommt.
Aber das benutzt ja auch keiner, oder?
Aber das ist mir doch egal. Ich meine, dann sollen sie doch unter Linux das nicht benutzen. Aber wenn das mein Betriebssystem schon kann, warum verhindern sie, dass es dann benutzt wird? Also Firefox ist einfach eine Feature-Verhinderungsmaschine. Und ein Fortschrittbremse ist das. Ja, so sieht es aus.
Okay, genug geratet, nächste Thema.
Okay, ich halte jetzt das Maul. Dann kriege ich jetzt sowieso so viel Dreck wieder in den Kommentaren. Ich mache jetzt hier so den Matrix-Wave.
Den Matrix-Wave.
Mich nervt das einfach, diese Grundhaltung. Und dann dieser ganze Kack mit diesem Web-M und noch mal ein neues Format, was keinen Schwanz Bock hat, wirklich noch mal alles komplett auf den Kopf zu stellen. Ich meine, das wird nichts bewegen. Diese ganze Google-Initiative, das ist einfach Boris. Das geht in die Tonne. Das ist einfach nur ums noch mal ein paar Jahre alles. Ja, ich sag da, aufkaufen den Kack. Wenn wir was frei haben wollen, lass es uns kaufen. Großer Flatter-Button, MPEG 4 for Sale. So, wie lange muss man da draufklicken, bis das dann irgendwie gemeinfrei ist? So was brauchen wir. Aber über solche modernen Konzepte redet keiner.
Durch dieses WebM haben wir damals, glaube ich, mich zu erinnern festgestellt, haben sie ja immerhin erreicht, dass die MPEG, wie auch immer die Gruppe heißt, sich zumindest mal genötigt gesehen hat, die Lizenzgebührmodalitäten irgendwie mal so ein bisschen klar zu ziehen.
Also man kann, ich meine, ob das nun wirklich genau deswegen so war, wissen wir nicht. Aber es sah danach aus.
Es hatte schon Zeit.
Das war ja auch meine die ganze Zeit meine Vermutung, dass dieser ganze Web-M-Kram sozusagen nur deswegen eigentlich gelounge wird. Das heißt aber wiederum auch Google steht da gar nicht so dahinter. Das war sozusagen nur die große Keule, die sie rausgeholt haben nach dem Motto, wir können auch anders.
Na Google ist ja auch ein bisschen langsam geworden. Mit so vielen Projekten, die sie da an der Hand haben.
Google steckt im Schlamm. Ist das ein neues Produkt? Ich weiß es auch nicht so richtig. Wir waren schon mal besser. Müssen sich ein bisschen mühen. So, ich halte jetzt das Maul.
So, nächste Thema. Was ist denn der nächste Thema?
Das ist doch Podcast.
Was ist das nächste Thema? Du hast tatsächlich gerade gesagt, dass FireFog schlechte Technologie ist, weil ich gerne einen MP3-Player machen wollte.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es schlechte Technologie ist. Ich habe gesagt, es ist einfach eine Fortschrittsbremse.
Also ich kann Tims Punkt schon in Teilen nachvollziehen.
Das Thema ist jetzt wirklich durch.
Also ich wollte ja eigentlich... Ich habe ein Buch, eine Buchvorstellung noch für Weihnachten. Doch, ist geil. Ich habe es sogar mitgebracht, damit ihr das hier alle sehen könnt und die Zuhörer dementsprechend nicht. Das Buch heißt Getting Started in Electronics und wenn ihr das auf Amazon kriegt, ja, das Cover sieht nicht so richtig ästhetisch aus, muss man sagen. Aber das coole ist halt, ich blätter es mal auf, das Buch ist halt komplett so handgezeichnet und geschrieben.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Schülerlinienblatt Handnotiz.
Aber blätter das mal hier kurz ein bisschen durch, wenn du keinen Lebkuchen an den Fingern hast. Und das Buch erklärt halt so richtig, von Anfang an irgendwie, wie funktioniert das mit den Elektronen bis ganz zum Schluss, Logic Gates und dem ganzen Kram. Was denn? Ja, siehst du, Tim sagt gleich geil auf der ersten Seite.
Ha! Ja, das ist der Level, mit dem man einsteigen muss. Cool!
Ja, das ist ein extrem cooles Buch. Also du fängst echt simpel an und super leicht verständlich.
Und wie das alles funktioniert. Die Leute sind schon ganz heiß.
Na, Tim, mach den Affiliate-Link doch dann nachher ins Blog. Genau, und wie gesagt, es hört halt auf mit Logic Gates auch. Also es geht so richtig von Anfang bis Ende und das sind nur...
Und kostet wie viel?
Ich hab's glaub ich für 20 Euro oder so was geschoppt. Das war halt früher bei wie hieß denn? Radio Shack heißt dieser Standard-Elektronik-Dealer. Da gab's sozusagen für die Einsteiger-Kids gab's dieses Buch sozusagen mit dazu. Mims. Das geile ist, der Typ arbeitet für die Nase und hat schon tausend Sachen gemacht, aber ist ein Kreationist, witzigerweise.
Hier gibt's noch nicht mal einen Cover bei Amazon.
Na doch, irgendwie hab ich mal eins gefunden.
Im Schätzchen massenhaft Covers.
Auf jeden Fall ist es wirklich, auch wenn's handgezeichnet und geschrieben ist, ist es wirklich so super cool gemacht und das war das beste Buch, was ich so zum Einstieg in die Elektronik überhaupt gefunden hab. Daumen hoch kann ich mir eben empfehlen. Das wird auch immer noch gedruckt, auch wenn Radio Shack das jetzt nicht mehr immer als Standardbuch bundelt oder so, aber... Ja.
Das sieht aus, als wenn du irgendwie einen Schüler überfallen hast und ihm sein Physikbuch geklaut hast.
1991? Das ist uralt!
Ja, und gibt's schon ewig, aber ist immer noch voll top notch, also gerade so die Semikondakt...
Das ist ja Schweine teuer!
Was kostet's denn? 24 oder sowas?
Ne, 85 Euro!
Ne, ne, ne!
Forrest Mims!
Ja, ne, das gibt's auch billiger. Ich hab das nicht für 85 Euro gekauft. Das gab's auch billiger. Getting started in electronics. Könnt ihr ja mal gucken. Vielleicht wird's auch gar nicht mehr gedruckt und ich hatte jetzt noch das letzte Exemplar, aber eigentlich...
Den Eindruck hab ich fast.
Forrest Printing 2007, Six Printing 2009, also 6. Auflage.
Also ich hab's hier bei Amazon für 1995. Dollar.
Amazon was?
Amazon Com.
Vielleicht hab ich's mir auch über Com bestellt, ich wisse es nicht mehr.
First published in 1983.
Ja, stimmt, in Com ist es da, in DE ist es nicht.
Genau, dann shoppt euch, dass man das so lange es noch gibt, das behaltet ein Leben lang im Schrank. Das ist nämlich wirklich...
Wie fand denn Com wirklich nach Deutschland?
Ja, du kannst bei anderen Amazons bestellen mit deinem deutschen Account und so. Das ist ganz cool gemacht bei Amazon.
Da kann man ja auch in jede Seite reingucken.
Also für die, die es nicht mehr in Print kriegen, es gibt auf so diesen Filesharing-Börsen, habe ich das auch schon rumgeistern sehen als PDF. Das ist natürlich ein Scan, weil du kannst das ja nicht OCRen oder so, aber das ist auch okay. Aber in Print ist es einfach schöner, weil die Kontraste besser sind. Ja, das ist so mein Tipp.
Da poste ich einen Torrent.
Affiliate-Torrent.
Das wär mal was.
Vor allen Dingen klärt das auch tatsächlich darüber auf, auf sinnvolle Art und Weise, dass die Betrachtung von Plus und Minus und der Fluss der Elektronen allgemein falsch ist. Und wie er eigentlich richtig ist. Dass die Elektronen nämlich von Minus zu Plus gehen und nicht andersrum.
Unsere Elektronen hier sind mehr oder weniger Smilies. Die einen haben einfach einen Minus als Auge und die anderen haben irgendwie einen Plus als Auge. Die positiven natürlich.
Das ist ja der Ion, also der Kern plus Elektronen. Protonen und so weiter. Übrigens, wenn wir gerade bei Amazon sind und wir eigentlich auf FreeBSD Freunde sind, habt ihr da gelesen? FreeBSD läuft jetzt auf Amazon E2 Microinstances.
Davon soll man eigentlich überhaupt noch nutzen?
Das heißt, man kann jetzt bei Amazon...
Ach, man muss nicht mehr Linux klicken?
Genau. Ich hab mir das jetzt auch mal geklickt. Amazon ist wie Google, deren Interfaces sind so unübersichtlich und bloated. Gerade von diesen Amazon-Web-Services, bis du dich da zurechtgefunden hast. Echt schlimm. Ich hab dann nach einer halben Stunde rausgefunden, wo man jetzt tatsächlich endlich dazu kommt, sich so eine Instanz zu klicken, nachdem man eine tausend Setup und Sign-In und haste nicht gesehen geklickt hat. Und dann kannst du dir halt so eine Micro-Instanz klicken und dann gibt's ja da die Images von Amazon, deine eigenen oder irgendwie so in so einem Tab und dann gibt's noch die Community-Images und bei diesen Community-Images ist halt ein FreeBSD neuen Current-Image drin und damit kannst du dir eine Micro-Instanz klicken und die haben halt den Xen-Support für FreeBSD jetzt wohl gerade gezogen, auch irgendwie so mit Support von Amazon, das heißt demnächst kann man FreeBSD in Xen ganz entspannt fahren und diese ganzen Hosts da draußen, die es da draußen so gibt, die haben ja weitestgehend halt immer so eine Xen-based Virtualisierungsgeschichte am Start und da gibt es dann bald auch FreeBSD.
Und wie ist das mit diesem Amazon? Du kaufst ja das, du zahlst pro Minute?
Genau, im Moment, noch eine Sache, nämlich die Micro-Instanz, die ist nämlich for free auch sogar, das heißt du kannst sogar, wenn du nicht wirklich viel Load da drauf hast, kannst du so eine FreeBSD Micro-Instanz ein Jahr kostenlos jetzt sogar benutzen gerade.
Ach, die ganze Zeit über? Also man hat einen kostenlosen Server bei denen?
Genau.
Man kann ein Jahr lang sich einen FreeBSD Server kostenlos da rumklicken lassen.
Ja, das sind halt nur ein paar hundert Megabyte, die du da zur Verfügung hast, aber wie gesagt, die genauen... Ich kann den Post mal dazu noch mal raussuchen, wo drin steht, was da alles...
Das klingt eigentlich ganz cool, das hol ich mir.
Ja, also zum Rumspielen ging halt, wie gesagt, nach dem Sign-Up ganz gut zu klicken. Ich hol mal grad den Link raus, wo sie das annunzen.
EC2 heißt das, ne? Wo steht das eigentlich?
Elastic Cloud, glaube ich, oder?
Das ist die zweite, oder was?
Die erste, die nicht geklappt hat. Warte mal, der Krüxen hat doch davon gepostet, dachte ich, oder? Hat er das repostet?
24, ich hab's schon aufgemacht.
Auf jeden Fall hätte ich dann auch gleich noch für so Hosting und so gleich noch mal die nächste Meldung. Und zwar, ich wollte ja... Oh, was war das? Ich wurde ja letztens erkannt, ne? Am Telefon. Wir mussten nämlich mal so spontan unsere Server ganz schnell innerhalb von 24 Stunden migrieren. Und dann haben wir so ein bisschen rumgeguckt, wo wir jetzt innerhalb, also wo wir jetzt einen Server kriegen, wo wir jetzt unseren Stuff migrieren können, damit wir in 24 Stunden fertig sind. Und dann hat einer meiner Kollegen mir die Jiffy Box von Domain Factory empfohlen. Und Domain Factory fand ich früher ja total doof, aber Domain Factory ist jetzt so neben Host Europe eigentlich ein, also die sind fast cooler als Host Europe, weil die haben echt extrem coolen Service. Da kann man zum Beispiel auch Ruby on Rails easy hosten. Die haben echt coole Preise, coolen Service, eine kompetente Hotline. Also wenn man da anruft, da sind auch Leute dran, die Checkung haben, die wissen, was IMAP ist. Und die haben jetzt auch so einen Cloud-Service, und der heißt Jiffybox. Und da haben wir uns halt so eine Jiffybox geklickt, und die ist auch sendenbasiert letztendlich. Und auf jeden Fall ging halt eine Sache, nicht im Webinterface zu klicken. Dann hab ich da angerufen und dann meinte der Typ, darf ich mal eine Frage fragen? Mh, machen Sie zufällig einen Podcast? Hatte sich gefreut und hat dann auch zwar nicht direkt mein Problem lösen können, aber hatte es schnell eskaliert, damit es noch innerhalb...
Aber hatte ich ehrlich be-begleitet?
Ja, nee, aber fand ich gut. Auf jeden Fall ist diese Jiffybox halt auch genau so ein relativ cooler Service, ist auch relativ preiswert. Und du kannst halt instantan klicken, kannst 24 Stunden da erstmal rumklicken und testen. Und hast halt auch so ein Webinterface, wo du einfach alles total schick und fluffig konfigurieren kannst. Nur da gibt es halt momentan eben auch nur diverse Linux-Instanzen.
Diese Jiffybox, das ist auch so was, fahr es hoch, fahr schnell wieder runter.
Genau, du kannst es pausieren, starten, du kannst dir das Xen-Image von deinem Ding runterladen. Also du hast halt auch im Gegensatz zu Amazon EC2, da hast du ja keine Persistenz. Das heißt, wenn die Kiste aus ist, ist halt alles, was du mit Speicher hattest, weg. Es sei denn, du kaufst ja noch irgendwo ein Persistenz-Layer dazu, da speicherst du das halt woanders hin. Und bei denen hast du halt so eine richtige Festplatte, du kannst dir irgendwie Chores und Ram dazu klicken, wenn du das brauchst. Du kannst die pausieren, dann kostet es halt nur noch zwei Cent oder irgendwie sowas. Und du kannst dir halt das...
Zwei Cent pro Minute?
Ich weiß nicht, muss man mal gucken. Und du kannst dir halt das Xen...
Pro Mikrosekunde.
Du kannst dir halt das Xen-Image halt auch runterladen. Das heißt, selbst wenn du dann wegmigrierst auf eine eigene Kiste, hast du halt deinen ganzen Stater. Du kannst auch auf Knopfdruck deine Instanz verdoppeln. Also irgendwie mehrere Server dir klar machen. Und es war irgendwie echt ein cooler Deal.
Jetzt wäre es auch gleich nochmal ein Affiliate-Link mit holen können.
Genau, ne, ne, ne. Da hatten wir die Hörerschaft...
Wir müssen ja mal klar machen, dass wir hier keine Sponsoren haben.
Also wir reden hier nicht... Wir reden nur überzeugt, was wir echt cool finden. Genau.
Wir reden nicht das Wort.
Genau. Jiffybox kann man mal klicken. Und Domain Factory als Host da auch. Also die sind wirklich echt ganz fit, finde ich.
Wo stehen hier die scheiß Kosten? Das gibt es doch nicht.
Hier ist doch auch irgendwo...
Da steht ja nichts von Preis.
Da standen hier Preise.
Ah, da ist der Preisetap. Achso, okay. Pro Stunde sind das.
Dann zahlst du halt hier für... Also wir haben jetzt hier die mit 4 Cores und dann zahlst du halt im Monat 52 Euro und hast die halt instant on. Und die ist auch echt snappy. Also ich hatte ja so ein bisschen Zweifel, ob so virtualisierte Kisten halt auch wirklich snappy sind. Aber ich hab noch nie so einen schnellen Computer so in der Hand gehabt. Also das war echt rattenflink.
Na gut, wo wir jetzt gerade bei der Preisung von Produkten sind.
Das klingt echt gut, ich glaube, vielleicht mach ich das ja auch einfach mal.
Na, kannst du wie gesagt einen Tag haben.
Leute, das klingt jetzt langsam echt wie abgesprochen, ja. Aber hier, ich hab doch letztes Mal über meinen neuen Laserdrucker schwadroniert, ne? Und das war ein, ich versuch jetzt gerade mal die korrekte Bezeichnung nochmal zu finden, ein CM1410. Weil das ja einer von denen war, weil ich ja eh einen Farbläser haben wollte und die dann irgendwie auf jeder Liste waren von kann jetzt schon Airprint. Und dann konnte er keins. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt muss man dazu sagen, gab es bereits ein Firmware-Update. Das hat bei meinem Gerät noch nicht aufgegeben.
Das wurde sogar live im Chat announced.
Das kann gut sein, aber das habe ich jetzt in dem Moment vielleicht nicht gerade mitgelesen. Ich hab's dann mitbekommen während oder nach der Sendung. Und ja, habe das mal installiert und siehe da, alles wunderbar. Und ich bin überhaupt erstaunt. Das ist ja jetzt, also mittlerweile sind diese Drucker offensichtlich an diesem Punkt angekommen, wo ich sie immer haben wollte.
2010.
Ja.
Hat echt lange gedauert. Also das, ja, ich mein, dieses Gerät steht da, es ist leise, keine Ahnung, wie lange das so bleibt. Und es ist einfach ohne, dass ich irgendeinen Treiber installieren musste, auf Mac, als Drucker, als Faxgerät und als Scanner voll integriert ins OS.
Alle drei Probleme in einem Gerät und es geht sogar?
Ja.
Und es hat einfach immer alles sofort funktioniert.
Das sind drei Dinge auf einmal, das geht nun wirklich nicht.
Also früher hieß es immer, es gibt drei Sachen, die nicht funktionieren. Drucken, wobei es ging so ein bisschen, aber Faxen und Scannen, das war immer der schlimmste Horror.
Der konnte aber nicht Faxen oder Scannen.
Aber der konnte Drucken.
Gibt es da eigentlich nicht so Hausdrucker, wenn man in so ein Miethaus einzieht? Ich meine, bei manchen Wohnungen gibt es ja, dass man unten eine gemeinsame Waschmaschine im Keller stehen hat, da steht da nicht so ein gemeinsamer Drucker rum.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall meine gute Preisgestaltung und billig einkaufen und dann teuer Toner und so weiter. Das kennen wir alles. Aber das Ding funktioniert soweit. Und es hat sich gleich in mein WLAN eingebucht. Ist auch über Ethernet ansprechbar.
Verschickt auch Mails, was du alles so druckst.
Neue Firmware hat auch ein besseres User-Interface mitgebracht. Mails kann er auch verschicken.
Kannst auch Mails an den Drucker schicken und die dann ausdrucken lassen.
Ich glaube, das geht, aber ich hab das jetzt ehrlich gesagt.
Sein Spam hin, du Hatterleitend.
Brauchst bald gar keinen Computer mehr, brauchst nur noch den Drucker.
Ist der auch so ein Internet-Ausdrucker? Das ist ja dieses neue, vom WWF, ne, dieses...
Das WWF-Format, was man nicht ausdrucken kann? Das war ein Witz, oder? Nee, das war kein Witz.
Das ist WWF-format, echt?
Das ist doch PDF mit irgendwie, du darfst mich nicht drucken.
Sie haben die Erteilung geändert.
Lustiger Witz. Das ist so wie diese E-Mails, wo unten eine Madrid steht, bitte denken Sie, genau, denken Sie an die Umwelt, drucken Sie dieses Teil nicht aus.
Das macht die UD Kaltz auch. Ja, die schicken jetzt, please save a tree, oder save a tree, und don't forget to bring a towel.
Ja, druck's nicht aus, lass besser 24 Stunden nach dem Rechner laufen, wie mit all ihren sirrenden Festplatten, damit du permanent Strom verbrauchst, um dieses Dokument anzuzeigen. Anstatt es einfach auszudrucken mit so ein bisschen Farbe und dann hat sich der Lack. Quittest doch nicht den Regenwald, weil du deine Mails nicht ausdruckst.
Bitte dich.
So viel Zeit.
Ich glaub, das ist schon echt viel, was so gedruckt wird in so einem Laden. Das ist so...
Einst du?
Ja.
Ich glaub auch, natürlich. Sie druckt einfach alles aus, dann liegt es da.
Der Papier ist halt geduldig.
Wir kriegen regelmäßig so quasi Dokumente, wo dann drinsteht, was zu tun ist sozusagen, wo die Produktbeschreibung drin ist. Vor jedem Meeting ist dann ein Projektmanager, der druckt das dann für jeden aus. Das ist total albern. Dann hast du da so einen schönen Stapel Papier. Mit einem Meeting, also das ist echt. Also da kann man echt einiges an Papier sparen, wenn man dann einfach mal sagen würde, wir packen das mal in Wiki rein.
Nächstes Mal zu Weihnachten wollen wir alle iPads. Statt Lebkuchen.
Ja, ich glaube, wir kriegen ja auch bald neue iPads, ne? Wollen wir nicht mal ein bisschen Glas kugeln?
Lass uns mal im Glas umherkugeln.
Also, Steve, wenn ich nicht bald ein neues MacBook Pro kriege, mit aktuellen Chips, aktueller GPU, Fett, Batterie und allem Shit, nehmt's Ärger. Da machen wir ja nur noch Windows 7.
Ich will MacBook Pro R.
Genau, MacBook Pro R 15 Zoll. Aber trotzdem mit ordentlicher Grafikkarte, bitte.
Alles mit allem.
Die Keilform macht's halt möglich.
Maximale Leistung, maximale Batteriedauer.
Ja, und CD-ROM kannst du weglassen. Ist bei mir eh schon wieder am Arsch, glaub ich.
Und zwar irgendwie 11 Zoll Formfaktor, mit 20 Zoll Bildschirm. Ich hätte ja so einen kleinen Computer mit einem großen Bildschirm. Das ist das, was die Leute wollen. Einen kleinen Computer mit einem großen Bildschirm. Das geht aber nicht.
Dann sollen sie sich halt was ausdenken.
Ich war jetzt schon wieder in so einem Shopping-Urge, dachte mir so, MacBook R, MacBook R, MacBook R.
Sieht ja auch toll aus, ne?
Ja, aber dann hab ich so die Constraints wieder ein bisschen durchgegangen und hab mir dann gesagt, nö.
Welche?
Und jetzt kommen wir nicht mit so einem Stick.
Ich komm überhaupt nicht mit Sticks. Ich bin total gegen Sticks.
Ich möchte das Thema wechseln. Ich find das eher, MacBook R.
Na, ich wollte eigentlich über das iPad-Glas kugeln.
Ach, über das iPad.
Ich will neuen Rechner.
Das ist ja nun offensichtlich, die nächste Hardware, die von Apple rauskommt, wird wohl das neue iPad sein, oder? Ich meine, wie eure Erwartung...
Im Januar wird mir erstmal noch MacBooks kommen. Im Januar? Im Januar war doch früher immer so klassisch MacBooks. Aber das ist ganz lange her, ne?
Ja, doch. Aber irgendwas kommt im Januar. Das müssen wir machen, das ist Tradition.
Ich meine, wenn man sich die dünne Gerüchteküche anschaut, dann ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur von iPads die Rede. Aber die Gerüchte sind mir eigentlich auch relativ schnurz. Die Frage ist ja, wir wissen nicht, was sie zu leisten in der Lage sind. Wir wissen nicht, was sie sich ausgedacht haben. Wir wissen nicht von dem, was theoretisch vorstellbar wäre, ob es in einem Test sinnvoll ist, ob es bezahlbar ist. Wir wissen nicht, ob ein iPad genauso gebaut werden kann oder ob das auch nur erwünscht ist seitens von Apple, wie jetzt das iPhone ist. Wir wissen ja noch nicht mal, ob das nächste iPhone noch so sein wird, wie das iPhone jetzt ist.
Vermutlich nicht. Ansonsten wäre es ja nicht das nächste iPhone.
Naja, die ersten drei iPhones, also zumindest das zweite und das dritte iPhone waren, war dasselbe Gerät. Das hast du ja auch schon in der Numerierung, in der internen Numerierung gesehen. Das dritte iPhone war das...
Ich überlege jetzt gerade, welches. Ich glaube, das 3GS hatte da nämlich, das war das erste, was eine richtig neue Nummer hatte. Also das erste iPhone hieß iPhone 1,1, glaube ich, das zweite 1,2 und ich glaube, das dritte hieß dann 2,1, wenn ich nicht alles täusche. Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, das zweite hieß 2,1 und das 3GS hieß dann 2,2.
Die Spezialisten von Mobile Macs wieder haben es voll raus.
Eine andere würden diese Frage gar nicht interessieren.
Schauen wir mal, iPhone 2,1.
Ein Mac-Tracker könnt ihr da übrigens gucken.
Braucht ihr euch nur die Firmware-Files angucken, da steht die Nummer immer drin. Ich guck mal schnell.
Ich gucke in Mac-Tracker.
Alles recht. Das 3GS ist ein 2,1. Ja klar, weil da ja intern sich der Prozessor geändert hat.
Eben hat sich eine ganze Menge geändert.
Du hast auch total recht. Die ersten beiden waren identisch. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus. Die ersten beiden waren identisch und dann kam halt neuer Prozessor, andere Geschwindigkeit. Das war sozusagen wesentlich. Wobei jetzt zum iPhone 4 hat sich ja alles nochmal geändert, sowohl der Prozessor als eben auch das Gehäusedesign. Ich wäre jetzt so überrascht nicht, wenn das nächste, wenn wir jetzt bei 3.1 sind, dass das nächste ein 3.2 ist.
Wie, du meinst, die machen den Antennagate nochmal?
Ich denke, die wissen, dass sie kein Antennagate hat. Na ja, die hatten ein Antennagate in den Medien, aber ob sie das wirklich in diesem Telefon hatten, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man das Telefon nicht benutzen könnte. Das ist definitiv geiler als das alte.
Ja, es funktioniert besser als das alte.
Also ich würde es nicht tauschen.
Aber es könnte noch besser sein.
Ja, es könnte immer alles noch besser sein. Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich auch auf ein iPad hinaus.
Das darfst du aber nicht.
So, wie sieht das nächste iPad aus? Sieht das nächste iPad aus wie das iPhone 4?
Ne, größer.
Glas? Vorne und hinten? Und die Antenne drum herum?
Ja, würde ich gut finden. Ist ja eigentlich schon so, oder?
Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Quatsch, wir hören jetzt nochmal zu Demonstrationszwecken hier so ein iPad. Lieber Zuhörer, wir halten das jetzt mal in die Kamera, damit hier unsere Mitpodcaster das sieht auch mal.
Ich höre auch ein iPad.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht so aus wie so ein iPhone, das sieht nämlich ganz anders aus.
Das ist nämlich zum Beispiel mein erster Kritikpunkt bei dem iPad, den hab ich ja eigentlich auch von Anfang an gebracht und der gilt auch immer noch. Das Ding ist halt unten rund.
Ja, ist total bekloppt.
Und wenn du das nicht in einer Tasche hast und du versuchst da drauf drum zu tippen, dann wackelt es.
Ja, ist schon Arsch. Das war auch bei den iPhones schon so. Und bei dem iPhone 4 ist es ja gefixt, weil es ist ja gerade und es ist einfach mal viel besserer.
Genau, und deswegen dachte ich mir schon das erste Mal, okay, vielleicht, ja. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob dieses große, also ob Apple so glücklich geworden ist mit diesem Glas, wenn man sich anschaut da ihre Produktionsprobleme mit dem weißen iPhone. I don't know. Wir wissen es nicht. Wir wissen nicht, ob es so billig und so einfach gelaufen ist, wie man, wie sie sich das gewünscht haben. Man weiß es nicht. Es kann ja sein, dass das viel zu teuer war und dass sie wieder auf, das weiß ich, vielleicht sind sie auch auf irgendein ganz anderes Material jetzt. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber was ich weiß ist, was ich will. Und ein iPad sollte eben nicht mehr so wackeln. Das ist jetzt nicht das schlimmste Feature. Es muss eine deutlich spürbar bessere Bildschirmauflösung haben. Also das denke ich, das ist so offensichtlich. Wenn sie das nicht bringen, nachdem sie jetzt bei dem iPhone mit dem Retina-Display so ein Tamtam gemacht haben. Und ich finde einfach so ein PDF zu lesen und ein Buch zu lesen, das ist auf dem iPad grenzwertig. Aber es ist irgendwie zu viele Pixel. Es ist irgendwie zu eckig, zu kantig, zu klobig. Das ist nicht gut.
Also die Schrift sieht einfach total ausgefranst aus.
Genau, es ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen farig. Und ich glaube, da gehen sie bei.
Da müssen sie ja. Wir haben jetzt die Latte hoch gesetzt und jetzt müssen sie auch springen.
Das sind ja die einfachen Weisheit mit Computergeschäft hier.
Unter Retina-Display geht nichts mehr. Das wissen die bei Apple auch.
Ob es Retina in der Definition von Retina werden wird, das wage ich. Also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Na ja, und die müssen aber schon ein bisschen hochschrauben.
Ja, sie müssen hochschrauben, aber Retina ist ja sozusagen diese Definition, dass du da die nicht mehr vom Auge unterscheidbaren Pixel hast auf den normalen Abstand. Der normale Abstand ist beim iPad weiter als beim iPhone, würde ich sagen. Also das ist sozusagen der Abstand von deinen Augen bis zu deinem Schoß, wo du das Teil hast. So wie das auf jedem iPad-Plakat zu sehen ist, dieser Abstand. Das heißt, das ist ein bisschen weiter als man ein iPhone hält. Ein iPhone ist irgendwie auf zwei Drittel der Distanz.
Guck mal, beim iPhone ist es ja so, die haben da verdoppelt in beide Dimensionen. Beide Dimensionen halt, zweimal zwei. Aber das dauert dann wieder drei Wochen, dass alle Developer ihre schicken Grafiken hochladen, die passend sind, und so weiter und so fort. Vor allem sind die auf dem iPhone eh schon höher, das heißt, das müsste dann auf dem iPad dann wieder gehen. Also ich denke mal, man muss nicht unbedingt in beide Dimensionen verdoppeln, die können auch irgendeine andere Vergrößerung nehmen. Und die Developer und auch die, das weiß das hier, das UI-Kit und so, das kann das alles prima hinregeln, das müsste gehen.
Ich glaube, die werden es aber trotzdem verdoppeln.
Das wird aber halt schon teuer werden, meinst du? Nicht bei dem großen Display?
Teuer inwiefern?
Ich meine, das wäre dann ein HDTV-Display-Größe.
So viel ist das ja noch auch nicht.
Na ja, man muss es von... Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie es jetzt schon machen. Also ich glaube, auch mit 1,5 Pixel machen sie nicht, weil dann würden nämlich plötzlich die...
Doch, das machen sie allein schon deshalb wie scheiße dann diese ganzen Android-Tablets dastehen.
Also mit 1,5 Pixel machen sie nicht, weil ansonsten würden nämlich die Sachen auf einem neuen iPad, die bestehenden Sachen, auf einem neuen iPad schlechter aussehen als auf einem alten iPad.
Das war auf dem iPhone auch so.
Nee, das war auf dem iPhone nicht so. Das sah auch genauso gut aus wie auf einem alten iPhone. Da musste ja nix, das war ja das gleiche Bild, das hat genauso viele Pixel.
Das hat genau reingepasst, das stimmt. So optisch war es das gleiche, das ist richtig. Das ist bei einer Halbwache...
Neue Apps sind einfach besser.
Aber die Apps haben sich doch jetzt schon angepasst, diesen Feature, dass sie nachfragen können, wie viele Pixel ein Punkt sind.
Ja, aber es gibt auch viele Programme, die das nicht getan haben.
Genau. Und ich glaube...
Ja, aber die rendern auch noch nicht selber, die lassen sowieso alles Apple rendern, wenn das sowieso in der richtigen Auflösung ist.
Du hast icons, die musst du auf eine entsprechende Auflösung liefern und du hast die Grafiken, die im App sind.
Musst du für das iPhone 4e alles machen?
Ja, aber bei so Linien und bei alles, was nicht Foto ist, also beim Fotos ist es egal, aber bei allen, wie so klare Linien, Patterns, Moiré-Muster, eineinhalb klingt einfach nicht...
Das klingt so, als würde es scheiße aussehen.
Klingt für mich so...
Ich denke, es ist machbar.
Ich glaube, wenn ich Steve Jobs wäre und der Typ kommt an mit ja, wir haben irgendwie doppelte Auflösung, haben wir noch nicht, aber wir hätten hier anderthalbfach.
Das ist die Radiatur des...
Dann wird der Typ einfach mit dem Messer im Rücken irgendwie aus dem Raum rausgetragen. Damit darf er nicht mehr gar nicht kommen.
Vielleicht, wenn die Pixel ein bisschen langgezogen sind.
Die Radiatur des Pixels rund wäre jetzt...
Wäre ganz schön krass, wenn das iPad mit 2000 Mal...
Das glaube ich nämlich 2048 mal 1300 irgendwas. Das wäre schon...
Das ist doch das, wovon wir reden. Das ist das, was der Buchlese-Auflösung hier fehlt. Die doppelte Auflösung. In jeder Richtung. Das ist einfach genau das, was dieser Pixel ist, mir zu groß. Und ich hätte gerne, da wo jetzt einer ist, hätte ich gerne vier.
Hätten wir alle gerne.
Ja, aber wieso? Der Kunde entscheidet. Das, was wir wollen, wird später von Steve da eingebaut.
Ja, aber ein Stück weit, also ganz bisschen, entscheidet auch natürlich technische Machbarkeit.
Die technische Nachbarkeit hat sich nach dem Kunden zu rechnen.
Und Steve sieht das ja überhaupt gar nicht ein, den Punkt hier, dass das irgendwie technisch nicht geht. Und jetzt haben wir ja auch den Rumor gehört, dass da eine Fabrik mit Toshiba oder was auch immer da irgendwie sich noch bastelt.
Was Toshiba heute laut deutlich dementiert hat.
Vielleicht schreibt das ja irgend einer mit. Ich sage doppelte Pixelauflösung. iPad 2 doppelte Pixelauflösung kommt.
Aber wie viel hat es denn jetzt?
Na, was auch immer.
1024x1536.
Aber im Chat sagt ja auch gerade einer 14...
Ja, es hat doch 1024x168, oder?
Ja.
Genau, das macht dann 2048x1536.
Ich meine, das hätte mehr Pixel als...
Als alle Laptops.
Als alles da draußen. Es gibt einfach nicht so große Displays mit der Auflösung, gibt's einfach nicht.
Das würden sie bauen lassen.
Du hast ja zu deinem 17 Zoll einen ganz anderen Abstand.
Ja, nee, davon mal abgesehen, aber es gibt's einfach nicht. Es gibt keine so hochauflösenden Displays größer als Smartphones.
Die gab's bis zum iPhone 4 auch noch nicht in der Größe vom iPhone 4, bis es das iPhone 4 gab.
Die waren aber alle schon ganz schön knapp dran. Das iPhone 4 ist nur ein bisschen größer als die anderen.
Ja, knapp dran sind die bestimmt auch.
Also, ich meine, wenn jemand es noch jetzt knacken kann, dann vielleicht Apple, weil die halt eben, wie auch beim Flash...
Der iPhone-Bildschirm ist höher aufgelöst, als sie es fürs iPad brauchen. Jetzt erzählt mir nicht, dass man so einen Bildschirm nicht bauen kann, weil es gibt diesen Bildschirm bereits. Der ist im iPhone. Man muss ihn nur größer machen.
Nur viermal nebeneinander kleben.
Ja, das ist doch alles. Ja, es ist eine Frage des Ausschusses. Es ist keine Frage, ob man das bauen kann. Das kann man bauen. Es ist eine Frage des Ausschusses und ob es bezahlbar ist. Und es ist eine Frage der Grafikleistung des iPads, ob sie in der Lage sind, die Performance beizubehalten, mindestens, weil sie im Prinzip beim Blitting die vierfache Datenmenge durch die Gegend schieben müssen. Das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Vielleicht machen sie ja die Doppeltauflösung in beide Richtungen, aber machen insgesamt das ein bisschen kleiner. Also, dass sich die DPI irgendwie verdoppelt, aber halt ein bisschen...
Aber dann hättest du jetzt gleiche Probleme mit den Pixeln. Also, dann hättest du wieder anderthalb Pixel. Also, meine zweite Voraussage.
Das iPad hat exakt denselben Formfaktor, das iPad 2 hat exakt denselben Formfaktor wie das erste.
Sicher?
Und also so sicher, wie ich mir nur irgendwie sicher sein kann, bin ich mir da.
Also, da wär ich mir auch relativ sicher.
iPad 2 ist einfach the same shit.
Also, von den Maßen her.
Von allen aus, also, vielleicht ist der Rand etwas weniger, bisschen mehr spitzer. Das Display ist, also, wenn es eine Abweichung gibt, dann ist die so in einem marginalen, geringen Bereich, dass die niemand merkt. Sondern es ist irgendwie, dann handelt es sich wirklich so um Millimeter. Wie ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wenig.
Wir speichern das hier mal als Camp-Show da weg, ne?
Jaja, ich mach jetzt einfach mal, ich dachte mal, ich bin jetzt einfach mal bold, weil ich hab auch immer gemerkt, dass ich mit meinen Voraussagen auch immer so wisch wie was ich naja könnte und vielleicht und bloß nicht fest nageln lassen. Ich lass mich jetzt einfach mal fest nageln. Bildschirm doppelt.
Ist ja bald Weihnachten.
Ja. Size, ich schreib's auf. Size bleibt.
Ich will, dass es halb so schwer ist.
Ja, es muss leichter werden.
Halb so schwer, dann wär ich...
Muss oder wird?
Muss.
Und deswegen wird auch.
Deswegen wird auch, genau.
Stimmt, das geht ja nur nach Kunden, finde ich.
Ne, mal ehrlich, das haben sich ziemlich viele Leute beschwert, dass es ganz schön schwer ist und ich denke, Apple wird da was tun, was ist mit?
Genau, jetzt ist die Frage, wie? Weil diese Stabilität, die sie jetzt haben, die haben sie deshalb, weil sie da ihr Aluteil haben. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das Gerät voll gepackt ist mit Zeug.
Akku ist da halt drinne.
Na gut, aber Akku, naja.
Weniger Akku reintun, nur wenn...
Geht gar nicht.
Ja, machen sie nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass es leichter wird.
Ich will, dass es leichter wird.
Haben sie nicht beim iPhone 4 gesagt, dass der Bildschirm leichter ist, weil er dünner ist und so? War doch nicht was?
Also er ist dünner, weil der Bildschirm und diese Glasfronten miteinander verklebt sind.
Genau, das ist jetzt irgendwie eins, was vorher irgendwie zwei Schichten war.
War das nicht beim MacBook Air das Ding? Also bei MacBook Air war es auf jeden Fall auch irgendwas mit Reinraum und was, was, was, was.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das Ding noch nie so aufgemacht.
Immer noch nicht.
Aber meine Voraussage ist, es wird etwas leichter sein.
Etwas.
Ja, was ist denn etwas? 10%, 20%?
Doch, 20% mindestens.
Ich würde eher so, was wiegt das jetzt? Was war das? 600, 700?
680.
Ohne 3G, ne?
Genau, das 3G wiegt 730.
Wahrscheinlich machen sie es minimal leicht, aber wirklich nicht viel.
Also ich sage weniger, aber nicht weniger als, also sie schaffen nicht mehr Ersparnis als 10%.
Also sie werben damit, dass es leichter ist, aber es ist nicht viel. Und es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schwerer.
Ich will ein halbes Kilo.
Same, bisschen drüber.
Nix ist.
Die müssen alle Blutniedel-Ding haben wollen, ist doch klar. Hat sich durchgesetzt, ist gut. Konkurrenz ist keine da, da geht der Preis da hoch.
Ist doch logisch.
Denn das hat heute echt so den...
Der Preis geht nicht hoch.
Klar. Im iPhone 4 auch ein bisschen hoch.
Äh, trotzdem.
Auch so ein Display ist teuer mit dein doppelten Auflöser. Kannst nicht alles für umsonst haben, das geht nicht.
Nee, nicht umsonst, aber ich denke, dass...
Und das ist ein gutes Produkt, da kann man auch mal Geld von nehmen, wird sich der Steve denken, und das ist auch so.
Ich glaube, das genau Gegenteil wird passieren.
500 Dollar ist einfach eine magische Grenze. Also dieses 4,99, das ist einfach eine strategische Ansage.
Ich glaube, der erste Preis war schon ein ganz schöner Kampfpreis.
Glaube ich überhaupt nicht.
Doch, das ist auf definitiv einen Kampfpreis, aber sie sind die Einzigen, die sich diesen Kampfpreis leisten können, weil sie einfach diese ganze Produktion von allem so im Griff haben.
Die Marge ist danach wie vorgigantisch bei dem Teil.
Die Einzigen, die auch wirklich das Development machen von diesem ganzen Baukram.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass wir mit der nächsten Generation auf Masse gehen, also ich hab hier einen extrem Anteil an deiner Firma und du musst die Preise hoch machen, sonst bin ich als Aktionär nicht das Beste.
Du sagst, es wird teurer. Die Aktionäre interessiert nicht der Verkaufspreis, die Aktionäre interessiert die Marge.
Schon klar.
Von daher ist der Preis egal, wenn die Marge stimmt.
Ja, aber wenn der Preis ein bisschen höher ist und die Ausgaben für das Gerät gleich bleiben, dann steigt auch die Marge.
Ja, aber wenn der Preis ein bisschen höher ist, dann werden weniger Leute so ein iPad kaufen, die sich sonst eins gekauft hätten.
Die können doch gar nicht dafür produzieren, wie Leute dieses Ding haben wollen.
Mittlerweile schon.
Ja, weil jetzt alle aufs Neue warten.
Jetzt ist Weihnachten, mein Freund.
Okay, jetzt sag ich auch nochmal. Ich sag, dass sich relativ wenig ändern wird. Die Display-Auflösung wird gleich bleiben. Es wird eine Kamera eingebaut, klar.
Eine Frontkamera für Facetime.
Genau, so Facetime-Kamera als unsere Ehe.
Moment, bleiben wir einfach mal beim Preis und gehen wir das mal Feature für Feature durch. Wir können gleich die Kamerasachen machen. Was sagst du, wird es teurer, bleibt es gleich, wird es billiger?
Billiger. Du?
Okay, ich bin unentschlossen. Ich sage, es wird auf keinen Fall teurer.
5% teurer.
Und maximal 10% billiger. Also sowas wie 4,49 als Einstiegspreis. Zumal...
Alte wird es als...
Genau, das Alte, das kann ich mir nicht auch vorstellen, dass sie das Alte für 400 rauskloppen.
Genau.
Das ist forschbar. Und dann würden sie aber mit dem neuen bei 500 bleiben. Also die halten auf jeden Fall den Preis.
Halten oder 5% drüber?
Kamera?
Klar, Facetime.
Eine, zwei?
Ich würde ja sagen zwei.
Ich würde ja glatt sagen nur eine. Weil zum Fotos machen ist das Ding einfach bekloppt. Und dann reicht eine Front. Und wenn du dann wirklich ein Foto machen willst, dann kannst du immer noch umdrehen.
Was ich mich ja frage ist...
Eine.
Wo?
Wo ist diese... Wo ist die FaceTime-Kamera? Wo bauen sie diese Frontkamera ein?
Na dahin, wo jetzt der Helligkeitssensor ist.
Wo ist der Helligkeitssensor?
Na da oben, wo man den Helligkeitssensor...
Du meinst, weil du das iPad so halten kannst, wie du willst.
Wo ist denn oben?
Gegenüber vom Homebutton würde ich auch sagen.
Würde ich auch sagen.
Och. Würde ich auch sagen.
Ja, aber was heißt denn das? Das heißt, wenn du das Ding quer hältst...
Komm mal klar. Oder das wäre natürlich... Das wir natürlich machen könnten, dass sie tatsächlich eine für Hochkant und eine für Portrait-Modus drin haben. Also beide auf die Person gerichtet. Ich quatsch. Damit du deine drehen kannst, damit du es dann so hältst. Wenn du es so seitlich hältst, weil das hältst du ja noch eher so und hast dann so die Handflächen über den Bezels an der Seite, wo dann auch die Kamera wäre.
Wäre dann hier auch so, aber...
Ja, aber du hältst das iPhone anders. Ich halte das iPad regelmäßig mal und ich könnte mir eventuell vorstellen, dass hier oben noch eine zweite Kamera drin ist und dass er dann einfach die Kamera wechselt, je nachdem, was gerade teuer ist.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Was kostet so eine Kamera?
Viel.
Drei Dollar?
Voll viel im Verhältnis zu dem ganzen Rest.
Also ich wäre für zwei Kameras.
Der iPod hat zwei Kameras.
Was für eine Kamera?
Na hinten eine gute, vorne eine FaceTime-Kamera. Weil ich will halt auch nicht dauernd Geräte wechseln. Also ich will jetzt nicht nur mein iPhone rausholen, um ein Foto zu machen. Dann muss ich das aufs iPad schieben, damit ich das auf dem iPad in meine Pages-Dings reinziehen kann. Oder was weiß ich.
Also ich sag FaceTime-Kamera okay. Meinetwegen auch eine gute. Also eine gute Kamera, so wie beim iPhone die gute Kamera ist und die FaceTime-Kamera ist schlechter beim iPhone, oder? Okay, ich würde sagen, es ist nur eine drin, die ist aber unter anderem schnell gut. Aber es ist definitiv nur eine. Das iPad, das ist einfach auch so ein Gerät, das ist in so einer Hülle.
Aber gab es jetzt hier nicht die neuen Hüllen mit Kameraloch?
Ach, was wissen die denn da? Die raten, du glaubst doch nicht, dass Apple diesen Taiwan-Hüllen-Buden erzählt hat.
Aber die haben recht gehabt bisher.
Die haben auf jeden Fall recht gehabt.
Die haben bessere Tracker-Rekorde.
Die haben aber auch genauso. Ja, ich meine, die haben vielleicht einfach richtig geraten.
Nee, die haben nicht richtig geraten, die haben die exakten Maße gehabt.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass die das erzählt bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die das nicht mehr erzählen. Allein schon deshalb, die wissen nichts. Beim iPad war das doch auch so, da war doch alle überrascht. Da war kein einziges Höhlenteil am Start.
Ja, aber bei den vollen Geräten dann immer schon. Also bei den iPods zumindest.
Beim iPhone 4 war das auch nicht so.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, also bei den diversen iPod-Nanos gab es auf am Anfang keine andere Hülle außer die von Apple angekündigte.
Bei den diversen iPod-Nanos gab es auf der IFA regelmäßig schon von Hammer irgendwelche Hüllen zu sehen, die dann perfekt gestimmt haben. Die schlicht und ergreifend die richtigen Hüllen waren. Schon vorproduziert.
Auf jeden Fall, die, die es jetzt gibt, müssen nicht die richtigen sein. Das kann man ja schon mal so festhalten.
Die könnten vielleicht auch für ein anderes Gerät sein.
Ich sage, eine Kamera, FaceTime nach vorne. Dennis sagt auch eine, oder?
Ich will zwei.
Ich sage ein oder zwei, auf jeden Fall beide nach vorne.
Ein oder zwei ist keine Aussage.
Keine nach hinten raus.
Also eine.
Eine mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Lightpeak.
Bauen sie einen zweiten Dog-Connector ein?
Einen zweiten, sie bauen einen Lightpeak ein.
Ich hätte gerne einen zweiten.
Nein, sie bauen keinen zweiten ein. Weil? Weil ich glaube, dass es zu viele Komplikationen gibt, mit welches Gerät man wo anschließt. Also dass man dann plötzlich zwei USB-Kabel dran hängen hat und so was, und weil das zu irgendwelchen Komplikationen führt.
Weil du als zwei Rechner einen iPad anschließen könntest.
Wo soll denn das Problem sein, wenn du zwei USB-Kabel an deinem Computer hast?
Weil du die zwei USB-Kabel an zwei verschiedenen Computern haben könntest.
Oder dass du das irgendjemand bei zwei USB-Kabel über zwei USB-Anschlüsse an seinem Mac anschließt und dann sich wundert, warum, oder weiß er toll was?
Ich glaube auch nur einen.
Ich glaube nur einer.
Ich hätte ja gerne einen zweiten.
Ich weiß, dass du gerne einen zweiten hättest, aber kriegst du den.
Allein weil einfach eine Killer-Up für das Teil ist einfach Bilderrahmen. Und ich will Bilderrahmen quer.
Das ist keine Killer-Up für einen Bilderrahmen.
Doch.
Nicht mal für Bilderrahmen war Bilderrahmen eine Killer-Up.
Ein Freund von mir hat mir gerade erzählt, er hätte sich jetzt irgendwie ein billiges 150 Euro Android-Houjimin-Teil gekauft, um es als Bilderrahmen zu verwenden. Und zwar nicht, weil er das für die tollste Anwendung hält, sondern weil es diese Bilderrahmen nicht mehr gibt auf dem Markt.
Wie, die sind ausgestorben?
Ja, er meinte, 20 Euro Bilderrahmen? Nee, 20 Euro mag schon noch da sein, aber in so einem Midrange-Bereich, wo das Display auch was taugt. Ist ja nicht so, dass du jetzt für 20 Euro ein geiles Display kriegst, was du von allen Seiten gut einsehen kannst etc. Ich hab's nicht überprüft, das war seine Aussage. Er meint einfach, diese Bilderrahmen kriegen jetzt aus dieser Tablettecke einfach Konkurrenz. Aus dieser Billigtablettecke. Und für mich war das schon, also das war das erste, was ich mir gewünscht habe, dass ich das so quer auf so ein Dock, wo es lädt, draufstecken kann. Und dass es quer vor mir ist, damit ich da drauf schauen kann. Damit ich das als Bildschirm, der quer vor mir ist und der lädt, die ganze Zeit da so habe, als Terminal, als Überwachungsmonitor, als Kontrollpad, was auch Video abspielt.
Als Überwachungsmonitor. Mach einfach mehr Fotos im Hochformat.
Warum nicht? Das ist das, was man mit dem iPad wunderbar machen kann. Nur, dass es immer forciert ist, dass wenn es in so einem Dock steht, dass es senkrecht stehen muss. Ich finde, es sollte auch quer stehen.
Aber der Anwendungsfall ist nicht, dass es als Display vor dir steht, sondern dass du es in der Hand hältst und damit arbeitest.
Das ist der eine Anwendungsfall und der andere ist der, den ich gerade beschreibe. Da habe ich eine Menge Ideen, wie man das verwenden könnte. Ich würde das einfach gerne haben wollen. Ich glaube allerdings trotzdem, dass er nicht kommt. Ich hätte ihn aber gerne.
Hast du jetzt eingetragen, als kommt nicht?
Und ist es Lightpeak?
Du schreibst jetzt eigentlich nur deine Politik, oder auch unsere?
Soll ich jetzt hier eine Tabelle aufmachen für alle?
Du machst ein Doodle hinterher und dann posten wir das dazu.
Und wann wird es kommen, das Gerät?
Erstmal ist die Frage, ob Lightpeak oder nicht.
Kein Lightpeak.
Wir machen Doodle, dann kann jeder nochmal drüber nachdenken.
Ein Doodle, wo wir hier auch unseren schönen Termin abgesprochen haben letztens.
Kennst du nicht? Doodle?
Doch, Dennis hat auch gedudelt.
doodle.com Das ist immer noch das Einzige, das ist irgendwie völlig bekloppt. Ja, ohne Jump. doodle.com ist einfach eine Webseite, die nicht das tut, was der Name nachlegt, sondern das ist einfach so eine Site, wo du so ein, wie soll man das beschreiben?
So eine Matrix von Optionen und...
Genau, nach Person hat und jeder kann so verschiedene Features anklicken. Es geht primär, denke ich, der Haupteinsatz dafür ist, sich auf gemeinsame Termine zu einigen. Weil du halt einfach zu einem Set von vorgeschlagenen Terminen, kannst du sagen, da kann ich, da kann ich nicht, da kann ich nicht, da kann ich nicht. Das ist ganz praktisch. Das sollte mal bloß jemand ordentlich machen. Weil es nervt irgendwie, das ist irgendwie auch hässlich.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Haben wir jetzt schon alles beim iPad? Was ist denn noch dran an diesem Gerät?
Was hast du denn zum Lightpeak?
Was, was, was, was, was, Lightpeak? Ah, Mini Display Port hätte ich ja gerne.
Der weicht aus zu dem Lightpeak, Tim weiß was. Was? Lightpeak? Ja.
iPad, Lightpeak, bringst du das zusammen?
Ja, es wird doch gerumort, dass es einen neuen Dock-Connector gibt und der auf Lightpeak basiert.
Wird das gerumort?
Wo soll der sich an-connecten dann?
An die anderen Millionen Lightpeak.
Vor allem in Windows, wo sie ihre meisten Geräte hin verkaufen.
Die Lampe flimmert. Das würde für den zweiten Dock-Connector sprechen. Im Dock gibt's Lightpeak. Und das kannst du damit...
Wo sollen die denn hin-connecten?
Deinen Audio-Lichtglas-optischen...
Ach so, damit man endlich... Qualitativ hochwertiges Audio mit dem iPad übertragen kann.
Wie war das bei Firewall? Mit irgendwas müssen wir anfangen, ne?
Ja, aber nicht ausgerechnet mit einem Gerät, was hinten dran hängt.
Vielleicht jetzt mal, wie sieht's denn aus mit dem Air-Dock? Patentieren lassen.
Air-Dock. Kein Mensch, der uns zuhört, weiß überhaupt, was Lightpeak ist.
Doch, haben wir doch die letzten Podcasts schon erwähnt.
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Das ist so eine total langweilige Intel-Technologie, über die angeblich alles laufen wird, aber die erst mal auf den Markt kommen muss.
Bist du sicher, dass wir darüber geredet haben?
Also letztes Mal schon, ja.
Ich hab's notiert gehabt, aber es kam meines Wissens nicht dran.
Ich wusste ja auch nichts. Tja, das war ja bis schon vorletzte Sendung.
Gibt's da, in der Chat, haben wir letztes Mal über Lightpeak geredet?
Wollen wir jetzt erstmal überhaupt noch an den nächsten iPad Lightpeak dranstecken?
Ich will mal einen Bold-Prediction machen. Ah, okay. Der Chat wird schon obszön. Weil das Firewire ist jetzt mit Ethernet der dickste Connector halt und die müssen beide weg.
Aber das ist ein MacBook, das ist das iPad.
Ja, aber die iPads werden ja ans MacBook angeschlossen. Und USB 3 haben sie scheinbar auch kein Bock, die Apple-Jungs.
Ja, aber Firewire kommt hier sowieso nie ran.
Ja, das ist schon klar, aber...
Ich schmeiß noch nicht den Dock-Connector weg für irgendwelches Lightpeak.
Nee, der Dock-Connector, also ja.
Und dann noch ein zusätzlicher Ausgang. Ja, wir haben jetzt USB, was uns alle immer haben wollten, das haben wir nicht, und Audio-In haben wir nicht, was alle immer haben wollten. Dafür haben wir jetzt was keiner hat, Lightpeak.
Denken wir mal bitte nicht so technologieorientiert, sondern denken wir mal anwendungsorientiert. Was ist falsch am iPad, was neu gemacht werden muss?
Also bei mir ist es nur Gewicht und Display hauptsächlich. Ich sage...
Und die Kamera. Was kann denn das iPhone, was das iPad nicht kann? 3G hat's, das kann nicht tazern. Okay, das ist alles eine Software-Frage.
Der Gyro, weiß nicht, ob das so nötig ist.
Ist das nicht, ist noch nicht drin?
Der hat doch einen Gyro, oder?
Das ist ein Gyro schon?
Ach nee, stimmt, das war iPhone 4.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja, ja, dann kriegt er noch einen Gyro.
Der kriegt einen Gyro, definitiv. Gyro ist dabei, das ist klar. Nee, Gyro ist dabei.
Will ich nicht.
Besserer Lautsprecher, keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr, was meine Vorhersage ist für das nächste iPad? Das wird das Massengerät. Das wird billiger sein. Und das wird im Wesentlichen das gleiche Gerät sein wie bisher. Also bis auf Kleinigkeiten, vielleicht ein bisschen schnellerer Prozessor, vielleicht so viel RAM, wie das iPhone hat. Dualcore, weiß ich noch nicht.
Genau, sie bauen da ein A5-Dualcore ein.
A4, ich glaube, die sind jetzt auf den Namen A4 gerade noch so spannend, dass das A5 kommt.
Vielleicht ist das A4 Duo.
Vielleicht A4 Duo.
Nee, die machen nicht so ein beklopptes Name.
A5 auf Basis von...
Sie werden sagen A5 und die werden nicht mal damit werben, dass es ein Dualcore ist.
Nee, das werden sie nicht. Da schreiben sie nur drauf, dass es der schnellste und tollste ist.
Das wird nicht irgendwo stehen, wenn es am Straßenlaternen-Fall hast. Das wird nicht auch in der Werbung auftauchen, jetzt mit Dualcore, aber das wird es dich natürlich schon erzählen.
Ich bin Ad-Blocker für dieses Gesicht da auf Wikipedia.
Das ist ein Neues.
Jetzt haben sie diesen Pavel Richter da draufgeholt.
Das ist wirklich furchtbar.
Warum muss man die ganze Zeit angestarrt werden, wenn der Wikipedia was nachschlägt?
Weil das Vertrauen einen weckt.
Und warum haben die keinen Flatter-Button stattdessen?
Ja, und warum kann man das nicht dauerhaft entfernen?
Ja, ich hab schon diese Extension installiert, irgendwie No More Jimmy Wales, und jetzt schicken sie mir...
Jetzt kriegst du noch nicht mehr, siehst du?
Jetzt schickst du mir Pavel Richter. Jetzt brauch ich noch die No More Pavel Richter. Die ändern das auch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, aber jetzt mach ich erst mal kurz weiter. Meinetwegen etwas schnelleren Prozessor, etc., PP. Was aber das Eigentliche sein wird, ist, dass das sozusagen der Angriff auf den Massenmarkt wird. Und zwar, dass sie von dem Teil wirklich richtig viele verkaufen wollen. Das wollen sie groß machen. Das ist noch nicht groß genug, weil so die Apps sind noch nicht ganz so geil wie auf dem iPhone, weil ich glaube, es gibt nämlich einfach nach wie vor...
Was?
Es gibt unglaublich viele Apps, die einfach bisher nur fürs iPhone entwickelt werden.
Es gibt unglaublich viele Apps, die nur fürs iPad entwickelt werden.
Was? Und was sind denn so die geilen, wirklich guten Anwendungen auf dem iPad? Das ist noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Also ich meine, Spiele zum Beispiel, die meisten Spiele, die kommen, kommen...
Außer Wetter und Aktien gibt es da fast nix.
Also, erstmal gibt es hervorragende iPad-Varianten. Twitter vor iPad zum Beispiel ist super, ja. Dann gibt es einfach eine ganze Batterie von Super Synthesizers und solchen Music-Creation-Sachen und Mixern.
Rebirth.
Fernsteuerungssoftware. Das ist einfach auf dem iPad echt geil.
Es gibt ein paar geile Apps dafür, aber die eigentlich coolen Sachen kommen nach wie vor immer noch. Alle zuerst fürs iPhone.
Na, es gibt Sachen, die gibt es nur fürs iPad.
Ja, es gibt Sachen, die gibt es nur fürs iPad, aber es gibt viel mehr Sachen, die gibt es nur fürs iPhone. Wenn irgendein Spiel kommt, dann...
Na ist ja egal, es hat ja nichts darüber aus, dass die Apps nicht toll sind.
Ist ja noch nicht genug. Der Markt ist noch nicht groß genug. Also es gibt fürs iPhone wesentlich mehr geile Apps als fürs iPad.
Das kann sogar sein.
Ja, aber mehr ist ja nicht entscheidend. Entscheidend ist ja, haben die Apps schon genug Traktion, das iPad als solches voranzubringen? Und ich denke über diesen Punkt sind wir schon lange hinaus.
Das mag ja sein, aber das ist noch nicht genug. Sie wollen, ich glaube, also, lass mich einfach mal eine Vorhersage machen und dreh dich nicht mal rein.
Was ist denn die Vorhersage?
Die Vorhersage ist, dass das ein Massenprodukt wird.
Du redest mit Tim, das muss dir schon klar sein.
Darum wird es billiger und darum wird es endlich wirklich für jedermann nutzbar sein. Und zwar, das eigentlich wichtige Problem ist eigentlich mehr ein Softwareproblem. Es wird einrichtbar sein, ohne dass man einen Computer dazu braucht. Das wird nutzbar sein.
Standalone Funktion.
Das heißt, Over-the-Air-Update.
Ihr wisst schon, dass es hier um Apple geht. Seit wann geht Apple nach dem Massenmarkt? Und das wird irgendwie billiger und so.
Apple hat vom iPhone, wie lange nach der Einführung haben die den Preis gesenkt um 100 Dollar oder 200 Dollar?
Ich bin da nicht überzeugt.
Das iPhone ist wirklich, drei Wochen nachdem es rauskam, ist es um 200 Dollar billiger geworden.
Ja, weil sie am Anfang voll daneben gelegen haben.
Nö, weil sie gesehen haben, dass es jetzt schon einschlägt und nicht erst nach einer Weile.
Das heißt, das iPad ist nicht eingeschlagen und deswegen sind sie nicht mit dem Preis runter?
Das iPad ist schon mit dem Preis runter.
Das ist gleich schon mit runter Preis angefangen, meint er. Und warum ist das iPhone jetzt am Ende teurer geworden?
Weil es die nächste Generation in der Produktion teurer ist.
Weil sie die Bumper so umfassinieren mussten, die sie wegen dem Tennergeld gratis raus tun mussten.
Wieviel teurer? Wovon reden wir jetzt eigentlich?
30 Euro, 5%?
Euro? Naja, Euro ist nicht aussagekräftig. Dollar ist aussagekräftig.
5% ist es teurer geworden, circa.
Und da haben sie ein bisschen teure Matsrereien genommen.
Nobody cares a shit bei so einem subventionierten Teil, ob das jetzt irgendwie in seinem Ruhmskreis 5% teurer ist. 5% ist echt eine Schwankung. Wie muss man im Kontext der Währungsverschiebung und des Zustandes des amerikanischen Marktes und dem Verhältnis zwischen China und den USA sehen und nicht so sehr jetzt mit, oh das Gerät ist teurer geworden. 5% spielt da echt keine Rolle.
Also ich glaube, dass sie jetzt das erste Jahr haben, sie mit dem iPad erstmal so die ganzen uns early Adapter gemolken. Und damit wir so einen Zeitlang haben, die Einzelne zu sein, die das rumzurennen. Und ab nächsten Jahr wird es so sein, dass wenn man in die S-Bahn oder in die U-Bahn einsteigt, man sieht, oh nicht schon wieder einer mit dem iPad. Genauso wie es jetzt mit dem iPhone der Fall ist. Das wird, das ist noch lange nicht da, wo Steve das hin will.
Ich hab so viele iPads gesehen in den letzten Wochen.
Ja, ich hab auch viele gesehen.
Überall von Leuten, die das rausgezogen haben. Irgendwie als ich aus, wo komm ich her, aus Schottland, Flugzeug, da saß so eine ältere Frau neben mir. Und zog auf einmal ein iPad raus und fing an ein Buch zu lesen.
Ja, aber nix im Vergleich zum iPhone.
Ich war da beim iPhone, da war keiner, der auf dem iPhone ein Buch gelesen hat.
Machen sie andere Dinge auf ihrem iPhone. Aber iPhone ist wirklich mittlerweile...
Da muss man ja nicht sagen, dass es mehr iPhones verkauft sind als iPads, das weiß ich auch. Aber die Behauptung, dass es sich bei dem iPad jetzt noch nicht um ein Massenprodukt handeln würde, halte ich für sehr gewagt.
Nicht ein Massenprodukt wie Apple Assemble.
Wir drehen uns im Kreis.
Ja, aber lass mich mal meine Prediction einfach aufschreiben.
Ja, was war denn die Prediction?
Gleiches Gerät, Standalone, Frontkamera, mehr oder weniger.
Und wie funktioniert das mit dem Standalone? Du kaufst es und dann?
Du kaufst es, kannst das irgendwie Overseer aktivieren, kannst dir da dein iTunes-Account anlegen, wenn du magst. Overseer Updates gehören natürlich dazu, die übernehmen sie jetzt vom Apple TV. Und dann brauchen sie noch irgendeine Backup-Möglichkeit. Da haben sie auf der einen Seite Time Machine. Nein, nein, nein, Cloud. Also du kannst dir deine Apps sowieso wieder runterladen, wenn dein Gerät flöten geht.
Das ist ja schon jetzt kein Problem.
Du kriegst deine Musik wieder, wenn du sie hast.
Du meinst dieses neue Rechenzentrum ist unter anderem ein Backup, ein Time Machine Cloud Storage Backup für iPad?
Was hast du da großartig drauf? Da hast du ein paar Fotos drauf. An eigenen Materialien. Du hast ein bisschen Musik drauf, die du im Idealfall sowieso bei iTunes gekauft hast. Vielleicht machen sie es ja auch so nur für bei iTunes gekaufte Musik ist der Backup Service gültig. Du kriegst ein paar Fernsehsälen wieder und ein paar Spielereinstellungen müssen du speichern. Viel mehr ist das doch gar nicht. Lass das pro Gerät in Summe, also im Diff zu anderen Geräten, 300, 400, naja bei Bildern 2, 3 GB sein. Das kostet dir nicht die Welt.
Was sie bei iTunes kauften, bräuchten sie bei iTunes nicht wirklich zu speichern, sondern sich nur merken.
Genau, das merken sie sich eh schon. Sie müssen bloß die Lizenzvereinbarung ändern, dass es dir wieder zum Download anbieten, wenn du es verloren hast.
Beziehungsweise, ja, genau.
Das könnte durchaus passieren. Das könnte passieren.
Aber Backup, alles in MobileMe, in die iDisk sozusagen rein.
Wie gesagt, so wahnsinnig viel ist es doch gar nicht.
Nee, das stimmt schon.
Das muss kommen. Habt ihr euch mal dieses Chrome OS, Google hat jetzt diesen Chrome-Laptop-Prototypen vorgestellt.
Sind wir durch mit dem iPad? Haben wir schon alles vorher gesagt?
Also meine Vorhersage ist auf jeden Fall, ja.
Also Standalone, iPad fände ich auch gut. Das wäre auf jeden Fall, da würde ich auch meinen Namen drunter schreiben.
Zieht das schon jemand mal live?
Nee, Richard hat gesagt, das ist Müll und dann nehme ich das nicht.
Also ich hab's mir irgendwann mal, also vor ganz, ganz... Wobei, er hat dem jetzt eigentlich den Punkten durchaus recht.
Was, wie, was, was, was?
Richard Storman hat gesagt, dass es scheiße ist, weil man soll seine Daten nicht der Cloud anvertrauen, sondern lieber selber drauf aufpassen.
Der lebt noch? Oh, das ist ein besser Wisser, ey.
Ja, aber die IT-Handschaft ist ja nun voll mit so ein Eifertierchen. Ja, er hat nen Punkt. Er hat nen Punkt.
Aber er ist wirklich auch so ein... Hast du den mal live erlebt?
Ich hab neulich, ich hab neulich Geschichten darüber gehört, wie er bei jemandem...
Das ist schon mal so ein... Das ist schon mal einen... Einen schlimmeren Giftswerk getroffen?
Ich hab neulich jemand getroffen, der ihn mal für ne Woche bei sich beherbergt hat und...
Oh, die Leute stöhnen alle.
Der hat dann gekotzt.
Alle, alle Leute, wo der ne Woche war, sagen immer sowas wie Warum hat mich keiner gewarnt?
Er wurde gewarnt, aber... Das ist nicht wahr. Das war noch klümer als er dachte.
Was macht der denn so?
Der ist einfach, der ist einfach... Der ist einfach der totale Autist. Der hat einfach keinerlei Social Skills.
Also wie alle Nerds so.
Ja, der puppt alle sofort an, die er nicht kennt und schreit die gleich an. Ja, ich war irgendwie, das erste Mal, ich ihn getroffen habe, da hatte ich irgendwie gerade eine Kippe in der Hand. Erster Satz, den er zu mir sagt, do you know you're killing yourself? Wieso? Ist das so interessant, ob ich das weiß? Oder nicht weiß irgendwie? Was interessiert das ihn? Er will halt gleich in das Hirn rein. Das ist irgendwie echt so ein komischer Vogel. Und dann muss er immer seine Schuhe ausziehen und irgendwie... Lass uns nicht über Richard Stormen reden.
Ja, wir wollten auch über Chromos reden.
Genau, wir wollten über Chromos reden.
Also ich hab mir irgendwann mal vor Ewigkeiten, also man kriegt das ja im Augenblick eigentlich gar nicht. Man hat diesen PC, diesen Laptop, den Google da verteilt oder verschenkt oder verkloppt oder wie auch immer, so in begrenzter Stückzahl, den gibt's und da ist das drauf. Aber ansonsten so runterladen kann man sich das ja nirgendwo. Man kann die Quellen runterladen und sich selber kompilieren. Weiß ich aber auch nicht, wie aktuell die im Augenblick sind. Und da hab ich mal vor Ewigkeiten mit, das war schon September oder so was, oder vielleicht noch früher mir mal so eine Version von Vanilla runtergeladen und mir die mal angeguckt. Und ja, es ist halt ein Fullscreen-Chrome. Das ist im Wesentlichen ist es das. Also es ist, loggst dich ein mit deinem Google-Account auf dem Ding und dann hast du da dein Chrome und kannst da mit rumsurfen. Und das ist, das war's. Und das nicht mehr, nicht weniger. Und ja, wobei was, was die eben haben, darum komme ich auf dieses Standalone, weil was ich glaube, was bei denen wirklich das tolle Argument ist, die haben jetzt so ein kleines Werbevideo gemacht, was jetzt nur mittelmäßig lustig war. Aber was eben auf diesen eigentlichen, auf diesen eigentlichen Einsatzzweck dieses Geräts hindeutet, das nehme ich, dass sie, dass sie alles in der Cloud speichern. Du kaufst dir das Gerät und dann, und du lässt einen LKW über deinen Laptop rüberfahren. Und ohne, dass du dich jemals um Backup kümmern musstest, holst du dir das, holst dir den Nachfolger, holst dir ein neues Gerät und logst dich ein. Und du hast alles wieder da, wo du es hattest. Und hast deine Google Docs da. Und Google arbeitet daran schon seit Ewigkeiten. Und Apple muss da definitiv hinkommen.
Muss wo hinkommen?
Dass du ein Standalone-Gerät hast. Dass du da nicht einen Mac brauchst, um ein iPad zu verwalten. Weil das albern ist.
Ja, ist die Frage, ob das nur mit Cloud geht. Also ob das wirklich so the only way ist.
Es gibt ja auch Möglichkeiten, dass du das nicht so einem großen Konzern anvertraunst, sondern das auch selber machst und so. Da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt wirklich der Weg ist, alles Google zu geben oder alles Amazon zu geben. Sondern ich vermute schon, dass du das jetzt so auf Amazon-Storage oder irgendwelchen Storage-Providern basierst. Du dir aber irgendwie deine eigene Syncing-Appliance da gekryptet irgendwo hin tun kannst, sodass du irgendwie noch selber trotzdem noch die Kontrolle drüber hast. Dass jetzt Google halt nicht deinen Stuff auch komplett durchforsten könnte, sondern eben du deinen Kino hast und du nur da rankommst und du musst deine Passphrase angeben. Dafür kannst du aber auf allen Geräten synken. Also sowas gibt es ja hier zum Beispiel dieses Tar-Snap. Heißt das so? Tar-Snap, dieses von diesen FreeBestie-Typen. Der auf Amazon S3, der hat so eine Backup-Lösung gehackt und du bezahlst, also der speichert das auch auf Amazon S3, ist aber alles gekryptet. Gibt es für Allo Esse einen kleinen für?
Tar-Snap.
Snap, ich glaube Tar-Snap heißt das.
T-A-R Snap.
Und das, was man da bezahlt, damit supportet man auch noch das FreeBSD-Projekt. Das ist halt extrem wenig. Du zahlst da irgendwie extrem wenig so am Ende und du hast halt dein eigenes Krypto-Backup in der Cloud hoch verfügbar. Ich glaube, das heißt Tar-Snap. Ja, und so eine Lösung kann ich mir halt schon gut vorstellen, aber so oder so? Ja, also das ist halt in der Wolke, wenn eine Wolke passiert, halte ich schon für den.
Also das mag jetzt deine Lösung sein, das wird aber nicht die Lösung sein, die Apple ihren Oma und Opa anbietet, sondern ich glaube deren Option wird sein, entweder machst du das wie bisher über iTunes und dann kannst du es auf deinem eigenen Rechner haben oder du packst es eben bei denen in die Wolke.
Sagen wir, können die unsere Hörer, wollt ihr nicht mal alle, mal schnell eure Freunde auf Twitter und in den Chats einfach auch nochmal zu MobileMax einladen? Ich würde ja jetzt gerne nochmal die 500er-Hörer-Gruppe voll machen.
Also brauchen wir noch einen, oder?
Naja, da fehlen, also das ist hier ein bisschen schwer zu sehen, aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, fehlen noch 20 oder so.
Wir können doch selber mal twittern, dass ja alle mal vorbeikommen sollen.
Hab ich ja schon.
Ach, hast du schon?
Aber wenn jetzt noch 20 dazukommen, dann wären wir Rundfunk.
Und dann müssen wir gleich irgendwie...
Dann sind wir dran. Dann hätten wir nochmal so was richtig Verbotenes getan. So ist das einfach so strunzlegal. Macht überhaupt keinen Spaß.
Tar Snap, Online Backup, Vodde, Truly Paranoid. Wo waren wir jetzt? Also, Apple muss in die Cloud, Apple muss irgendwie Standalone werden.
Ich glaub, das wär so machen.
Also es gibt ja eine ganze Menge von diesen Diensten. Ich verlier ehrlich gesagt mittlerweile schon ein bisschen den Überblick. Mir wurde auch ein anderer nochmal nahegelegt, den noch nochmal zu testen. Pico Dollars.
Na, das ist halt...
Was ist denn das bitte für eine... 300 Pico Dollars per Byte Months.
Ja, das ist halt... Also du bezahlst wirklich extrem wenig. Also da unten ist eigentlich der wichtige Satz so. Also erstens ist es nicht auf Minimum Monthly Fees. Also wenn du nichts machst, bezahlst du nichts. Und TarasNet ist built only based on actual usage. If you only store a small amount of data, a five dollar payment might last you four years. Also wenn das halt nur für deine Keys und so ein Kram...
Also nicht so wie bei Dropbox, wo du sagst, damit ich überhaupt erst mal so viel Gigabyte zur Verfügung habe, auch wenn ich sie nicht benutze, muss ich sonst so viel bezahlen.
Ah ja.
Aha. Und das, was du bezahlst, kommt halt in ein paar Prozent auch der FreeBSD Foundation noch zugute. Aber die Kleinst, also er hat das OSX-Tool dazu, das hat auch ein Xcode-Project-File und so, das kann man so mit ein paar Klicks sich bauen. Gibt es bestimmt auch Binaries zu.
Ja, aber wie...
Die Frage ist, wie funktioniert das denn auf dem Mac?
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Ich meine, er macht das da jetzt nur so so ein Ersync und schreibt es dann da hin? Oder ist das jetzt wirklich so, ein Teil hat sich geändert, er holt sich den Kernel-Event und schreibt dann die Datei auch gleich hinterher?
Ich wollte also...
Ach, wie das mit ZFS.
Fragen über Fragen, Fragen über Fragen. Also genau kann ich sie auch nicht sagen. Ich bin letztens mal wieder darüber gestolpert und fiel mir jetzt gerade als erstes Einwurf um in the Cloud speichern und ob es jetzt nur bei Google oder Apple oder ob es eben vielleicht auch andere Sachen gibt.
As the name suggests, Tarsnap is closely related to TAR.
Also ich kenne...
Also Archive wegschreiben sozusagen. Das heißt du rufst Tarsnap anstatt TAR auf und schreibst sozusagen ein Archiv irgendwo hin. Na ja.
Also wie gesagt, das ist mir jetzt... Also noch benutze ich es zum Beispiel nicht, aber es gibt irgendwie Leute im Club, die das ganz toll finden.
Weil du eben so ein Krypto-Tar wegschreiben kannst und nur dafür bezahlst, was du wirklich...
Genau und das ist halt in der Cloud, das heißt selbst wenn da irgendwie eine Festplatte stirbt, ist nicht alles weg und so. Also es ist halt für wirklich sowas für Keys, die du wirklich nicht verlieren willst und so. Ist schon okay. Ist halt AES256 gekryptet.
Aber du musst schon noch deinen eigenen Key haben, sozusagen, um da überhaupt drauf zu greifen zu können.
Naja, irgendein Credential brauchst du schon, ja. Also du brauchst ja, so wie ich das verstanden hab, brauchst du auch keinen Key, sondern halt tatsächlich eher so eine Passphrase oder sowas. Naja, gut, das kann man sich nochmal in Ruhe angucken. Wir waren ja eigentlich bei, wo waren wir eigentlich gerade?
Ich muss noch was erzählen.
Wir waren bei Tarsnap.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz zuwarten, wo wir gerade bei diesen Diensten sind. Ich hatte ja, und ich hab gerade Blackout.
Hallo?
All profits made by Tarsnap in December will be donated to the FreeBSD Foundation. Bei FreeBSD tut sich gerade echt auch wieder so einiges, ne? Schön.
Wobei ich sie aber wimmern hören, wie das mit ZFS nicht vorangeht bei Oracle.
Aber ansonsten ist FreeBSD so viel cooler als Linux. Ich benutze ja jetzt gerade auf Arbeit immer mal wieder Linux-Note gedrungenermaßen. Und ich kann ja nicht verstehen, wie Leute Linux auf Servern einsetzen können. Das ist konsistent. Also bei Linux ist es halt so, vor allen Dingen bei diesen Debian und Ubuntu Geschichten, da gibt es halt immer so unterschiedlichste Wege, wie man so Dinge tun kann, und es ist nie ganz klar, welches Tool jetzt wirklich das Tool ist, um die Aufgabe zu lösen. Das fängt schon an bei so etwas wie Package Management. Da gibt es halt DEPKG, da gibt es aptitude, da gibt es aptget und aptcache, und was der Teufel, was du nicht noch alles machen kannst, um Pakete zu installieren und zu deinstallieren. Und die tun zwar im Prinzip das Gleiche, es steht zumindest das Gleiche drauf, aber es sind halt am Ende nur Wrapper um ein Tool. Und sie tun halt trotzdem irgendwie immer doch noch eine Sache anders, was dich dann in die Situation bringt, dass du mit einem Tool nur noch die Software deinstallieren kannst. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel so einen Postgres installiert und das ließ ich nicht mehr deinstallieren. Und das ging dann nur mit dpkg und minus f und hast du nicht gesehen und irgendwelchen force options war halt mit irgendwie aptitude installiert, keine Ahnung. Also da fängt es schon an. Dann finde ich ja bei Linux auch total furchtbar, dass sie in jedes Paket, also in ihre eigenen Patches rein machen muss. Also du kriegst halt einen Apache. Und es ist ein Apache, der nicht so ist, wie Apache den ausliefert. Also ich verstehe schon, was der Grund ist, warum sie jedes Paket anpassen und in ihren Einheitsbrei einmischen. Dass sich alles halt gleich verhält. Aber ich finde es halt kacke, auf allen Plattformen da draußen ein Apache zu installieren und weiß, wie er funktioniert. Nur auf Linux ist es halt komplett anders. Mit Sites enabled und hast du nicht gesehen. Und dann packen sie es in eigene Verzeichnisse. Da ist die HTTP-Conf was komplett anderes. Und sie haben noch eine Apache-Conf daneben gelegt und so ein Kram. Dann ihr Schizophrenes Verhalten mit User Bin, also ETC, User ETC, User Local, ETC und so. Also es ist nie auch ganz klar, welches Programm sich jetzt in welches Verzeichnis reinschreibt und so eine Geschichten. Es ist halt so von vorne bis hinten. Oder welche Firewall nimmt man auf Linux? Sagen halt alle, naja es gibt IP-Tables, aber das ist nicht ganz so einfach. Aber da gibt es noch Rapper, aber die benutzt keiner, weil die, oder die sollte man nicht benutzen, weil die können nicht alles oder machen irgendwas falsch und so. Also es ist halt von vorne bis hinten alles so ein...
Aber Huckel, das ist doch Freedom.
Furchtbar.
FreeBSD will dir doch nur die Wahl nehmen. Und deswegen ist es nicht free.
Ich weiß nicht, also irgendwie tatsächlich finde ich... Also ich benutze ja seit eh und je FreeBSD auf dem Server.
Ist jetzt ja genauso wie du. Also ich kann das total nachvollziehen. Es ist so ein bisschen eine Geschmacksfrage irgendwo auch, wo man sich einfach wohler fühlt. Und es gibt Leute, die fühlen sich einfach wohler, dass sie einfach zwar auch alles verkacken können, aber im 1000... Wir sind jetzt Rundfunk? Oh, jetzt geht's rund.
Meine Damen und Herren, die Tagesschau.
Echt, ihr habt alle eure Freunde eingeladen jetzt? Geil.
Macht jetzt noch mal so einen Spick nach oben. So, jetzt kommt er wieder raus.
Entweder müssen wir einen guten Witz machen oder sie freundlich begrüßen. Werbung! Wie macht man das im Kaufhof, wenn der hunderttausendste Gast im Kaufhof gerade reinkommt?
Nee, so nicht.
So bestimmt nicht.
Kommt alle ran, kommt alle ran hier!
Nee, da gibt's doch was zu gewinnen.
Kennt ihr am Kaufhof, am Alex, diesen Typen mit dem Zocken?
Also wir begrüßen auf jeden Fall den Unbekannten. Wir haben hier ein Mahnmal aufgestellt für den unbekannten 500. Hörer. Na, das soll ein Zeichen setzen. Das sollen sich alle merken.
Nie wieder darf ein Podcast von diesem Studio ausgehen, oder was?
Nein, in diesem Studio darf nie wieder ein Podcast ausgehen. Wir senden jetzt einfach dauerhaft 24 Stunden, weil wir dürfen nie wieder unter die 500er Marke fallen.
Ach so.
Sonst ist kein Rundfunk mehr. Ja, sonst ist kein Rundfunk mehr. Mann ey, dass das wirklich funktioniert, ich bin beeindruckt.
Ich hab noch was, jetzt wollen wir 500 Hörer haben, kann ich noch was erzählen kurz, weil ich hab nämlich was für eure iPhones gebaut, denn demnächst steht ja wieder der Kongress rein, wenn ihr hoffentlich alle Karten habt.
Du auch?
Nein.
Echt nicht? Kommst du nicht?
Du hast gesagt, ob ich eine brauche, oder?
Nee, hast.
Achso, ja, ich hab eine.
Hast du eine?
Ich glaub, wir sind versorgt.
Es gibt so viele, die keine haben.
Ja, es ist ganz furchtbar und grausam und schlimm, und wir leiden auch mit euch, wenn ihr...
Ich kann ja schon sagen, es gibt keine mehr.
Ich hab's auf einem ganz regulären Wege gemacht. Ich hab mich genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, ich saß sturzbetrunken in einer Cocktailbar und hab per iPhone mir mein Ticket gekauft, damit das auch wirklich alles gut geht und hab das dann am nächsten Tag sofort überwiesen. Also ich hab jetzt hier nicht irgendwelche Kontakte oder sowas, die ich nicht mal habe, genutzt.
Onkel, du bist doch so ein bisschen schuld. Kannst du nicht mal erzählen, was da überhaupt der Challenge war?
Darf ich?
Nee. Also letztes Jahr war ja so, da haben wir ja Presale gemacht und haben ja die Familie zuerst begünstigt. Da gab es auf internen... wissen schon. Also erst die Familietickets bekommen und dann den Rest so verscheuert und dann noch eine Abendkasse sozusagen. Und da haben sich ja ganz viele beschwert, erst mal, das geht ja gar nicht, dass hier die Familie begünstigt wird und die armen Leute da draußen nicht eine gleichberechtigte Chance haben. Deswegen soll es jetzt dieses Jahr eine gleichberechtigte Chance geben, das heißt...
Familie sind Mitglieder des TCT.
Genau. Und alle, die sich so dazu gehören. Naja, und dieses Jahr soll es halt gleichberechtigt sein, dass halt alle die gleiche Chance haben und deswegen gab es so einen öffentlichen Presale. Und das kennt man ja auch eigentlich von allen anderen Konferenzen, das ist ja eigentlich nichts Neues. Und das ist auch bei allen Konferenzen, die ein bisschen populär sind, so, dass man da auch ein bisschen schnell sein muss und dass es halt mehrere Badges gibt, aber dass diese Badges auch immer schnell weg sind. Aber das hat jetzt auch ganz vielen Leuten nicht gepasst. Und dazu kam dann...
Nicht Badges, sondern Badges, sozusagen. Wie war die Verteilung? Es gab drei Verkaufstermine?
Ja, das weiß ich alles nicht so genau, aber es gab drei Termine und dann halt...
Für uns so viel kontingente und es hat immer fünf Minuten gedauert, aber alles klar.
Das Problem ist halt, die Veranstaltung ist wahnsinnig populär so. Das BCC ist halt der einzige Veranstaltungsort, der eigentlich......in Frage kommt?... eigentlich in Frage kommt, genau. Und halt sehr limitiert ist in der Teilnehmerzahl.
Da dürfen halt nur 3000 Leute rein. Wenn man da mehr reinlässt, kriegt man Ärger mit der Feuerwehr und so weiter, Versicherung, die Betreiber wollen das auch nicht, deswegen 3000 mehr geht nicht. Rein, würde ich aber sagen, wollen bestimmt 4.000 oder 4.500. Nö, so viel mehr auch nicht.
Aber der letzte Konkret ist...
Keine 2000 Leute, die sich beschweren, dass sie kein Ticket kriegen, so ist es auch nicht.
Die beschweren sich nicht, aber die wollen.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwo auftauchen.
Ich würde auch tippen, dass wir mehr noch verkaufen können. Also deutlich mehr.
4.000 Leute reinkriegen, das ist kein Ding. Geht aber nun mal rechtlich nicht. Kann man nicht machen, gibts auf den Kopf.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist ja dieser Vorverkauf natürlich auch chaotisch-discordisch ein bisschen spät gestartet. Und dann gab es auch noch so komische Regelungen mit diesem 24-Stunden-Cool-Off und so. Interessiert die Hörer da bestimmt auch alles gar nicht so richtig.
Doch, 24-Stunden-Cool-Off?
Naja, das ist ja so. Beim CCC, da wollen wir ja alles ganz richtig machen mit den Daten und so weiter. Da hat sich ja, da haben wir uns überlegt. Ich hab mir das nicht überlegt. Ich hab es nur so in Teilen implementiert, aber dass die Leute halt keine personenbezogenen Credentials hinterlassen müssen. Sondern sie können sich mit irgendwas da anmelden, mit irgendeinem Namen, irgendeinem Passwort. Können halt sagen, hier sind meine Tickets. Und dann gibt es halt, kannst du die aber erst nach 24 Stunden auch wirklich klicken und kaufen, weil dann irgendjemand nochmal guckt, ob das nicht geskriptet ist und du...
Dass einer von einer IP-Adresse sich 1000 Tickets geklickt hat zum Beispiel. Damit die nicht bei Ebay landen und so. Da wurde nochmal handsortiert danach.
Das haben halt auch viele nicht verstanden. Das hätte ich auch nicht verstanden. Ich hätte halt erwartet, man geht da rauf, klickt sein Ticket, bezahlt und pengt. Aber dann hast du dich halt so... Jetzt geht der Pre-Sale los, okay, anmeld. Wie, jetzt muss ich 24 Stunden warten? Wenn du das genau zum Beginn des Pre-Sales gemacht hast, hast du, wie ich es gemacht hab, 24 Stunden nochmal warten müssen. Und Leute, die sich davor schon einen Account geklickt haben...
Haben dann schon den Batch weggekauft.
Also es war nach 24 Stunden schlicht und ergreifend nichts mehr da.
Und der Modus operandi des ganzen Pre-Sales war jetzt nicht so optimal. Hab ich mir jetzt aber auch nicht ausgedacht. Aber dass ein Pre-Sale da sein muss, finde ich schon gut. Weil letztes Jahr standen halt extrem viele Leute im Regen, sprichwörtlich. Weil sie halt nicht mehr reingekommen waren. Weil sie sind zu voll worden. Sie sind teilweise von sonst wo angereist. Und wenn du diesen Frust vermeiden willst, geht es halt nur damit, dass du Vorhärtigkeits verkaufst. Und die Leute dann wenigstens wissen, ob sie reinkommen oder nicht.
Ich hab schon so litermatische E-Mails gelesen....
aus entfernten Orten wie Spandau an und dann ist kein Ticket da.
Ich meine, das ist bei den Nerds halt aber auch so krass. Die gehen einfach so ab. Letztes Jahr schreien sie, wie Familie begünstigen. Das geht ja gar nicht. Wie dieses Jahr ist die Familie nicht begünstigt? Seid ihr total bescheuert?
Man muss ja nochmal dazu sagen, dass... Das mit Familie wird ja auch gemeint. Der Kongress ist ja schon auch eine Menge auf ehrenamtliche Mitarbeit angewiesen. Das sind diese sogenannten Engel. Und alle Leute, die sich halt die letzten Jahre bemüht haben und mitgeholfen haben, die kriegen dieses Jahr ein bisschen Vergünstigung. Weil die kriegen ja sonst nichts. Ich glaube, ein T-Shirt kriegen sie, aber sonst kriegen sie nichts. Die müssen auch Eintritt zahlen und alles andere. Die müssen da teilweise acht Stunden Schichten schieben und so weiter.
Also eine Vergünstigung im Sinne von, dass sie ein Ticket sicher hatten.
Genau. Bezahlen mussten die das auch, so ist es nicht. Aber sie haben halt garantiert eins bekommen. Sozusagen. Das war alles. Das sogenannte Golden Ticket.
Und jetzt können wir die Überleitung wieder zurück zu Max schieben, denn?
Genau. Für die paar Leute, die jetzt ein Ticket haben, ich hab mich immer so geärgert über die ganzen, oder was heißt geärgert? Ich fand die immer nicht so dolle, diese ganzen Eventplaner, die es so gab zum Thema, also dieses, wie hieß das das System da gleich? Pentabuff, diese Pentabuff-Standard-Ausgabe, diese HTML-Tabelle, die ist auf dem Rechner ganz okay, aber auf dem iPhone ist die ja quasi unläsbar.
Die ist auch sonst scheiße.
Und, was hab ich jetzt nicht gesagt, aber bei dir hab ich jetzt eigentlich gesagt, was alles auch gewundert.
Ich darf das sagen.
Und darum hab ich da eine iPhone-Seite zusammengebaut. Und zwar findet ihr die unter 27c3.343max.de. Und ich hab bei mir auf dem Blog auch einen kleinen Artikel dazu gebaut. Und die ist so, also man sieht immer, was ich immer das Wichtigste finde bei so einem Zeug, dass man eigentlich, man will ja eigentlich nur wissen, was ist jetzt und was fängt gleich an. Und darum ist das so eine Tabelle, es scrollt, wenn man es auf dem iPhone aufmacht, automatisch zu der entsprechenden Stelle hin, an der man sich gerade befindet. Also zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Man kann sich Veranstaltungen markieren. Und ich hab wirklich, ich glaube, ich hab ungelogen drei Wochen an dem Scroll-Mechanismus gesessen. Also nicht nur dafür, so wahnsinnig bin ich jetzt nicht, sondern ich hab ihn jetzt dafür noch ein bisschen verbessert. Achso, und man kann ihn schön so als App aufm Home-Screen legen. Und dann ist er quasi sofort da. Und ich werd's jetzt auch noch so umbauen, dass er dann auch offline funktioniert, falls das Netz grad nicht da ist oder ähnliches. Also ich hoffe mal, dass es damit dann geht, dass man gut informiert ist.
Loading, Loading, Loading.
Installiert euch jetzt mal. Geht jetzt mal drauf. Vielleicht ist jetzt mein Server schon down.
Was denkst du denn? 500 Hörer.
500?
Refreshed noch eigentlich, aber aufm Phone geht's grade nicht. Wahrscheinlich war der in WLAN wieder.
Mein WLAN, dein Server.
Nee, aufm Browser mit hier Kabel, Internet geht's super fluffig, aufm Phone jetzt ja nicht über WLAN, wa? Ja, check's einfach mal aus.
Wahrscheinlich bist du als Kind irgendwie in die WLAN-Strahlung gefallen und seitdem fällt überall das WLAN aus, wo du bist.
Ja, der ist Burgundianmitter, der Tim.
Ja, das bin ich.
Ich bin der Burgundianmitter.
Ein bisschen langsam ist es schon.
Ich bin schon müde.
Ich hab da so ein kleines... Und dieses Scrollkit, das ist ja, weil man, es ist ja im HTML, ist es ja nicht möglich zu scrollen. Ich glaube, das Thema hatten wir schon mal.
Im HTML ist es nicht möglich zu scrollen.
Du kannst nicht einen Bereich der Seite zum Scrollen definieren. Du kannst nicht sagen, hier ist ein Diff mit Overflow auf dem iPhone. Du kannst nicht einfach Rollbalken dranhängen, du kannst keinen Bereich definieren, den du dann einfach scrollen kannst. Und darum habe ich da so ein, jetzt, das heißt, jQuery-nested-touch, habe ich das genannt.
Aber es war auch eine gute Entscheidung, dass sie es so gemacht haben. Oder dieses Scrollen in Webseiten ist doch für einen Arsch.
Wenn man es gut einsetzt, ist es super.
Fenster? Weißt du mal nicht, da musst du in dem Bereich sein, wenn du scrollst, also auch hier gerade auf dem, wenn du mit so einem Wheel auf der Maus irgendwie scrollst, dann weißt du mal nicht, scrollt jetzt das Browser-Fenster oder der Inhalt von diesem Frame oder was auch immer. Also das ist immer so ein bisschen blöd. Man weiß nicht, wo man gerade so richtig ist. Also so Scroller in Scroller finde ich doof.
Ich finde das, ich finde das... Na, wenn beide scrollt, ist das natürlich doof. Also man müsste dann natürlich eine Seite machen, wo der äußere Rahmen nicht scrollt, sondern wir entsprechenden Bereiche scrollen. Liesse sich ja aber alles machen. Also das Apple da... Das Apple da so gar keine Möglichkeit für das Vorsied. Und es ist jetzt... Ich hab da auch wirklich, wirklich lange dran gesessen. Also dieses halbwegs hinzukriegen, wie das Apple macht, so mit diesem kinetischen, dass das weiter scrollt, wenn man... wenn man schon losgelassen hat und das, wenn man... wenn es am Rand ist, dass dann dieses Bouncen macht. Das hat auch ewig lange gedauert.
Und wieso, womit machst du das denn?
Na, komplett in JavaScript. Also ich nehme diese Touch-ARP und werte die aus und die bump dann. Und dann das absolut größte Problem war, dass wenn er dann gescrollt hat und du hast so irgendwie so einen Diff, dann ist natürlich Safari schlau und sagt sich, die Bereiche, die gerade nicht sichtbar sind, die render ich auch erst, wenn sie sichtbar wären. Das heißt, wenn du da so durch scrollst, dann flickert das die ganze Zeit ohne Ende. Weil er hat es halt eher berechnet, erst wenn er es braucht. Und das konnte ich dann, das heißt dann hat mich, ich weiß nicht, zwei Tage gekostet. Also ich hatte es zwischendurch schon aufgegeben und hab dann noch irgendwo nochmal eine Lösung gefunden. Ich hab es dann ehrlich gesagt bei der iPad-App von Gmail geklaut. Weil bei denen ist das nämlich so schön gelöst. Und das muss man nämlich mit einer 3D-Transformation machen. Also das ist jetzt quasi eine 3D-Webseite, die nur, ist leider ein bisschen höher, das ist noch nicht so optimiert.
Ich meine, wenn es jetzt schon nicht performt, wie soll es dann erst auf dem Kongress werden?
Ach, dann ist es offline.
Ja, das ist offline.
Das ist nur das W-Line hier.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das W-Line.
Wie gesagt, das wird ja auch mit Offline-Caching noch laufen.
Das ist eine Miegel-Nagel-Neue-Time-Capsule, die hier rumsteht.
Und legst du einfach mal, legst du einfach mal auf den Home-Screen und dann ist alles gut.
Ich hab so die Schnauze voll. Ich hab hier rumgebastelt, auch mit diesem blöden, mit dieser Fritz-Box.
Vielleicht solltest du aufhören, so viel rumzubasteln. Vielleicht solltest du einfach mal...
Haben wir denn noch Themenärzte?
Wenn ich nicht rumbastel, gibt es hier kein Internet. Also, erinnerst du dich nicht, was hier für ein permanentes Dauerproblem ist mit dem Netzzugang? Und ich werd wahnsinnig. Und jetzt hab ich irgendwie mehrere Geräte hintereinander ausprobiert, die alle irgendwie... fail ist. Ja, ich meine, bei der Fritz-Box kann ich jetzt so abschließend noch gar nicht sagen, was Sache ist. Allerdings hab ich interessante, interessantes Feedback bekommen von Leuten, die da etwas näher an der Entwicklung stecken. Und da hoffe ich, dass ich jetzt nächsten Tagen nochmal Zeit finde, mich da ein bisschen mit zu beschäftigen. Und vielleicht wird das ja nochmal was.
Mit dir und der Fritz-Box.
Aber man ist dann doch immer wieder schnell da, wenn man so diese Apple-Peripherie in Betrieb nimmt.
Das ist irgendwie echt schöner.
Vor allen Dingen.
Das ist echt einfach, das ist einfach immer wieder schön.
Es geht auch runter bis zu diesen komischen Display-Adaptern. Heute hat der, oder gestern hat ein Kollege von mir so einen Mini-Display-Port auf DVI-Adapter von irgendeinem Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises. Flo Chi Minh ist auch schön. Und selbst bei diesem Adapter, den haben die so hässlich und fest sich so scheiße an. Ich weiß nicht wieso, die Oberfläche ist so rau, keine Ahnung. Es ist grau und keine Ahnung. Und dann hast du diesen Adapter von Apple, rund gelutscht, weiß und so. Das ist wirklich schöner, ja. Fest sich schöner an, hat irgendwie... Nee, glaube ich.
Ja, auch ordentliche Schrauben dran, die auch irgendwie richtig festziehen und halten und die auch so geriffelt sind, dass man sie mit der Hand auch wieder gelöst bekommt und dann ich irgendwie noch mal ein Tool brauche.
Echt, ist das mittlerweile so?
Früher waren die doch so rund auch.
Das hatten sie mal, aber ich glaube die letzten...
Nee, aber das ist schon so. Man guckt halt immer so die anderen Produkte an und denkt sich so, man, das ist doch alles nicht so schwer.
Und Apple ist auch nur in China produziert.
Das ist alles nur der Eve.
Achso, ich muss mich korrigieren. Ich meine halt, das ist ja hier sozusagen... Bei dem Teil sind es die Löcher. Aber es passt dann halt auch einfach alles. Wie auch immer. Wie lange nehmen wir eigentlich schon auf? Viel zu lange. 3 Stunden. Was?
Hab da nur ein Thema hier, ich mach alles.
Gib mir einfach zuwerfen, die brauchen.
Was hatte ich denn eigentlich noch geschrieben? War das schon Rastagreber?
Ja, deine Punkte sind schon abgearbeitet.
Ich hatte bestimmt noch irgendwas anderes mit.
Ja, wir hatten aber noch eins, was du noch erwähnt hast, das hatte ich auch auf der Liste. Ich weiß nicht ob wir da groß drüber reden können, aber der Heise-Verlag bringt jetzt endlich eine Macintosh-Zeitschrift raus.
Eine Zeitschrift gleich oder ist das eine reine Webseite?
Freezes over. Eine Zeitschrift. Das ist so ein Print?
Ja, das verstehe ich halt auch nicht genau.
Okay, ich verstehe das.
Macintosh, du sollst ein bisschen hinterher sind.
Nee, ich verstehe nicht, dass so Computer, dass überhaupt Print-Medien noch funktionieren, weil da sind doch die Nachrichten von gestern drin. Und bei Computer-Zeitschriften, die wöchentlich oder was? Alle zwei oder monatlich sogar erscheinen und dann mit so einer CD wo Software drauf ist.
Ja, aber es ist einfacher einen Überblick über diese ganzen Nachrichten zu bekommen, wenn du da einfach nur in Papier hin und her blätterst, als der Netz irgendwelche Quellen. Du, der du morgens um 16 Uhr wenn du aufstehst, erstmal deinen Mac-Surfer mit 30.000 Links abgrasen, die alle anklickst und durchliest und diesen ganzen Jargon auf verstehst.
Ich bin nicht hier der, der 25 Taps offen hat.
Du hast nur 25 Taps offen?
Ich hab gar keine Taps.
Max hat nur so viele Taps offen um den Kindern da draußen.
Genau, 33 jetzt.
Du bist ja so ein gut Mensch.
Aktuell sind es gerade 29, ich bin ärgerst davon.
Du solltest dir noch so rechts um so ein Plug-In noch so einblenden, live saved.
Du wirst den das Bundesverdienst-Tap verliehen bekommen.
Achievement.
Ihr macht Witze. Aber wenn Morph die Welt untergeht, ich bin da nicht dran schuld gewesen.
Du bist so ein Savior-Counter in Game Center, so ein Achievement. You unlocked an Achievement.
Man sollte Game Center überhaupt für Filmendinge nutzen, als bisher so getan wird.
Wie ist denn da die AP eigentlich?
Wenn Max nicht so viele Taps offen hätte, dann würde ihm 13 Zoll reichen.
Auf jeden Fall heise macht ne Zeitung. Und die kommt alle drei Monate raus, weil keiner weiß, was drinstehen wird.
Alle drei Monate?
Alle drei Monate viermal pro Jahr. Liebe Zeit. Naja, was haben sie bisher gemacht? Bisher haben sie dieses eine Special rausgebracht. Das ist jetzt in ihrer gesamten Geschichte als der führende Technologie-Zeitschriftenverlag in Deutschland die erste Publikation gewesen, die sich vollständig dem Mac widmet, soweit ich mich erinnern kann. Mir ist nicht bewusst, dass sie jemals irgendwas hatten, was sich direkt an den Mac gewinnt hat.
Aber ich weiß schon wieder, was das für eine Zeitschrift ist. Das ist so eine Zeitschrift für Leute, die sich gerade frische Mac gekauft haben. Die kaufen sich dann so eine Zeitung. Das erinnert mich damals. Kaufst du dir eine Mountainbike-Zeitschrift? Ist das so? Kaufst du dir eine neue Kamera? Gehst du erst mal los, kaufst du eine fucking Kamera-Zeitschrift? Oder kurz vorher, weil du dich informieren willst. Und alle Leute, die irgendwas neu haben, holen sich erst mal die passenden Zeitschriften dazu. Machst du einen Motorradführerschein, kaufst du erst mal ein paar Monate lang...
Bei den Zuwachsraten des Macintosh-Marktes ist das dann auch total naheliegend, dass man so eine Zeitschrift rausmacht, dass man sagen kann, alle drei Monate hast du schon wieder genauso viele Neukunden, wie du vorher insgesamt Kunden hattest.
Kann sein.
Aber du weißt schon, was ich meine?
Das ist die Zielgruppe, oder? Und so wird die Zeitschrift dann auch aussehen.
Wie aussieht ihr mit mir? Mir ist das doch egal. Ich finde das erst mal grundsätzlich gut.
Ich wollte das jetzt auch gar nicht so negativ meinen. Ich wollte nur sagen, es ist nichts für mich.
Ja, jetzt warst du so negativ, jetzt weint der Heise.
Na, dann kannst du doch vielleicht was schreiben, was du für einen Eindruck hast. Das Einzige, was zu bedauern ist, ist der neue Einsteiger auf ihrem Frischkaufenseil.
Die ZFS-Kolumne von Dennis Arndts.
Das Einzige, was ich vermissen werde, ist FSDKlog. Weil da ist nämlich jetzt nichts mehr los.
Ja, es dünnt etwas aus.
Die heiße Seite finde ich jetzt erst mal noch nicht so spannend. Also FSDKlog war irgendwie so kurz und knackig. Das war irgendwie so auf meinem Niveau.
Ja, und dieses heiße.de ist unläsbar.
Es ist gleich wieder so, als wenn ich ein Idiot wäre.
Textwisse und...
Idiot?
Ja, das ist immer alles so doppelt und dreifach erklärt und so hmmm, also zu viel. Zu viel, was die alles gar nicht wissen. Ich brauche irgendwie die... Technical Summary, also so, genau.
Mach nochmal das Geräusch.
Stimmt, aber ich meine, in dem Blogpost hat der Leo irgendwie, also da war irgendwie kein Wort zu viel. Aber auch keins zu wenig.
Genau, und wenn du wissen wolltest, hast du halt draufgeklickt. Und bei Heise, ich glaube, die haben auch immer gar nicht so richtig Links, oder? Und werden dann natürlich in allen Artikeln von vorher.
Nein, das war bei Spiegel immer so.
Ein Tim und Max Agreement Achievement.
Ich glaube, jetzt wird das Universum aufzuexistieren.
Okay, ich akzeptiere, dass das jetzt nicht so ein tragendes Thema ist, aber dass man drei Stunden diskutieren kann. Aber ich finde es zumindest schon mal bemerkenswert, dass bei Heise die Erkenntnis gereift ist, dass es sich auch mal lohnt, über irgendwas zu schreiben, was nicht mit dem Fixen der Registry und dem Neuen installieren von Windows XP zu tun hat.
Oder das Kapär, das wieder einen Bug hat.
Diese CT hätten sie doch auch Windows Missing Manual nennen können.
Das war schon mehr.
Ich extrahiere doch mal Windows aus der CT. Dann hast du noch deinen Prozessor geflüstert und dann?
Festplattenkarussell.
Die Hand schon.
Aber das war doch die coolste Sache, oder? Prozessor geflüstert und Festplattenkarussell.
An dem Tag, wo Windows wirklich benutzbar und einrichtbar und konfigurierbar und installierbar wird, geht auch der halbe Zeitschriftenmarkt pleite.
Bevor es jetzt soweit ist mit Windows 8 an demnächst oder jetzt schon mit Windows 7, selbst Dennis benutzt es ja schon, machen sie noch rasch eine Mac-Zeitschrift. Das ist eigentlich nur konsequent.
Das ist ein mutiger Schritt, die haben sich geguckt, irgendwie der Mac-Markt wird größer, da gibt es mehr Einsteiger. Einsteiger sind Leute, denen wir unsere Zeitung verkaufen können, also da kloppen wir mal rein in die Lüge.
Ich lese den Heise News-Ticker sehr gerne nach wie vor.
Den Mac-News-Ticker oder den normalen?
Den normalen.
Ja, den lese ich auch. Der ist ja auch okay.
Und den Mac-News-Ticker, also dieses Mac&I, das habe ich mir jetzt mit abonniert. Ich finde das liest man nach wie vor, dass das Leo ist.
Ja, aber das ist so viel Text, das ist mehr als vorher.
Ach Gott, das ist jetzt so iBooks 1 und 2, das sind zwei Absätze, das kann man alles machen. Abgesehen davon hat Leo jetzt endlich mal, ich glaube, der kann jetzt mal davon leben, wie er sich ganz zuvor relativ mühsam nur ernährt hat. Mühsam ernährt sich das Eichhörnchen. Ja, sei ihm das mal gegönnt.
Aber CT finde ich wirklich schlimm und die EX auch.
CT lese ich seit Ewigkeit nicht mehr.
Ja, aber wenn er vorher noch einen Flatter-Button gemacht hat, also entweder werde ich jetzt hier genug geflattert oder ich gehe zu CT.
Vielleicht macht er den nächsten Button entweder flattert jetzt oder ich komme nicht wieder.
FSK-Log dünnt aus.
Ja klar, dünnt das aus.
Das dünnt aus. Wenn er Freizeit hat, ist er bei Bits und so. Ist er jetzt?
Nicht bei uns?
Die letzten Sendungen war er immer bei Bits und so dabei.
Der war bei Bits und so?
Ernsthaft?
Der fährt extra nach München?
Die verteilen sich ja gerade über die ganze Welt. Der Alex ist in Finnland.
Also lösen die sich jetzt doch auf?
Nein.
Sie verteilen sich nur über die Welt.
Ja. Das distributed.
Als mit Kanada und so.
Weil sonst würde der Tim den ganzen Lebkuchen kriegen und wir würden da im Stadion zu gucken. Das geht ja immer gar nicht.
Die sind ja auch viel georteter als wir. Die reden nicht durcheinander.
Die haben auch Themen.
Die schreien nicht.
Die lesen einfach vom Blatt ihr Skript ab.
Die haben aber eine Sache, die die nicht haben.
Kiklar oder so.
Oder Flash.
Das haben die nicht.
Und jetzt haben wir gerade 200 Hörer verloren. Die anderen sofort.
Aber ich wurde gerade von Bits und Zooms korrigiert, dass nämlich die Audio-Streams beim HTTPS-Streaming sehr wohl auch MP3 sein können.
Wie die sind jetzt bei uns auch.
Die hören unsere Sendung, kupfern die uns ab.
MP3 aber dann auch wiederum in diesem Spion-Spiel.
Muss das auch in diesem TS sein?
Audio-only-Streams-can-be-serious-of-MP3-elementary-audio-files-format?
Ich kann es aus diesem einen Satz leider nicht korrekt herleiten, wie es auch sein kann, aber es geht wohl auch mit MP3. Ich weiß gar nicht, hatte ich das gesagt, dass das nicht geht? Ich hab nur gesagt, dass ich das nicht wollte.
Du hast gesagt, dass Firefox eine, was?
Fortschritts-Verhinderung ist.
Das bittet sich ja hier auf Streaming, vermutlich, weiß ich nicht, der Kontext fehlt hier so ein bisschen. Ja, Firefox ist Fortschritt-Verhinderung.
Aber dann könnte man doch, wenn sie das können, dann könnte man doch in Flash einen HTTP-Streaming klein schreiben.
Mit diesem JavaScript-Audio ist jetzt nicht diese Cram-Cheft-JavaScript-Engine einfach schnell genug, um das MP3 und MP4 direkt im Browser zu dikonen.
Cram-Cheft, das heißt Cacheft.
Es gibt Nintendo Game Boy Emulator, es gibt alles Mögliche, emuliert jetzt schon in JavaScript. Warum könnt ihr nicht eigentlich Audio direkt dikonen?
Hier Herrle, man, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr ihn kennt.
Du kennst ihn auf dem Audio-Kanal, oder?
Der ist aber auf mich zugekommen und hat mir erzählt, dass er einen Video-Dekoder, also und zwar einen Diff-X-Dekoder in JavaScript schreiben möchte, damit es auf dem iPad läuft. Das war so sein Ansatz. Da hab ich gesagt, bold move. Na, ein Video-Dekoder, also ein Videokodec quasi. Ich sag jetzt einfach mal, ich glaub es war Diff-X, kann aber auch sein, dass er MKV gesagt hat, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, MKV ist kein Enkoder und Diff-X ist mp4. Das kann der schon. Die Besser-Wisser sind jetzt wieder ganz voll.
Jetzt leg doch mal hier die Zeitung an.
Ich wollte hier mal gucken, ob in der CT was für mich ist. Ich hab mir mal eine gekauft.
Ach du liebe Zeit.
Ich muss ja schon noch sagen, dass die CT schon noch die coolste Computer-Zeitung ist, die es so gibt, oder?
Ich find die so ätzend.
Kennst du aber eine bessere?
Nee, die sind alle ätzend.
Ja, aber die ist mit Abstand am wenigsten ätzend.
Na ja, okay, das ist besser als Markt und Technik und Data-Bäcker-Handy-Wohnung.
Aber die Computer-Bild, hallo?
Also die CT ist eigentlich schon noch ganz okay, finde ich. Auch wenn ich sie jetzt schon seit 1000 Jahren nicht mehr gelesen hab, aber ich fand die früher okay.
Ich find's ja ein bisschen...
Und da waren manchmal schon coole Artikel drin.
Die haben nach wie vor auch coole Artikel drin. Ich meine, die machen so zu dieser ganzen sensuoserer Debatte, zu diesem Kontrollverlust-Street hier und so was. Da sind die ja auch immer, die probieren ja auch immer... Da ist ein bisschen. Also ist jetzt nicht extrem viel, aber ich glaube, die ahnen immer noch, oder bilden sich immer noch ein, dass sie auch eine gewisse gesellschaftliche Verantwortung hätten. Und dann finde ich das gut, dass sie das machen.
Also ich würde sagen, das einzige Problem an der CT ist, ist, dass es halt print ist. Weil die sind einfach, was da drin steht, ist einfach für mich nicht mehr aktuell. Ansonsten finde ich, fand ich eigentlich immer okay.
Ja, aber nee, eigentlich ist das auch immer so, du liest halt so einen Artikel über irgendwas. Und da gab es auch mal so einen Artikel über die neue Mac OS X und so. Und das ist immer nur so der Anfang. Du denkst dir so, okay, jetzt blätter ich um. Und jetzt kommen die juicy Details.
Ja, aber du bist auch schon so voll eingetaucht ins IT-Business. Da ist natürlich alles nicht mehr so spannend.
Also es hängt immer sehr davon ab, es gibt Zeiten, da haben sie, es gibt manche, du hast absolut recht, da sind sie gerade so an der Oberfläche von irgendeiner Sache. Ich hab allerdings auch schon echt viele Themen gehabt, wo so die CT es geschafft hat, zu dem Thema wirklich ein ziemlich, also natürlich ein Einsteiger, aber ein ziemlich umfassendes Einsteigerwissen zu vermitteln, sodass man erstmal alle Quellen hat, um jetzt so richtig einzutauchen. Und wo diese ganzen Blog-Artikel, die dann so irgendwie das Detail, und dann schreibt da wieder jemand mal zweieinhalb Seiten Tutorial und so, wo dies einfach nicht gebracht haben, aber wo die CTs geschafft hat, wirklich einen guten, übersichtlichen Artikel zu schreiben.
Ja, also es ist bestimmt auch für viele Leute gut, aber ich, ja, wie gesagt, also immer wenn so diese Reise, also immer wenn so eine große Headline vorne drauf war, und ich mir dachte, okay, das interessiert mich jetzt wirklich mal, und ich kaufe mir mal diese Zeitschrift, habe ich diesen Artikel gelesen, dachte mir, und jetzt?
Jetzt gibt es das, haben wir das bisher wirklich noch gar nicht erwähnt, dass es die CT jetzt fürs iPad gibt? Im App Store? Ich hab sie mir leider noch nicht genau mal angeguckt. Ich wollte sie mir noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter angucken. Das könnte ich ja fast wieder spannend finden.
Da sieht man mal, was für ein absteigender Ast dieser PC-Markt ist, ne?
Wie das?
Nein, keine Ahnung. Ja, sie haben ja auch die Sicherheit von iPhone-Anwendungen, beim Banking.
Ach stimmt, da haben sie...
Externe Festplatten am Mac.
Hast du wirklich die CT?
Ja, was ist los? Da ist es was passiert, Leute. Ich glaub, die haben jetzt auch alle Macs.
Na, ich glaub auch.
Die Redaktion hat jetzt einfach alle Macs.
Das ist auch krass, ich mein, so die Nerds, selbst so die Hardcore-Mac-Hasser-Nerds, ja, die kaufen sich jetzt alle einen Mac, weil sie die Hardware geiler finden.
Ja, das Macbook erster, wie der nächste Schritt.
Jetzt mal Nerd geflüstert, weißt du, wer sich dem nächsten Mac, also wer sich überlegt, einen Mac zu kaufen, kommst du nie drauf. Nee, Pfeffer noch nicht. Was heißt schon wieder?
Macht er doch schon ewig und irgendwas fällt immer ein, dass es irgendwie doch nicht das war.
Ja, aber letztens hab ich ihn total gehören.
Ja, aber diese Lenovo-Hardware, die sind ja immer weniger zufrieden, Jungs. Und das war ja früher immer so, dass sie alle hier IBM gekauft haben.
Ja, kommt alle in unser Reich. Hier ist es schön.
Na, da wird da kein Mac OS drauf fahren.
Raus. Doch, ach, glaube ich schon sogar.
Nee, glaube ich nicht. Nein, hat er nicht seine Tools. Hat er.
Hat er mehr als auf dem Linux.
Der Pfeffer kann.
Natürlich, schon ewig.
Nein, der hat dann Windows, Mann. Er fährt doch manchmal Linux, aber der Switch zwischen Windows und Linux.
T-Man, T-Man, T-Man, die Sendung geht aus dem Motor. Ich kann euch ein schönes iPhone-App vorstellen.
Also wir sind hier so ein bisschen gägge, gogo, tra la fitti.
Ja, es ist ja auch fast schon Weihnachten.
Und wir sind ja auch high von diesen Lebkuchen, die Gebürze.
Wir haben überhaupt keine schöne Hardware empfohlen, was die Leute nicht so unter den Weihnachtsbaum legen sollen.
Diesen Helikopter, diesen Ding, den AR-Dron.
Und diesen Logic Analyzer, das fanden ja gleich mal ein paar Leute total toll. Fand ich ja schön, dass auch so ein paar Elektronik-Bastler hier zuhören.
Die AR-Dron? Findest du die so empfehlenswert?
Keine Ahnung, ich hatte noch die eine.
Also ein Kumpel hat mich ja auch gefragt, er will mal wieder als Bastel, meinte, wie sieht es denn aus mit Quadcopter, dann hab ich auch gesagt, na das Basteln macht Spaß und dann lässt du ihn einmal fliegen und dann ist es langweilig. Es ist so wie mit Eisenbahn, früher, du baust ja auf, das macht Spaß, dann fährst du mit der Eisenbahn einmal im Kreis und dann ist es langweilig.
Oder Autoverfahr.
Also was willst du mit so einem Quadcopter machen? Also ich meine, hä?
Na in die Fenster von deinen Nachbarn rein-spionieren. Du wohnst im Erdgeschoss, da hast du nicht viel Spielraum.
Aber die sind doch alle verpieselt, die Fenster.
Ach, mir würde da schon so einiges einfallen. Aber ich bin nicht so der Basteltyp. Also ich bin einfach...
Ja, aber angenommen, ich geb dir jetzt hier so einen Quadrocopter schon fertig gebaut. Was würdest du mit dem machen?
Einen Lieferdienst aufbauen. Ich sag das total cool, wenn so Pizza per Quadrocopter geliefert werden würde.
Ja, ist zu schwer, kannst du vergessen.
Was ich damit machen wollen würde?
So rumfliegen. Obwohl, okay, die Leute gehen auch mit dem Drachen auf den Berg und lassen ihn fliegen, aber okay, das ist noch was anderes, weil das muss man erst mal managen.
Ja, also mit Kindern ist Quadrocopter schon was geiles, ja.
Ja, wenn er nicht wegfliegt beim Drachen.
Aber so fliegendes Auge, beziehungsweise so Luftbilder. Das find ich schon interessant. Da kennen auch Leute, die das machen.
Demnächst.
Ja, da kennen wir ja alle. Und da war es ja vielleicht auch noch cool, aber jetzt macht es ja auch wirklich schon wieder jeder, und dann ist es schon auch nicht mehr so spannend. Man kann leicht, nicht mehr so... Google Drone View.
Also so viele Leute, die wirklich gute Luftbilder mit Quadrocopter machen, da kenn ich aber nicht so viele. Genau einen. Und meine ich richtig.
So einfach und richtig.
Na gut, genau Software und Hardware und die Kamera, die richtig hängt und so weiter. Nicht irgendwas, was rumfliegt und ein Bild von unten machen kann. Sondern was du so, wo du dich an so ein Feld steckst und sagst, hier, von da bis da, GPS da und da. Und dann fliegt das Teil irgendwie ab und stitcht die Bilder schön zusammen. Und dann passt das auch und dann hast du das irgendwie in amtlicher Auflösung. Das nenne ich Luftbilder. Dass du also wirklich mal so einen Bereich Heires hast. Aber dann brauchst du wahrscheinlich langfristig auch irgendwie so die Anwendung für den ganzen Kram. Kannst du natürlich als Dienstleistung machen, aber dann hast du auch nichts anderes zu tun als das. Aber ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne Bastelnummer. Aber diese AR-Drohnen, naja, also ich weiß nicht. Das ist schon ein beeindruckendes Teil. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass so Version 2 oder 3 rockt, aber das Ding hat ja auch echte Macken. Ein Freund von mir ist das Teil gleich weggeflogen. Nee, das hat wohl offensichtlich wirklich so einen Bug, dass das Teil irgendwie so ein bisschen die Orientierung verdient. Die haben ja auch so, ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Designentscheidung war. Das Teil hat ja so Ultraschall-Sensoren zur Höhenmessung. Und das scheint doch sehr fehleranfällig zu sein, das Prinzip. Weil, weißt du, es fliegt über irgendwas rüber, dann hast du da eine kurze Erhöhung, eine Mauer, irgendwas und wumm. Und auf jeden Fall am Anfang, das war wohl mit vielen erst ausgelieferten Modellen, so wie keine Ahnung, ob es immer noch so ist, die Dinger sind einfach weggeflogen. Da gibt es diverse Videos davon. Wie gesagt, ein Freund von mir, das ist auch passiert, das Teil ist dann irgendwie in der Volksbühne einfach, einfach weg, einfach in den Himmel. Und er hatte dann irgendwie noch so ein paar Fotos, so Screenshots, wo er irgendwie Berlin von oben.
Und das war's, tschüss!
Das ist schon cool, du kannst es halt mit so einem iPad steuern und so, das geht alles schon in die richtige Richtung. Das ist schon so ein bisschen auch das Next-Generation-Toy, keine Frage. Aber mir gefiel das Hardware-technisch. Das ist einfach nicht stabil genug. Das ist einfach nicht so die Hardware, die ich mir so vorstelle.
Aber ich mein, vielleicht könnten wir jetzt einfach hier in die Runde rumgehen. Was wünschen wir uns zu Weihnachten für Gadgets?
Ich will MacBook Pro updaten, welchen Happi ich zahle auch.
Was wünsche ich mir für Gadgets? Ja, ist echt eine gute Frage. Ich wünsche mir Audiotechnik. Ich hätte gerne so ein Gerät, das es nicht gibt. Das trifft mich immer wieder hart.
Dass es Geräte nicht gibt, die du brauchst?
Ja, es gibt so verschiedene Geräte, die alle irgendwie im Prinzip schon mal in die richtige Richtung gehen, aber jedem fehlt irgendwas. Und das ist so ein bisschen mein persönliches Drama. Audio-Bereich ist knifflig.
Mit diesen traurigen Worten lassen wir jetzt die Zuhörer in ihrem Ledersessel zurück, verabschieden uns ins nächste Jahr.
Schwenken noch einmal den Konyak vor dem Kamin, hören.
Harry, fahr schon mal den Wagen vor.
Den Schnee, leise schneiden, schneidest du bestimmt, oder?
Ja, ist alles dicht.
Alle dicht.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr ein. Fällt dem Chat noch etwas ein? Wir sind durch, ihr hört es doch schon.
Ja, das Jahr ist zu Ende gleich und wir sind auch total durch. Wir brauchen jetzt erstmal fett.
Das Jahr ist zu Ende und wir sind auch schon fertig.
WikiLeaks.
Gibt es das jetzt auch aufs iPad?
Ja, nein, ja nein, WikiLeaks, ja nein. Was wollt ihr denn wissen, WikiLeaks? Was soll ich sagen?
Sollen wir vorlesen?
Weiß nicht. Gibt es da WikiLeaks aus der Macintosh Perspektive?
Das ist der falsche Podcast.
Das könnte man eigentlich mal raussuchen. Wenn ihr da draußen seid, suchen wir einfach mal nach Mac und Windows, wo das denn auftaucht und lesen alles vor, was es zu dem Thema gibt.
Bestimmt. Ich werde Montag bestimmt mit Holgi noch ein bisschen über WikiLeaks reden.
Wie viele Diktatoren sind mit iPhones bestochen worden? Bestimmt einige.
Diktatoren?
Hier, guck mal, hier kriegst du ein iPhone und dann lässt du dazu, dass wir da unsere Fabrik hinbauen oder so was.
Ami Genijet hat bestimmt kein iPhone. Der fährt Windows, Mobile, 65.
Ich hab mal gehört, dass Kim Jong-il einen Großteil seiner Macht auf dem regelmäßigen Verteilen von iPods aufbaut. Natürlich auch noch Autos und so, aber auch iPods.
Hier wollen noch Leute FPGA und sonst was updaten. Ich hab jetzt einen FPGA, aber ich hab noch nicht benutzt, weil ich überhaupt keine Zeit hätte, weil ich von Tumblr wegmigrieren musste und mir einen WordPress konfigurieren musste. Hab mir einen 4x4 Cube gelötet und so, aber das blogge ich auch alles.
Warum löst du nicht einfach mal diesen 10x10 Cube bevor du jetzt schon mit FPGA die nächste Dings anstarten willst?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Aber ich will ja erstmal den 4x4 Cube, um zu testen, ob der Arduino vielleicht doch schnell genug ist. Aber ich hab eigentlich schon rausgefunden, dass er nicht schnell genug ist.
Also ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt hier kein Gadget-Feuerwerk mehr, weil uns fällt nichts ein.
Genau, seid doch einfach mal so unter dem Weihnachtsbaum.
Seid einfach glücklich. Kauft euch nichts.
Hört alle Podcast-Folgen aus diesem Jahr.
Die neuen MacBook Airs sind schon schick. Genau.
Ich nehm zwei.
Ansonsten bedanken wir uns auf jeden Fall für die tolle Unterstützung, insbesondere in den letzten Monaten. Ich denke, das hat auch was ausgemacht, dass wir hier häufiger gesendet haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es auch ausgemacht haben, dass wir so lange sind. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum sind wir so lange.
Weil es Spaß macht.
Falls du immer über Firefox Herz siehst.
Immer.
Immer ich.
Hier kommen halt mal Leute auf den Sack, die sonst nie auf den Sack kriegen.
Ja, muss auch sein. Genau.
Oder Projekte, sagen wir mal, Projekte.
Genau. Aber wir bauen das ja auch noch auf. Ich will auf jeden Fall dieses Streaming. Also vielleicht noch mal zu dem Thema, gute Vorsätze fürs nächste Jahr und viel versprechen zu wollen. Aber was eigentlich mal echt toll wäre, denke ich, ist so, wir haben hier so einen Bildschirm, so ein Mac, der so das, worüber wir uns gerade unterhalten, wenn es das im Internet gibt. Und das ist ja häufig der Fall.
Wenn wir das mit der Gesammelte Pizza-Bestellung hinkriegen, dann müsste man es ja auch mal damit hinkriegen.
Ja, genau. Ich würde halt gerne dieses Streaming machen und jede Lösung, die mir das irgendwie erlaubt, dieses Screencasting mit Video, iPhone-kompatibel ins Web zu kriegen. Wenn es das gibt, dann mach ich das auch.
Sag mal mal, welche Streaming-Software du da jetzt hattest.
Wenn, wo?
Dieses HTTP-Audio-Streaming auf die Festplatte drauf. Ich würde das gerne mal haben.
Ja, das ist so ein kleines Tool. Das ist irgendwo so ein Blog verborgen.
Das gibt es in den Links.
Soll ich mal im Internet suchen?
Link in den Sendungen. Ja, ja. Der wird wahrscheinlich ganz böse sein, dass ich das verlinke, weil es irgendwie alles halbfertiger Kram ist. Oh mein Gott. Aber ja.
Was halbfertiges im Internet.
Aber jetzt hab ich gesagt, sehr buggy.
Besser als dieses...
Ja, also das würde ich gerne machen. Dann können wir mal überlegen, ob wir hier noch so ein paar andere Format-Anreicherungen machen. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht mal Leute einladen oder so. Anruf?
Ich finde es schon gut so. Macht schon Spaß.
Okay, aber das mit dem Bildschirm machen wir. Und mit dem Streamen machen wir.
Vielleicht, ja. Also was ich hier vielleicht noch gut finde, wenn... Also jetzt so Dennis zum Beispiel, der guckt jetzt gerade schon wieder irgendwo ganz woanders hin und hört auch gar nicht so richtig zu, wahrscheinlich.
Doch.
Und das passiert ja allen hier so, ne? Also da könnte man glaube ich noch... Ja genau. Da könnte man glaube ich noch, also wenn man da so ein bisschen...
Ja, das liegt ja in diesen Laptops.
Alle aus dem Fenster schmeißen.
Ja, aber die brauchen wir jetzt zum Chatten. Und zum nochmal nachforschen.
Aber wenn wir einen großen Beamer haben, wo der Chat mitläuft, weil ihr wollt ja mitchatten, ne?
Natürlich. Muss ja unseren Sämpfte abgeben. Also ich meine, wir ziehen ja auch schon ein bisschen Infos daraus, der ist schon ganz hilfreich manchmal. Weil wir können ja nicht alles recherchieren hier und wir wissen ja auch nicht alles...
Wir können ja auch nicht alles recherchieren. Wir haben ja immer nur zwei Wochen zwischen den Sendungen.
Das Recherchieren ist das, als ich die zwei Wochen dazu zusammen zur Aufruf holen.
Der Double Check.
Hört auf Huckel, das war immer meine Lösung.
Genau, darum können wir auch nicht über WikiLeaks reden. Da fehlt uns einfach die zweite Quelle.
Ich hab noch Verbindungen zum Hörervolk.
Das ist gut.
Ich hab mir da gerade im Chat zugetragen.
Das ist gut. Ja, und ich werd mir so ein iPad 3G kaufen, wenn es in neu kommt.
Ich krieg jetzt ein neues Notebook.
Da bin ich auf jeden Fall dabei. Und mit dem R...
Dass wir da kein 3G drin haben.
Ja, dass wir das nicht drin haben. Das ist so... Das ist echt so... Also, naja, wie auch immer. Aber für viele Leute ist das glaub ich schon...
Wir können hier auch noch Stunden weitermachen.
Das ist ganz gut.
Was ist noch so?
Ich finde übrigens die Sprachsteuerung beim iPhone gut.
Ich auch.
Genau. Noch ein Hinweis. Vielleicht noch mal direkt ein Hinweis bei Flatter. Da gibt es ja jetzt diese tolle Subscription-Möglichkeit. Wer also Lust hat, uns hier zu unterstützen, denn es unterstützt das wirklich und tatsächlich.
Genau, wir kriegen nämlich Sushi dann von Tim bezahlt oder andere Nahrungsmittel um hier überhaupt.
Oder so Clubbesuche in einer näheren Umgebung.
Also wir sind ja nicht so kommerziell.
Manchmal gehen wir auch in Puff und so.
Das machst du vielleicht. Weihnachtsfeiern. Aber wir sind ja nicht so kommerziell wie andere Podcasts. Also wir verdienen hier nichts. Tim gibt uns ein Essen aus.
Wir müssen sogar ausholen.
Ich nehme euch von der Kette für vier Stunden.
Genau.
Was hier schon an Arbeitsausfällen hätten, dann hätten wir so ein Glaubchen.
Okay, alles ist gesagt.
Noch mal auf die Tränendrüse gedrückt.
Genau, das gehört sich auch zum Weihnachten.
Heugi kriegt immer noch Gyros.
Das war's. So richtig Tschüss sagen kann ich auch noch, nicht der Trennungsschmerz.
Twinkie, Twinkie.
Bisser? Wir machen ja keine Sendung mehr. Das wär jetzt die erste gewesen. Eigentlich hatten wir sozusagen noch in der letzten Woche wäre jetzt noch vom Dezember eine, oder?
Auf dem Kongress kannst du eine machen, wenn du willst.
Wir machen jetzt zwischen den Jahren definitiv keine Sendung.
Deswegen jetzt ja eben.
Du musst eben mit Sonnenbrill über den Kongress laufen, sonst kommst du da nicht mehr raus aus dem Quatsch.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage.
Ja, aber genau, das ist die nächste Sendung. In vier Wochen?
Gucken wir mal. Januar... Bleiben wir mal im Mittwoch?
Ja, bitte. Und bitte nicht hin und her wechseln. Mit diesem Donnerstag nach Mittwoch.
Und wir brauchen einen neuen Namen bis zum nächsten Jahr, finde ich auch. Genau. Der Chat hat echt...
Also der 5.
5.
5. Januar scheint mir relativ realistisch zu sein. Das ist in drei Wochen. Das ist doch noch eine entspannte Auszeit.
Ja, nach dem Kongress, genau. Oder?
Dann sind wir doch schon wieder halbwegs auf.
So heute ist welcher? Der...
15.
15. In zwei Wochen ist der 29., das Fett Kongress. Dann ist danach der 5., also in drei Wochen, oder?
gesagt?
Das meinte ich mit dieser Aufmerksamkeit.
Das ist zumindest ein Mittwoch.
Ja, müsste gehen.
Dann sind wir uns ja einig.
Jetzt reicht's aber auch.
Ja, dann sagen wir Tschüss.
Wer kann den jungen Popularen vergessen?